ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORA NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ACOSTA AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
ALLEN ARAMBULA.
BAKER [inaudible]
BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
[inaudible]
BONTA BROUGH.
BURKE CABALLERO CALDERON
CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU.
CHAVEZ CHEN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI KANSEN CHU [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY DALY
EGGMAN FLORA.
FONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GRAY.
GRAYSON HARPER HOLDEN IRWIN
JONES SAWYER.
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE KILEY LACKEY
LEVINE LIMON LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY
MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
QUIRK QUIRK SILVA REYES BRIEF US
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
START STEINORTH STONE.
THURMOND.
TING VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY. TO PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER.
THE DAYS PRAYER.
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN REVEREND BOB OSHITA.
REMOVED.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
BUILDING THE FOUNDATION OF
CHARACTER BEGINS EARLY.
I FEEL IT BEGINS WITH PARENTS
AND WITH THE ADULT ROLE MODELS
IN OUR CHILDREN'S LIVES.
FEEDS OF INTEGRITY AND
RESPONSIBILITY ARE PLANTED EARLY
IN LIFE.
AND IF NURTURED THEY WILL TAKE
ROOT.
AND GROW DEEP INTO THE HEARTS
AND MINDS OF OUR CHILDREN.
ONCE WHILE LIVE READER OF A
CADET GIRL SCOUT TROOP AT OUR
TEMPLE.
MY WIFE PATTY SHARED AN INCIDENT
THAT OCCURRED.
DURING A PLANNED FRIDAY NIGHT
ACTIVITY.
THE PLAN WAS FOR THE GIRLS TO
BAKE LEMON BARS.
AFTER EXAMINING THE RECIPE THE
WEEK BEFORE.
EACH GIRL CHOSEN ONE INGREDIENT
THAT THEY WOULD BRING.
THAT EVENING THE GIRL SURVIVED
EXCITED TO BE THEIR COLLECTIVE
TREAT.
BUT THE ONE GIRL WHO AGREED TO
BRING THE LEMONS ARRIVED EMPTY
HANDED.
THEN WITHIN NONCHALANT SHRUG
JUST SAID. OH I FORGOT THE
LEMONS.
PATTY SAID.
THERE WAS ABSOLUTE SILENCE
[inaudible]
I ASKED.
WHAT DID YOU DO?
HE SAID NOTHING.
SHE EXPLAINED THAT IT WAS
OBVIOUS THAT THIS YOUNG GIRL WAS
ACCUSTOMED TO BE BEING BAILED
OUT BY THAT ADULTS AROUND HERE.
SHE WAS EXPECTING ONE OF THE
LEADERS TO SAY WELL THAT'S OKAY
I'LL GO I'LL GO GET SOME.
INSTEAD PATTY ALLOWED THE GROWTH
TO FUEL THEIR SHARED
DISAPPOINTMENT.
THEN SHE ASKED.
WELL.
WE HAVE NO LIMITS SO GIRLS WHAT
CAN WE DO WITH THE INGREDIENTS
WE HAVE.
THE EXCITEDLY EXPLORE THE TEMPLE
KITCHEN AND FOUND A CAN OF
CINNAMON.
SO THE GROWTH EXPERIMENTED AND
ATTEMPTED TO MAKE.
BIG TO BAKE SENTIMENTS GUARE'S.
I WAS AMAZED AT HOW TOUGH MY
GENTLE WIFE COULD BE.
THEN SHE SAID.
BECAUSE I CARE ABOUT EACH OF MY
GIRLS.
THEY HAVE TO LEARN NOW.
THAT PEOPLE ARE DEPENDING ON
THEM.
AND IF THEY'RE GOING TO FAIL AND
LET PEOPLE DOWN LET IT BE NOW
WHEN THEY ARE YOUNG.
AND THAT THE FAILURE JUST BE NOT
REMEMBERING THE PROMISE LEMONS.
ALTHOUGH PATTY SHARED THIS WITH
ME OVER FIFTEEN YEARS AGO.
I WAS SO IMPRESSED WITH YOUR
LEADERSHIP VISION.
THAT I ADMIRE IT STILL.
BUILDING THE FOUNDATION A
CHARACTER BEGINS EARLY.
I FEEL IT BEGINS WITH PARENTS
AND WITH ADULT ROLE MODELS IN
OUR CHILDREN'S LIVES.
FEEDS OF INTEGRITY AND
RESPONSIBILITY ARE PLANTED EARLY
IN LIFE.
IT REQUIRES US TO TAKE OWNERSHIP
OF OUR MISTAKES AND GROW FROM
THEM.
IF THE SEEDS ARE NURTURED.
THEY WILL TAKE ROOT AND GROW
DEEP INTO THE YOUNG HEARTS AND
MINDS OF OUR CHILDREN.
AND HELPED THEM TO BECOME
LEADERS.
WHO LIVE WITH INTEGRITY?
AND BE WORTHY OF RESPONSIBILITY.
NOW MORE ME.
WITH KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOINASSEMBLY
MEMBER ACOSTA AS HE LEADS US IN
THE PLEDGE MISTER.
POLLUTING OUR FLY [inaudible] TO
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO MONDAY AUGUST
THIRTEENTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN
ASSEMBLY MET AT ONE PM AUDIBLE
KEVIN MULLIN SPEAKER PRO TEM
ASSEMBLY PRESIDING CHIEF PUT
DEDUCTIBLES AND AT THE DESK.
WE COULD COPY AND LUIS READING
THE ROLES CALLED ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MESSENGER CALDERON MOVES.
AND MS BAKER SECONDS OF THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THERE
ARE NO ABSENCES FOR TODAY'S
SESSION.
WE ARE MOVING TO PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS.
MISTER ARE CALDERON HERE
RECOGNIZE YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY WILL FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE AND ALLOW US IN THE
MEMBERS GABRIEL GALLAGHER BRO
AND THURMAN TO SPEAK ON IN
GERMAN AND MANY [inaudible]
TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
RETURN AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY SIX
GONZALEZ FRET FLETCHER TO
ENROLLMENT.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
MEMBERS PURSUANT.
TO ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY SEVEN
POINT.
TWO I AM RE THE FOLLOWING ITEMS
TO COMMITTEE.
ITEM NUMBER ONE PART ME ITEM
NUMBER.
EIGHTY NINE THIS IS ITEM EIGHTY
NINE AB.
SEVEN SIX SEVEN QUIRK SILVA. TWO
JOBS ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
THE ECONOMY.
ITEM NUMBER.
NINETY ONE AB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN PATTERSON TO THE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE.
ITEM NUMBER ONE HOW.
TO AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY
GRAYSON TO THE AGRICULTURE
COMMITTEE.
AND I NUMBER ONE TEN A. B..
THIRTY SIXTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MARK STONE TO THE HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
COMMITTEE
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING.
TO MOVED TO BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE.
WE HAVE LOTS OF BUSINESS BEFORE
THE ASSEMBLY TODAY.
MEMBERS PLEASE COME TO THE FLOOR.
AS SOON AS PRACTICABLE WE ARE
GOING TO BE TAKING UP ITEMS ON
THE SENATE THIRD READING.
PRIOR TO OF THAT WILL GO SENATE
PERMITS SECOND READING
[inaudible]
SECOND READING.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL TWELVE FORTY NINE
FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE TO TWELVE
FOR SIXTY FIVE NINE THIRTY NINE
BY NINETEEN AND SEVEN FIFTEEN
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ.
IN AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS THIS IS SENATE THIRD
READING.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM.
ONE THIRTY FOUR PASS AND RETAIN
ITEM.
ONE THIRTY FIVE WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE UP.
FILE ITEM.
ONE THIRTY SIX THIS IS S. B..
TWELVE FIFTY THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL TWELVE FIFTY BY
SENATOR BRADFORD AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO ELECTIONS.
MS BURKE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT S. B.
TWELVE FIFTY EIGHT STRAIGHT FORM
A WORD MEASURE THAT REINFORCES
EXISTING LAW.
AND FURTHER CLARIFIES THAT THE
DOMICILE OF A MEMBER OF THE
STATE LEGISLATURE U. S. CONGRESS
IS CONCLUSIVELY PRESUMED TO BE
THE ADDRESS WHERE THEY ARE
REGISTERED TO VOTE.
THIS SIMPLY THIS BILL SIMPLY
AIMS TO REMAIN.
CONCERNING OUR DOMICILE LOTS BY
ADDRESSING ANY UNCERTAINTY AND
GOV CLARIFYING THAT MEMBERS THAT
LIVE AT OTHER ADDRESSES OUTSIDE
THEIR DISTRICT BUT THESE
RESIDENTS WILL NOT AUTOMATICALLY
ESTABLISH THEIR DOMICILE.
THIS BILL IS THE PRODUCT OF MANY
MEETINGS WITH STAKEHOLDERS
MEMBER SENATE ELECTION
COMMITTEES AND HAS ZERO
OPPOSITION AND HAS RECEIVED
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT SIMPLY
PUT S. B. TWELVE FIFTY ALIGNS
WITH THE ORIGINAL INTENT OF OUR
CURRENT ELECTION CODE LAW.
AND RIGHTS COURTS THE LEGAL
CERTAINLY TO CLARIFY THE
DOMICILE OF LEGISLATURE I
REQUEST TONIGHT.
NAME IS VERY MISTER HARPER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS WHILE ATTEMPTING
TO CODIFY AN APPELLATE COURT
RULING FROM THE CASE OF FORMER
SENATOR ROD RIGHT SENATE BILL.
TWELVE FIFTY WILL ACTUALLY LEAD
TO MORE CONFUSION AND POSSIBLY
MISLEAD VOTERS.
THE LANGUAGE OF THIS BILL STATES
THAT A MEMBER MAY HAVE A RENT
ANOTHER RESIDENTS AT WHICH A
MEMBER HAS ITEMS OF PERSONAL
PROPERTY PAYS UTILITY BILL
RECEIVES MAIL.
OR REGISTERS A CAR BOAT MEMBERS
IT'S GONNA CAUSE A LOT OF
CONFUSION TO APPLY IN THE LAW
THAT A PERSON CAN BE A RESIDENT.
AT A HOUSE OF HIS FRIEND WHERE
HE PARKS HIS BOAT AND THEN USE
THAT VOTE TO CLAIM HE IS A
RESIDENT OF THE DISTRICT AND
THEREFORE CAN REPRESENTED IN THE
STATE LEGISLATURE.
WE KNEW IT WE DO NOT NEED A BILL
CLARIFYING EXISTING LAW WHEN
IT'S CLEAR THAT SERA RIGHTED
VIOLATED THE RULES BY NOT LIVING
IN THE DISTRICT AND WAS FOUND
GUILTY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR NO VOTE --
MISTER CALDERON STAGE POINT OF
ORDER MISTER SPEAKER IS
EXTREMELY LOUD ON THE FLOOR
RIGHT NOW.
IF THERE COME IS DOWN AND PLEASE
GIVE THEIR ATTENTION A RESPECTED
MEMBER STANDING UP TO SPEAK.
ON THIS BILL.
WELL THE POINT OF ORDER IS WELL
TAKEN MEMBERS PLEASE FIND HER
DESKS.
AND KEEP YOUR CONVERSATIONS TO A
MINIMUM.
AND PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION
TO MS RUBIO WHO WILL BE SPEAKING
ON THE MATTER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER ICED I STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
AYE A WOULD BE A VICTIM --
OF THE CURRENT LAW I AM A SINGLE
MOTHER OF TWO CHILDREN AND MY
KIDS GO TO SCHOOL IN SACRAMENTO.
I FLY BACK TO THE DISTRICT ON
THURSDAY NIGHT MY CHILDREN FLY
BACK HOME ON FRIDAY NIGHT AND WE
COME BACK ON SUNDAY BECAUSE MY
CHILDREN COULD GO TO SCHOOL HERE.
AND MY RESIDENCY WOULD BE QUITE.
I LIVE IN BOTTOM PARK AND MY
CHILDREN GO TO SCHOOL HERE AND
THE REASON THAT I CHOSE TO BRING
MY SCHOOL MY CHILDREN WAS
BECAUSE I DIDN'T WANT TO LEAVE
THEM WITH MY PARENTS.
I AM A SINGLE MOTHER.
AND I TAKE CARE OF MY CHILDREN
AND FOR ME THE BEST SITUATION IS
THAT MY KIDS ARE HERE WITH ME SO
THAT I CAN GO HOME TO THEM EVERY
NIGHT.
IF MY RESIDENCY IS QUESTIONED
UNDER THIS CURRENT LAW THEN I
WOULD HAVE TO LEAVE MY CHILDREN
WITH EITHER MY PARENTS ARE SOME
BABY SITTER IN THE DISTRICT SO
THAT I CAN COME TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND DO THE WORK.
SO THE REASON FOR THIS BILL IS
FOR PEOPLE LIKE ME WHO.
CHOSE TO BE RESPONSIBLE I BRING
MY CHILDREN WITH ME INSTEAD OF
LEAVING THEM WITH THE BABY
SITTER WITH MY PARENTS THIS DOES
NOT.
A AFFECT THE RESIDENCY
REQUIREMENTS IT LIKE THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER STATED THIS IS
ABOUT [inaudible]
QUITE FRANKLY.
WOMEN LIKE ME AND THIS BURKE I'M
SORRY MY COLLEAGUE FROM --
MARINA DEL REY THAT CHOOSE TO
BRING THEIR CHILDREN TO
SACRAMENTO THIS IS NOTHING MORE
THAN CODIFYING AND MAKING SURE
THAT THE SITUATION THAT IS
QUICKLY CHANGING IN THE
LEGISLATURE WERE MORE WOMEN THAT
ARE PURE AND WE TOOK CHOOSE TO
BRING OUR CHILDREN.
IS NOT QUESTION IN THE FUTURE
FOR THOSE REASONS MEMBERS I ASK
FOR A AYE VOTE.
MS GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
SORRY I THINK YOU MEMBERS AYE
RIFF RIGHTFULLY RISE IN
OPPOSITION. TO THIS BILL ON I
THINK THE CONCERNS BROUGHT UP BY
MY COLLEAGUE FROM BALDWIN PARK
ARE VERY VALID AND SOMETHING
THAT WE SHOULD LOOK INTO.
I THINK THAT THERE IS TIME --
AMBIGUITY THAT TIME ABOUT WHAT
IS PRESIDENCY MEAN I AND I THINK
THEIR SEMINAL WORK THAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE BUT I THINK THIS.
SETS THE BAR LITTLE TOO LOW THE
REALITIES OF A LOT OF IS THAT
THEY DON'T EXPERIENCE.
MY COMMUNITY IS A COMMUNITY THAT
HAS OFTEN BEEN USED AS A DUMPING
GROUND AS A WASTELAND.
MY COMMUNITY HAS HAD MEMBERS AT
DIFFERENT YOU.
BILLY DON'T RESIDE IN THE
DISTRICT THERE WHEN WE DON'T
RESIDE IN THE DISTRICT WE FORGET
ABOUT THE PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE
TO DEAL WITH EVERY DAY.
I HAVE BEEN THAT PERSON WHEN I
LEFT COLLEGE FOR COLLEGE I
DECIDED TO MINE I DON'T CARE
ABOUT THE LEAD ABOUT THE ARSENIC
ABOUT THE CHROMIUM.
SIX ABOUT THE DIESEL I DON'T
CARE ABOUT IS THINGS THAT LIVE
IN THE BUDGET BUT OUR COMMUNITY.
AND NORTH UNTIL I MOVE BACK BUT
ALL THOSE THINGS CAME BACK TO MY
REALITY AND IT BECAME A PRIORITY
FOR MYSELF AND FOR MY
CONSTITUENTS.
THE REALITIES OF MY CONSTITUENTS
CAN CHOOSE TO MOVE ANYWHERE ELSE
THE CAN AFFORD TO MOVE ANY I
LIVE ANYWHERE ELSE.
INSIDE THE BECAUSE WE LEGISLATE
ON EXPERIENCE WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE HERE
RESIDENCIA THAT WERE LIVING IN
THIS DISTRICT AND WE CAN'T MAKE
IT EASIER. TO SCRAPE THE LA I
THINK THAT MAKING SURE PARENTS
ARE ABLE TO DO A GOOD JOB AND
TAKE CARE THEIR KIDS INTO
CHOICES LIKE MY COLLEAGUE HAD TO
DO.
ARE THINGS WE SHOULD LOOK INTO
AND WHICH HE DEFTLY MIXERS HIS
PROTECTIVE TO HAVE THAT CHOICE I
JUST DON'T FEEL THAT THIS IS A
BILL THAT WAS IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
AND SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AND NOBLE.
THANK YOU MISS GARCIA SEEN NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM MS BURKE
YOU MAY CLOSE.
THIS BILL DOESN'T CHANGE THE
DOMICILE RULES OR LAWS IT
CLARIFIES AND AS A MEMBER HERE
WHO IS A SINGLE MOM.
WHO DOES CHOOSE TO BRING HER
CHILD HERE WITH HER WORK
BUDDHISTS WHO FEELS LIKE SHE'S A
GOOD LEGISLATOR BECAUSE SHE
LOVES OUR COMMUNITY NOT BECAUSE
SHE DOESN'T GET TO BE THERE
MONDAY THROUGH THURSDAY?
MY MOM FOR OVER FORTY YEARS AGO
HAD TO DECIDE WHETHER SHE STAYED
IN CONGRESS OR WHETHER SHE
SHOULD BE A MOTHER.
I WILL NOT ALLOW MY DAUGHTER TO
HAVE TO MAKE THOSE CHOICES.
AS THE SECOND IS OF ONLY ONE
MOTHER AND DAUGHTER WHO HAVE
WORKED IN THIS.
FOR THERE IS NO REASON WHY WE
CANNOT MAKE PROGRESS I LOVE MY
HOME.
I LOVE LIVING IN ONLY I LOVE
LIVING IN ENGLAND IN MARINA DEL
REY.
BUT I LOVE WHAT I DO HERE.
AND I LOVE BEING PART OF THIS
BODY.
AND THE FACT THAT THERE IS NOT
CLEAR OCCASION THAT I CAN BE A
MOTHER AND A LEGISLATOR IS
UNJUST.
AND I WILL NOT STAND FOR IT THIS
IS NOT ABOUT ROD RIGHT THIS IS
ABOUT ME THIS IS ABOUT MY MOTHER
AND THIS IS ABOUT MY DAUGHTER.
AND THIS IS ABOUT WHAT
OPPORTUNITIES WE PROVIDE FOR ALL
OF US WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
AND WITH THAT THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE OR DESIRE TO
VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL [inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE.
INTEL A LOT EYES FORTY NINE
KNOWS.
THREE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM [inaudible]
ONE THIRTY SEVEN THIS IS
[inaudible]
S. B. [inaudible] TEN SIXTEEN
CORPORATION SENATE BILL TEN
SIXTEEN BY SENATOR ALLEN AND
OTHERS IN ATLANTA COMMON
INTEREST DEVELOPMENTS
[inaudible]
MR MERCY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER IT IS MY HONOR.
TO I MANAGED SAYS SENATE BILL
TEN SIXTEEN BY SENATOR ALLEN.
THIS WILL HELP.
CONDOMINIUM RESIDENTS TO HAVE
THE SAME.
RIGHTS TO ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING STATIONS AS HOMEOWNERS
THIS WILL PROHIBIT HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATIONS FIRM EFFECTIVELY
PROHIBITING ARE UNREASONABLY
RESTRICTING.
THIS ELATION OF TIME OF USE
METERS. TO GIVE UP CONDO
RESIDENTS BASICALLY THE SAME
RIGHTS HAT HOMEOWNERS A SINGLE
FAMILY HOMEOWNERS HAVE THIS THIS
BILL IS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES ON
THE SENATE FLOOR.
AND DISTRICT RECEIVED --
NO OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
VERY AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS MURATSUCHI SEEN
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OVER THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE AYES
FORTY NINE THOSE TO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEMONE THIRTY EIGHT IS S.
B. EIGHT NINETY FOUR THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SENATE BILL EIGHT NINETY FOUR BY
SENATOR DODD AND OTHERS AND ACT
LIKE TO INSURANCE.
MICHELINE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS WE'VE SEEN INCREASINGLY
DESTRUCTIVE FIRE SEASONS MANY
MEMBERS ON THIS FLOOR HAVE SEEN
THEIR DISTRICTS IMPACTED BY
THESE FIRES S. B. EIGHT NINETY
FOUR IS ONE STEP TO HELP PROTECT.
CALIFORNIANS AND WILDFIRES HIT
THIS BILL GUARANTEES UP TO THREE
YEARS OF INSURANCE COVERAGE. FOR
LIVING EXPENSES ASSURE US THAT
INSURANCE COMPANIES PROVIDE
VICTIMS WITH POLICY RENEWALS FOR
AT LEAST TWO YEARS FOLLOWING A
DISASTER.
AND ALLOWS POLICY HOLDERS TO USE
THE FULL REPLACEMENT VALUE.
OF OTHER STRUCTURES USED FOR
REBUILDING THEIR PRIMARY
DWELLING WE KNOW THE FIRES
FLOODS AND OTHER NATURAL
DISASTERS.
WILL HAPPEN AGAIN.
WE NEED TO TAKE STEPS NOW TO
IMPROVE INSURANCE COVERAGE AND
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THEY MISSED LEVINE.
DOCTOR QUIRK YOUR RECOMMENDS.
SO ON THE COVERAGE OF THE
ADDITIONAL HOME PERHAPS YOU CAN
ANSWER THIS IN YOUR CLOTHES.
UP MY CONCERN WOULD BE IS IF
THIS IS APPLIED RETROACTIVELY.
YES PEOPLE BY CERTAIN COVERAGE --
THEY GET A CERTAIN ARE RATED.
FOR COMPANIES ARE ALLOWED.
TO SHE IS BE THE REGULATED SO
THEY HAVE TO UNDERWRITE A
PARTICULAR RATE.
IF YOU ARE RETROACTIVELY ON OLD
POLICIES.
ARE ALLOWING --
FOR SORT OF ADDITIONAL
[inaudible]
RECOVERY.
THAT WASN'T COVERED INITIALLY I
HAVE A CONCERN IF THIS IS FOR
POLICIES GOING FORWARD.
THEN THAT'S FINE BECAUSE THEY
CAN GO DID THE JOB INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER TO GET ADDITIONAL --
REVENUE FOR THAT INSURANCE SO
WAS THIS.
CAN TO BE APPLIED TO OLD
POLICIES ARE ONLY TWO A POLICIES
GOING FORWARD.
QUESTION IS WITHOUT OBJECTION.
YEAH I THINK IT'S I'LL ANSWERED
MY CLOTHES RATHER.
THE SHOW BEEN WILL ADDRESS THAT
INQUIRY IN HIS CLOTHES.
MISTER VOEPEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS --
BILL.
WHEN YOU COMBINE --
HOME WITH ALL THE OTHER
STRUCTURES ON A PROPERTY
[inaudible]
THEN.
WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS YOU'RE?
YOUR ACTUALLY RAISING.
COST OF EVERYTHING GENERALLY
HOMEOWNERS POLICIES YOU WILL
ENSURE [inaudible]
EITHER. 80% 90% 100% WHATEVER
PERCENT THE CONSUMER PICKS.
OF REPLACEMENT VALUE.
YOU CAN ALSO PUT A RIDER ON
THESE POLICIES IF YOU WISH IN A
FREE MARKETPLACE.
IN ORDER TO REBUILD ACCORDING TO
THE NEW CODES SO THIS ISN'T JUST
A COOKIE CUTTER BILL HERE.
YOU HAVE TO WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO
BE DOING IS AFFECTING THE
MARKETPLACE AND PEOPLE'S CHOICE.
FREEDOM IN HOW THEY WANT TO
STRUCTURE [inaudible]
THEIR COVERAGE.
THE OTHER THING IS.
WITH ALL THE STRUCTURES OTHER
THAN THE MAIN HOME.
SOMETIMES A GARAGE COULD BE.
WORTH MORE THAN THE MAIN HOPE.
THIS BILL DOES NOT REFLECT THAT
THERE MAY BE OTHER STRUCTURES ON
THE PROPERTY [inaudible]
SO.
THE BEST THING TO DO.
IS TO ALLOW THE FREEDOM OF THE
CONSUMER TO PICK AND CHOOSE WITH
THEIR BROKER AGENT.
THE DIFFERENT POLICIES THAT SUIT
THEM.
IF YOU MAKE IT THE INSURANCE
COMPANY.
PAY AT THESE LEVELS AND YOU LOCK
HIM IN [inaudible] TWO YEARS.
PREMIUMS ARE GONNA GO UP THESE
COMPANIES WILL COVER THEIR RISK.
PREMIUMS WILL GO UP [inaudible]
AND THE PEOPLE THAT ARE IN HIGH
FIRE AREAS.
WILL BE DENIED AT A MUCH HIGHER
RATE THIS IS NOT A GOOD BILL
THIS TAKES.
A WORKING SYSTEM.
AND TRASHES IT THANK YOU.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
ON THE ITEM MISS LEVINE MIKLOS.
YEAH I THINK YOUR MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
OF NUMBER OF FIRE INSURANCE
REFORM BILLS HAVE BEEN
INTRODUCED THIS YEAR.
AS A RESULT OF THE WILD FIRES
LAST YEAR --
WORKING WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS
RESOLVE THESE ISSUES AND I THINK
THAT THESE ARE COMMON SENSE
REFORMS THAT WILL PROTECT.
HOMEOWNERS INTO THE FUTURE SPENT
CLASS FOR AN AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
CORPORAL --
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE FOR THIS
ARTICLE
.
MR LEVINE MOVES A CALL
THIS IS AT A FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY NINE S. B..
EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT WELL ON ONE
THIRTY NINE S. B. THIRTY EIGHT
CORKERY.
SENATE BILL EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT
BY SENATOR HERTZBERG AND
ACTUALLY TO CORPORATIONS MISTER
CALDERON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
BLOCKCHAIN HOLDS TREMENDOUS
PROMISE AND HAS MANY POTENTIAL
APPLICATIONS THAT CAN BENEFIT
CONSUMERS.
BUSINESSES AND INDUSTRIES IN
CALIFORNIA AND WORLDWIDE
CALIFORNIA HAS ALWAYS BEEN A
PLACE FOR INNOVATION OPPORTUNITY
AND WE NEED TO CONTINUE THIS
LEGACY BY WELCOMING THIS RAPIDLY
GROWING TECHNOLOGY.
FORBES RECENTLY RELEASED THE
FINTECH.
FIFTY LIST OF TOP FIFTY
FINANCIAL TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES
GLOBALLY AND ELEVEN OF THEM USE
BLOCKCHAIN.
TO A TECHNOLOGY OR ARE CONNECTED
TO THE CRYPTOCURRENCY INDUSTRY
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ALONE
TWENTY SEVEN POINT FOUR BILLION
WAS INVESTED INTO FINTECH START
UPS THAT WHICH INCLUDE BLOCKING
COMPANIES AND THIS NUMBER ONLY
CONTINUES TO GROW.
THIS IS WHY CALIFORNIA NOW THE
WORLD'S FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY
NEEDS TO EMBRACE THIS TECHNOLOGY.
S. B. EIGHT THIRTY A PROPOSES TO
ALLOW CORPORATIONS TO ISSUE AND
TRANSFER STOCK CERTIFICATES VIA
BLOCKCHAIN.
ALLOWING THESE CORPORATIONS TO
UTILIZE A MORE SECURE TECHNOLOGY
WILL INCREASE CONSUMER
PROTECTION AND HELP PREVENT
FRAUD.
THE AUTHOR AND I WORK CLOSELY ON
THIS MEASURE IN MY OWN AB TWENTY
SIX FIFTY EIGHT TO DEFINE
BLOCKCHAIN TECHNOLOGY FOR THE
FIRST TIME THE STATUTE IN ORDER
TO SEND A CLEAR SIGNAL. TO
COMPANIES THAT CALIFORNIA IS
STILL A PLACE FOR INNOVATION
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THINGS CALDERON.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
QUIRK LIBERAL.
AND MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE IS THERE TO
VOTE.
WORK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
AYE.
SIXTY ONE NO ZERO SENATE ARMY.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE GOING TO PASS AND RETAIN
ON FILE ITEM.
ONE FORTY THIS IS FILE ITEM.
ONE FORTY ONE S. B..
ELEVEN TWENTY EIGHT CORKERY
SENATE BILL ELEVEN TWENTY EIGHT
BY SENATOR ROTH NECTAR AND
COMMON INTERESTS DEVELOPMENTS.
MR BY THIS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SB ELEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT CREATES AN
AFFIRMATION PROCESS FOR
UNCONTESTED BOARD ELECTIONS
UNDER S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY EIGHT
ABOARD ME COUNCIL ELECTION WHEN
THE NUMBER OF NOMINEES IS LESS
THAN OR EQUAL TO THE NUMBER OF
POSITIONS AVAILABLE.
UNDER THIS BILL AT THIS
SITUATION OCCURS ANOTHER NOT
NOTICE NOMINATION HEARING WILL
BE MADE AVAILABLE FOR ANY MEMBER
WHO WISHES TO RUN IF AFTER THE
SECOND NOMINATION PERIOD.
THE ELECTION STILL HAS
INSUFFICIENT NOMINEES TO BE
CONTESTED THE BOARD MAY VOTE TO
SEAT THE NOMINEES BY ACCLAMATION
THIS BILL UNDERWENT.
SEVERAL ROUNDS OF NEGOTIATIONS
IN BOTH HOUSES JUDICIARY
COMMITTEES THIS BILL WAS AMENDED
TO INCLUDE A NUMBER OF
PROTECTIONS FROM SP TWELVE SIXTY
FIVE RELATIVE TO ONE ABOARD MAY
DISQUALIFY CANDIDATES.
FROM RUNNING FOR THE BOARD SP
ELEVEN TWENTY EIGHT HAS RECEIVED
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
AUSTRIA AYE VOTE TODAY.
THING IS CERVANTES SAYING NO
DISCUSSION.
OUR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
OUR CLUB THROW.
NUMBERS VOTE IS OUT OF OF ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE BECAUSE THERE
TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ZERO ANTI THAT I SHOULD BE
SEVEN NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM.
ONE FORTY TWO S. B..
SIX SIX EIGHT GREGORY SENATE
BILL SIX SIXTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE AND I PLAYED A
COMMERCIAL FEED MAKING
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE.
THIS COMING YEAR THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
MCGUIRE TO PRESENT S. B..
SIX SIXTY EIGHT THE CURRENT FINE
STRUCTURE IN PLACE FOR
VIOLATIONS OF THE COMMERCIAL
FEED LA IS NOT ENOUGH TO DETER
OFFENDERS PARTICULARLY REPEAT
OFFENDERS.
ON TOP OF THAT.
MOST COUNTY DA'S HAVE VERY FULL
CRIMINAL PROSECUTION SCHEDULE SO
MANY OF THESE VIOLATIONS DON'T
GET HANDLED.
THIS CREATES A CYCLE WHERE
VIOLATORS MOST PARTICULARLY
REPEAT VIOLATORS NO THAT THE
FINES ARE LOW AND CDFA.
CANNOT PROPERLY ENFORCE OR
PENALIZE THEM.
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND AND
THIRTEEN AND TWO THOUSAND AND
SIMPLE.
SEVENTEEN CV FAA'S ANIMAL FEED
INSPECTION PROGRAM QUARANTINED A
HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE VARIOUS
ANIMAL FOOD COMMODITIES BECAUSE
OF HEALTH.
AND SAFETY ISSUES.
S. B. SIX SIX EIGHT INCREASES
PENALTIES FOR FIRST TIME AND
REPEAT OFFENDERS.
AND ALLOWS CDFA TO HOLD
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS IN LIEU
OF CIVIL PENALTIES.
THIS IS LANGUAGE THAT DEFEAT
INSPECTION ADVISORY BOARD I BET
NONE OF YOU KNEW THERE WAS US A
FEED INSPECTION ADVISORY BOARD.
HAS RECOMMENDED TWICE AND IS
CHAMPION BY THE COMMERCIAL FEED
INDUSTRY THIS LEGISLATION IS
INTENDED TO HIT AGREE JUST
REPEAT VIOLATORS WHERE IT HURTS
MOST WHICH IS OUR POCKETBOOKS.
THIS BILL CREATES A STRONGER
DETERRENT SO CDFA CAN CONTINUE
TO ENSURE THAT THE QUALITY OF
SPEED SOLD.
IS HIGH THE HIGHEST QUALITY AND
STOP THOSE WHO ARE INTENTIONALLY
SKIRTING THE COMMERCIAL FEED LA.
THE BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS CABALLERO THIS
MATHIS HERE RECOMMENDS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION.
DE SOMEBODY THAT HAS ACTUALLY
HAD TO DO WITH THE OF WORSE CALL
A KEEN BECAUSE OF BAD FEE --
YOU KNOW THIS IS A GREAT WAY OUR
INDUSTRIES COME TOGETHER. TO
LOOK AT WHO THE GOOD ACTORS ARE
AND WHO THE BAD ACTORS OR AND
WHEN WE'RE ABLE TO HAVE AN
INDUSTRY COME TOGETHER AND SAY
LET'S MAKE SURE PEOPLE ARE
PLAYING BY THE RULES.
LET'S MAKE SURE THAT THE ANIMAL
THEY WERE TAKEN CARE OF ARE
GETTING GOOD FEE.
THIS IS SOMETHING SUPPORTABLE.
AND I THINK YOU ALL SHOULD
SUPPORTERS WELL LET'S MAKE SURE
WE'RE FEEDING OUR ANIMALS THE
GOOD STUFF ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MR MATHIS SEEN NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THIS TAKES
.
FIFTY FOUR THE CLERK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ALL AND TELL YOU
ABOUT.
I FIFTY FIVE KNOWS ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY.
ON FILE ITEM.
ONE FORTY THREE AND PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM. ONE
FORTY FOUR THAT BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM.
ONE FORTY FIVE S. B..
ELEVEN SIXTY THREE THE CORPORATE
SENATE ELEVEN SIXTY THREE BY
SENATOR GALGIANI AND EGGPLANT
AUTOPSIES [inaudible]
WAS CARILLO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT SB ELEVEN SIXTY THREE
ON BEHALF OF OUR SENATE
COLLEAGUE FROM THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY.
THE BILL THAT --
THIS BILL WOULD AUTHORIZE AN
AGENCY PERFORMING THE
EXCLAMATION OF A BODY OR
SKELETAL REMAINS THAT HAVE
SUFFERED SIGNIFICANT
DETERIORATION AND DECOMPOSITION
TO EMPLOY THE EXPERTISE.
OF A BOARD CERTIFIED FORENSIC
PATHOLOGISTS OR ANTHROPOLOGISTS
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY CONFIDENCE AND
TRANSPARENCY IN THE PROCESS OF
HANDLING UNIDENTIFIED OR
SEVERELY DECOMPOSED HUMAN
REMAINS.
THIS BILL ENJOYS A BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND RECENT AMENDMENTS
HAVE REMOVED ALL OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU [inaudible]
DOCTOR WOULD.
THEY MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS AT THIS
BILL I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT WHEN YOU'RE HANDLING
THESE KINDS REMAINS THAT YOU DO
IT VERY VERY CAREFULLY.
OFTENTIMES WE'RE DEALING WITH
CRIMINAL CASES AND THE EVIDENCE
CAN BE EASILY LOST I'VE BEEN
WORKING IN THE FIELD OF FORENSIC
DENTISTRY FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS.
AND I'VE SEEN IT AND SEEING
MULTIPLE TIMES WHERE WHEN THINGS
THINGS ARE DOT DON'T ALWAYS DONE
WITH IT WHERE THEY COULD BE.
IN OTHER JURISDICTIONS ARE NOT
MINE BY --
BUT I THINK I'M WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL I THINK IT'S A
GREAT STEP.
ASK YOUR ABOUT.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD SAY NO
ADDITIONAL.
DISCUSSION.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE RIGHT.
THAT A VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF ALL MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE
TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF OF
ICE FIFTY SIX NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
YOU'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY.
ON FILE ITEM.
ONE FORTY SIX FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY SEVEN IS S. B.. TEN
SEVENTY EIGHT CORP WILL READ.
SAID ABOUT TEN SEVENTY EIGHT BY
THE COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION
AND HOUSING AND ACT LIKE A
HOUSING.
THE* YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES IMPRISONING SP TEN
SEVENTY EIGHT WHICH IS THE
HOUSING OMINOUS BILL BY THE
SENATE.
TRANSPORTATION AND HOUSING
COMMITTEE THE BILL MAKES NON
CONTROVERSIAL AND TECHNICAL
CHANGES TO SECTIONS OF HOUSING
LAW -- HAS
NO OPPOSITION AND HAS NOT
RECEIVED ANY NO VOTES WITH THAT
RESPECT WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
NAMES YOU.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OVER THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTED THIS OUT OF THE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTE ICD.
NINE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
[inaudible]
FILE ITEM. ONE FORTY EIGHT IS S.
B..
TO NINETY EIGHT KERKORIAN SENATE
BILL TO NINETY EIGHT BY SENATOR
WIECKOWSKI AND ACTOR IN THE
CIVIL ACTIONS [inaudible]
DOCTOR WEBER.
pMISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT U. S. B. TO
NINETY EIGHT ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR Y. KOWSKI.
S. B. TO NINETY EIGHT WILL
PROTECT A MINIMUM BALANCE IN A
PERSON'S BANK ACCOUNT WHEN IT IS
LEVIED BY DEBT COLLECTORS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW EVERY DOLLAR
OF A PERSON'S BANK ACCOUNT
INCLUDING THEIR LAST PAYCHECK R.
ET AYE YEAH AYE TO SEE PAYMENT
CAN BE WIPED OUT WITH A SINGLE
DEBT COLLECTORS LEVY.
THIS NOT ONLY RESULTS AND
HARDSHIP OF PEOPLE BECAUSE IT
LEADS TO EVICTIONS CAR
REPOSSESSIONS AT MISS MEDICAL
TREATMENT.
BUT IS ALSO COMPLETELY CONTRARY
TO THE POLICY OF HAVING PEOPLE
PAY THEIR BILLS.
ALLOWING A QUOTE TAKE IT ALL
BANK LEVEES ALSO DRIVES PEOPLE
AWAY FROM TRADITIONAL BANKING IN
AN TO PREDATORY LOANS.
WHAT'S WORSE THE WESTERN CENTER
AND POT LOT POVERTY REPORTS AT
LEGAL SERVICES AROUND THE STATE
HAVE SEEN PEOPLE'S ACCOUNT FOR
DEBT THAT WAS THAT EVEN THERE'S
AND BY THE TIME THEY GET THEIR
MONEY BACK IT'S FOUR TO SIX
MONTHS OF PASSED.
THAT POOR DURING THAT TIME FRAME
AFTER THEY'VE BEEN EVICTED FROM
THEIR HOMES AND THE CARD NEEDED
TO BE EXPERIENCE THEY HAVE BEEN
REPOSSESSED.
INSTEAD OF ASSUMING WE DON'T
NEED ANY MONEY IN OUR ACCOUNT S.
B. TO NINETY EIGHT WILL PROTECT
ONLY TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
THIS IS ONE PAYCHECK AT ABOUT
FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR WAGES.
IT IS NEXT TO IMPOSSIBLE TO LIVE
IN POVERTY AND NOT GOING TODAY.
SB TWO NINETY EIGHT DOES NOT
ERASE ANY DEBT IT SIMPLY ALLOWS
PEOPLE TO PAY TODAY'S BEALS Y.
THEY WORK ON PAYING OFF
YESTERDAY'S DEBT.
IF WE ARE SERIOUS ABOUT OUR
COMMITMENT TO END POVERTY IN
THIS STATE WE WILL PASS THIS
BILL.
I URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR A BI S.
B..
TWO NINE EIGHT THANK YOU DOCTOR
WEBER.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM THE CLERK WILL OVER THE
ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THIS TAKES.
FORTY ONE DOCTOR ARE WEBER.
YEAH.
WHAT'S YOUR PLEASURE.
I HAVE NOTHING BUT TIME SIR.
BUT FOR THE MOMENT I'LL MOVE THE
CALL.
TAKE YOU BACK WEBER
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY --
FILE ITEMS ONE FORTY NINE AND
ONE FIFTY THAT BRINGS US TO FILE
ITEM.
ONE FIFTY ONE S. B..
THIRTEEN THIRTY THREE THE CLERK
MARIE.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN THIRTY
THREE BY SENATOR WIECKOWSKI AND
OTHERS IN ATLANTA LAND USE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
IS YOUR ATTENTION AS GLORIA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
RESENT SP THIRTEEN THIRTY THREE
BY SENATOR MY KOWSKI --
THIS BILL CREATES CONSISTENCY A
REQUIREMENT TO APPLY TO ALL THE
STATE'S PLANNING AND ZONING
ORDINANCE REQUIREMENTS.
CHARTER CITIES FOUR MINUTES LAST
WEEK FURTHER NARROW THE BILL TO
HONE IN ON JUST THE CONSISTENCY
IN HOUSING.
SP THIRTEEN THIRTY THREE IS
CRUCIAL TO ENSURING THE
LEGISLATURE'S WORK ON OURS
STATE'S HOUSING CRISIS IS NOT
FOR NOTHING BY REQUIRING
CONSISTENCY IN ALL FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTY TWO OF CALIFORNIA CITIES.
ON BEHALF OF THE SENATOR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THIS BODIES
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS CLARK NAM SEEN NO.
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO SARAH VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL ANTI ABOUT ICE.
FORTY TWO KNOWS.
TWENTY THAT MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL.
ON FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY EIGHT
WHICH IS S. B. EIGHT NINETY FOUR
THE CLERK WILL POST.
ON MEMBERS VOTER WHICH TO VOTE.
WELL MEMBERS WOULD WISH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHICH TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSER ALL.
TELL THE VOTE EYES.
FORTY TWO NO SEVENTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES
.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
AND VIOLENCE ONE FIFTY TWO AND
ONE FIFTY THREE PASS RETAIN ON
FILE ITEMS ONE FIFTY FOUR AND
ONE FIFTY FIVE THAT BRINGS US.
TO FILE ITEM.
ONE FIFTY SIX S. B. THIRTEEN
SEVENTY FOR BY DR QUIRK.
THE CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FOUR BY SENATOR
HUESO ACT LINDA ENERGY
[inaudible]
DOCTOR QUIRK.
THANK YOU SPEAKER IN MEMBERS SP
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FOUR DELETE
OUTDATED REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
FOR THE INTEGRATED ENERGY POLICY
REPORT.
AND ESTABLISHES A SUNSET FOR
DUKE DUPLICATIVE REPORTS.
THESE CHANGES ARE NEEDED TO
INSURE THAT ENERGY POLICY
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
REFLECT EXISTING TRENDS IN THE
ENERGY MARKET [inaudible]
THIS MEASURES RECEIVED STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND THERE'S
NO OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THEY CONNECT WORK SEEN NO
DISCUSSION MADE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
WAS THAT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTED
AS OUR VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL AND TELL YOU WHAT I
SIXTY ONE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEMS. ONE FIFTY SEVEN
THROUGH.
ONE FIFTY NINE THAT BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY S. B. FORTY
SIX A CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL FORTY SIX BY SENATOR
LEYVA AND ACTUALLY THE MOBILE
HOMES [inaudible]
MISTER GLORIA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT S. B. FORTY SIX BY
SENATOR LEYVA THIS BILL WOULD
EXTEND THE SUNSET DATE FOR THE
MOBILE HOME PARK MAINTENANCE
INSPECTION PROGRAM.
KNOWS IN PM BY ADDITIONAL FIVE
YEARS THIS BILL IS RECEIVED BY
PARTS SUPPORT SUPPORT IN BOTH
HOUSES RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GLORIA SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
DESERT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WAS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE ANTI VOTE EYES FIFTY
FOUR KNOWS ONE THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK
TO FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY FIVE AND
TAKE UP ONE FIFTY FIVE THIS IS
S. B. [inaudible] THIRTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT CORKERY.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT
BY SENATOR HUESO EXPLAIN THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
MR HOLDING FOR HIM TO SPEAK
TODAY A RISE 2% S. B. THIRTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT HUESO A BILL TO HELP
EXPEDITE PROCEEDINGS.
AT THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION.
AS MEMBERS OF OFTEN COMPLAIN
CPUC PROCEEDINGS OFTEN TAKE A
LONGER TIME THAT IS DESIRED BY
ALL PARTIES.
S. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT MAKES
MINOR BUT IMPORTANT CHANGES TO
HELP REDUCE THE LAG TIME DO
ADMINISTRATIVE HURDLES AT THE
CPUC.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
FOR THOSE REASONS I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ON THE
NUMBERS VOTE DESIRED TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
THE CLERK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TELL ME THAT
I SIXTY SIX NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEMS.
ONE SIXTY ONE THROUGH.
ONE SIXTY FOUR THAT BRINGS US
FILE ITEM.
ONE SIXTY FIVE S. B..
EIGHT TWENTY THREE CORPORATE
SEVERAL EIGHT TWENTY THREE BY
SENATOR HELL AND ACTUALLY THE
PUBLIC HEALTH.
DOCTOR WOULD.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
S. B. EIGHT TWENTY THREE
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO ADOPT
THE AMERICAN SOCIETY OF
ADDICTION MEDICINE.
TREATMENT CRITERIA OR EQUIVALENT
EVIDENCE BASED STANDARD AS THE
MINIMUM STANDARD OF CARE FOR
LICENSED ADULT ALCOHOLISM OR
DRUG ABUSE RECOVERY FACILITIES.
D. EIGHT C. S..
CURRENTLY DOES THIS VOLUNTARILY
BUT SEVERAL COUNTIES HAVE NOT
OPTED IN.
THE BILL ENSURES THAT EVERY
FACILITY IN THE STATE WHEN THEY
HACKED WHEN THEY GET A NEW
LICENSE WITH D. EIGHT CS OR
RENEW OUR UTILIZING EVIDENCE
BASED STANDARDS TO ASSESS AND
TREAT THEIR CLIENTS.
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS BACK
DESERVE THIS MINIMUM STANDARD OF
CARE THERE HAS BEEN NO
OPPOSITION THIS BILL IS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
I THINK THAT WOULD SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE RIGHT
[inaudible]
VOTE.
USER TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WELL CLOSER ROLE.
AND TELL YOU THAT I SUCCEED
KNOWS ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY SIX
S. B..
NINE SIXTY ONE COOPERATE SENATE
BILL NINE SIXTY ONE BY SENATOR
ALLEN AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT [inaudible]
MR GABRIEL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT AS SPEED
NINE SIX ONE WHICH PROVIDES A
VOLUNTARY TAX INCREMENT
FINANCING TO ALL. FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO HELP BUILD MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING NEAR TRANSIT.
THIS BILL PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR ENHANCED
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICT TO BOND AGAINST FUTURE
SALES AND PROPERTY TAX
INCREMENTS.
IT ALSO REQUIRES A DISTRICT HOLD
A SERIES OF HEARINGS ON ITS
FINANCING PLAN.
PROVIDING THE PUBLIC WITH THE
FORMAL OPPORTUNITY TO PROTEST
FORCE A VOTE OR EVEN REJECT A
PLAN IF THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
WOOD.
OBJECTIONS.
IN RETURN S. B. NINE SIX ONE
REQUIRES AT LEAST 40% OF A
DISTRICTS TAX INCREMENTS TO BE
SPENT.
BUILDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
CLOSE PROXIMITY TO A MAJOR
TRANSIT STOP.
THIS LEGISLATION ALSO MANDATES
ELISE 10% A FUNDING GO TOWARDS
URBAN GREENING AND ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PRODUCTS AND
AUTHORIZES REMAINING MONEY TO BE
SPENT ENHANCING TRANSIT SYSTEMS
AND SURROUNDING INFRASTRUCTURE
IN SUPPORT OF SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES.
THIS BILL HAS BROAD SUPPORT FROM
BUSINESS LABOR ENVIRONMENTAL AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN GROUPS AND
HAS NO OPPOSITION AGAIN MEMBERS
THIS IS A BAR THIS VOLUNTARY
TOOL EMPOWERS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO ADDRESS OUR HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THINGS GABRIEL SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CARCLUB RURAL.
MEMBERS VOTE.
ROSARIO VOTE ON MEMBERS VETERANS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOUGH DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL ANTI VOTE EYES FORTY
SIX KNOWS.
SIXTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
ONE SIXTY SEVEN S. B..
NINE SIXTY FOUR COOPERATE SAMPLE
NINE SIXTY FOUR BY SENATOR ALLEN
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
PUBLIC RETIREMENT SYSTEMS
[inaudible]
MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT S. B.
NINE SIXTY FOUR BEHALF OF
SENATOR ALLEN.
THIS MEASURE SEEKS TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC PENSION
FUNDS CALPERS AND CAL STIRS.
CONSIDER THE FINANCIAL RISK
POSED BY CLIMATE CHANGE.
THERE ARE FOUR DIFFERENT TYPES
OF RISK THAT CLIMATE CHANGE PUT
CHUCK CLIMATE CHANGE.
POSES TO THE VALUE OF BY NASA'S
THAT SHOULD BE CONSIDERED BY
PLAN PRODUCE AREAS.
THESE INCLUDE PHYSICAL RISK
TRANSITION RISK STRANDED ASSET
RISK AND LITIGATION RISK.
BOTH CALPERS CALPERS IN CALTRANS
HAVE GOVERNANCE DIRECTORS THAT
ADVISE THEM TO TAKE CLIMATE RISK
INTO ACCOUNT WHEN MAKING
INVESTMENT DECISIONS.
S. B. NINE SIXTY FOR CODIFIES
THAT CLIMATE RELATED RISK --
CODIFIES THAT CLIMATE RELATED
RISK OR MATERIAL FINANCIAL RISK
AND SO MUST BE CONSIDERED.
BY THE PENSION BOYS AND MANAGING
THEIR FUNDS AND ASK THE BOYS
REPORT ON THIS REST AND THEIR
COMPREHENSIVE FINANCE REPORTS
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
MY BOAT.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OVER THE ROLE --
DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
CLERK WILL [inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE.
I TELL YOU LOVE AYE AYES
[inaudible]
FORTY SIX KNOWS.
NINETEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT FILE ITEM.
ONE SIXTY EIGHT S. B. ONE
THOUSAND EIGHT CORKERY.
SENATE BILL ONE THOUSAND AND
EIGHT BY SENATOR SKINNER AND
ACTUALLY THE DENTAL SERVICES.
DOCTOR WOULD.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBER
SP ONE ZERO ZERO EIGHT REQUIRES
DENTAL PLANS BY CONSUMERS WITH
THE UNIFORM SUMMARY OF THEIR
BENEFITS.
MAKING IT EASIER FOR CONSUMERS
TO UNDERSTAND AND COMPARE DEL
OPTIONS WILL HELP CONSUMERS MAKE
BETTER INFORMED DECISIONS ABOUT
THEIR DENTAL CARE.
THE BILL HAS HAD NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THEY LIKE WOOD SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO'S OUR VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WINNERS OUT OF
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSER ROLE ANTI VOTE
AYE.
SIXTY THREE KNOWS ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM.
ONE SIXTY NINE PASS AND RETAIN.
ON FILE ITEM. ONE SEVENTY PASS
TEMPORARILY.
UNLESS YOU'D LIKE TO TAKE UP
MISTER
[inaudible]
MEMBERS I'D.
I AM ONE SEVENTY ONE WE'RE GOING
TO PASS AFTER EARLY AND MOVE TO
ITEM ONE SEVENTY TWO S. B..
TEN EIGHTY SIX PLEASE READ
SENATE BOLTS HAD EIGHTY SIX BY
SENATOR ATKINS AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO WORKERS COMPENSATION
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS S. B. TEN
EIGHTY SIX PERMANENTLY EXTENDS
THE WINDOW OF TIME DURING WHICH
FAMILY MEMBERS OF A PUBLIC
SAFETY OFFICER WHOSE DEATH IS
ATTRIBUTABLE TO A SERIOUS
ILLNESS CAUSED BY THEIR WORK.
ARE ELIGIBLE TO COLLECT SURVIVOR
DEATH BENEFITS PRIOR TO TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN OFF IF AN
OFFICER DIED.
MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED FORTY
WEEKS AFTER DIAGNOSIS THEIR
FAMILY BECAME INELIGIBLE FOR
THESE BENEFITS.
IN RECOGNITION OF MEDICAL
ADVANCEMENTS IN THE ARBITRARY
NATURE OF THE TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY WE CAP GOVERNOR BROWN IN
THE LET LEGISLATURE DOUBLE THE
ELIGIBILITY PERIOD FOR THESE
FAMILIES. FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY
WEEKS IN.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN HOWEVER
WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE ACTION THAT
TIME MIND WILL REVERT BACK ON
JANUARY.
ONE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN S. B.
TEN EIGHTY SIX WILL ENSURE THAT
THESE OFFICERS GRIEVING FAMILIES
ARE NOT DEPRIVED OF THE BENEFITS
THEY DESERVE DUE TO AN ARBITRARY
NONE FAIR TIMELINE.
MEMBERS THIS BILL IS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT THIS FAR WE
HAVE ALL WITNESSED THE IMMENSE
BRAVERY OF OUR FIREFIGHTERS AS
WELL FIRES CONTINUE TO RAGE
ACROSS THE STATE.
NOW MORE THAN EVER IS IMPORTANT
HONOR THEIR SERVICE PROTECT
THEIR FAMILIES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I AM SEEING A REQUEST TO SPEAK
MEADOW PARK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
HOW MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE?
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
RULING TALLY THE VOTES EYES
SIXTY FIVE KNOWS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM ONE SEVENTY
THREE PASS AND RETAIN WERE
MOVING TO ITEM ONE SEVENTY FOUR
S. B. ELEVEN SEVEN A TO MY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL OF AND SEVENTY TWO
BY SENATOR PELL AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO HIGH SPEED RAIL.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
SP ONE ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO IS A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE THAT PUTS
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY ON PAR
WITH OTHER AGENCIES CHARGED WITH
CONSTRUCTING MAJOR
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS.
SIMILAR TO CALTRANS AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
AND THE UC SYSTEM.
THIS BILL AFFORDS THE AUTHORITY
WITH THE SAME RIGHT OF WAY
ACQUISITION.
TOOLS THAT REMOVED DUPLICATIVE
REQUIREMENTS AND STREAMLINE
OTHER PROCESSES THAT ULTIMATELY
WILL SAVE OUR STATE.
BOTH TIME AND MONEY.
MEMBERS THE FACTS ARE VERY
STRAIGHT FORWARD FACT.
THIS PROJECT IS OFF THE GROUND
IN IS THE LARGEST INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS TO EVER BE CONSTRUCTED
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
FACT THIS PROJECT HAS CREATED
OVER TWO THOUSAND WELL PAYING
CONSTRUCTION JOBS HAS OVER FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SMALL BUSINESS.
IS WORKING ON THIS PROJECT AND
HAS PROVIDED TWO BILLION DOLLARS
IN ECONOMIC ACTIVITY IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND SIX BILLION
DOLLARS STATEWIDE.
FACT THE PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL
WILL SAVE THE STATE MONEY REDUCE
DELAYS IN ACQUIRING RIGHT OF WAY
AND WILL CREATE MORE JOBS.
LET ME BE CLEAR.
THIS BILL DOES NOT REMOVE ANY
OVERSIGHT FUNCTIONS TWO OR
PROVIDE THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY.
THAT GOES BEYOND WHAT IS
PROVIDED FOR OTHER SIMILARLY
SITUATED STATE AGENCIES.
THIS BILL SIMPLY PROVIDES A MORE
STREAMLINED PROPERTY ACQUISITION
PROCESS THAT IS CONSISTENT WITH
THE AUTHORITY PROVIDED TO OTHER
STATE AGENCIES.
MEMBERS THIS IS THE TYPE OF
LEGISLATION THAT WE SHOULD BE
PASSING A BILL THAT REMOVES
DUPLICATIVE BUREAUCRATIC
PROCESSES A BILL THAT CONTINUES
TO HOLD THE OTHER --
AUTHORITY ACCOUNTABLE TO THE
PUBLIC IN A BILL THAT PUTS
PEOPLE BACK TO WORK MEMBERS THIS
BILL IS SUPPORTED BY LABOR AND
HAS NO OPPOSITIONS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AS A MEMBER OF THE PUTS STATE
PUBLIC WORKS BOARD I SEE THE
PROCESS.
WE HAVE OUR MEETINGS OF GOING
FORWARD IT'S AN ONEROUS PROCESS
THAT.
BED DE --
ACQUISITION OF LAND AND IT ON
RIGHT AWAY IS GOING IT IS
ABSOLUTELY LIKE SLOGGING THROUGH
THE MUD.
THIS WILL BE AN ESSENTIAL
COMPONENT THAT WILL SAVE.
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS GOING
FORWARD INEFFICIENCIES AND I I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MELINDA'S.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN.
I SHALL REMIND YOU OF THE MANY
ARTICLES THAT HAVE BEEN WRITTEN
ABOUT THE HIGH SPEED RAIL AND
THE COST OVERRUNS AND THE FACT
THAT WE HAVEN'T ACTUALLY SEEN
ANYTHING DONE YET THIS IS A NON
EXISTANT TRAIN.
IT'LL PROBABLY WILL NEVER EXIST
IN OUR LIFETIME ALTHOUGH THE
COST IS GOING TO CONTINUE TO
RISE LESS OVERSIGHT FOR THIS
PROJECT DOESN'T MAKE IT BETTER
AND ACTUALLY MAKES IT WORSE.
IF THIS WERE PUT BACK BEFORE THE
VOTERS TODAY I WOULD.
ALMOST BET THAT VOTERS WOULD
REJECT IT THEY WOULD SAY YOU'RE
NOT ABLE TO COMPLETE THIS
PROJECT IT'S NOT GONNA COST WHAT
YOU SAID IT WAS GOING TO COST.
IT'S OUT OF CONTROL DON'T PUT
ANY MORE MONEY TO INTO IT AND
CERTAINLY ANY MONEY YOU DO HAVE
AN IT KEEP AN EYE ON IT THIS
ELIMINATES PROTECTIONS. FOR
LANDOWNERS IT DOES ELIMINATE KEY
OVERSIGHT WHICH IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT WITH THE PROJECT THAT
COST BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
IN IN WHAT OTHER PROJECT WHAT
OTHER DEPARTMENT DO WE TURN A
BLIND EYE TO HOW MONEY IS BEING
SPENT WE JUST SAY YOU KNOW WHAT.
YOU GOTTA GO HEAD WE TRUST YOU.
HAVE YOU READ THE REPORTS AND BY
THE WAY.
THERE'S AN AUDIT PENDING
WOULDN'T YOU LIKE TO SEE THE
RESULTS OF THE AUDIT BEFORE YOU
GO PUTTING MORE MONEY AND LESS
OVERSIGHT INTO THIS PROJECT
WOULD NOT MAKE SENSE OF THEM NOT
FINANCIALLY RESPONSIBLE.
IN THE END AND THE MATURITY THAT
WISEMAN VOTING ON PROJECTS LIKE
THIS.
I URGE A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER HARPER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED HER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
HIGH SPEED RAIL IN THE STATE HAS
BEEN NOTHING BUT A BILLION
DOLLAR BOONDOGGLE THE ORIGINAL
COST OF THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
SYSTEM BETWEEN SAN FRANCISCO AND
LOS ANGELES.
WITH THIRTY FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
TODAY THAT CAUSES BALLOONED UP
TO NINETY EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS
AND IT WILL NOT BE COMPLETED.
UNDER ITS PROJECTIONS INTEL
TWENTY THIRTY THREE ACCORDING TO
SOME ESTIMATES TAXPAYERS DESERVE
TO KNOW WHY THE PRICE OF HIGH
SPEED RAIL IS INCREASED SO MUCH.
BUT THIS BILL WOULD DO THE
OPPOSITE AND RESTRICT THE
OVERSIGHT OF THIS MONSTROSITY OF
A PROJECT.
STATE HAS AN AUDIT SCHEDULED --
IN -- AYE A
GREEN WITH MY AYE KA COLLEAGUE
FROM FROM LAKE ELSINORE.
THAT THIS STATE HAS SCHEDULED A
AND AUDIT SCHEDULE BE RELEASED
IN OCTOBER WHICH WILL EVALUATE
COST OVERRUNS OF THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY WE SHOULD WAIT
UNTIL THE AUDITOR'S COMPLETE.
BEFORE WE DECIDE TOOK UP THIS
PROJECT LOSE AND MAKE THIS AN
EVEN BIGGER MONSTROSITY THERE
ALREADY IS WITH EVEN LESS OVER
STRUCK OVERSIGHT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A NO VOTE ON THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BAKER YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
SAM I I WON'T REITERATE THE GOOD
POINTS IF BEEN MADE BY OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM LAKE ELSINORE AND
HUNTINGTON BEACH BUT I DO WANT
TO SAY I I TO HAVE BEEN TO
HEARINGS ON HIGH SPEED RAIL I'VE
BEEN TO WHERE THERE'S BEEN.
MUCH OF THIS INFORMATION
DISCUSSED IN TWO PARTICULAR
POINTS COME OUT.
THAT UNDERSCORE WHY WE SHOULD
NOT BE REMOVING THE APPROVAL
PROCESS WE SHOULD NOT BE
STREAMLINING WE SHOULD BE MAKING
SURE WE HAVE AS MUCH OVERSIGHT
AS POSSIBLE.
NUMBER ONE OF THIS LAST SPRING
THE NEW --
OF CEO OF THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY MISTER BRIAN KELLY
HIMSELF FOR WHOM I HAVE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF RESPECT.
FOR HE DOES A VERY GOOD JOB
MADAM CHAIR TOO EAGER MISSED MEN
SPEAKER WINCH ORDER IN THE
CHAMBER PLEASE.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR RESPECTS THE
SPEAKER.
BRIAN KELLY --
WAS VERY FRANK WITH A
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE AND
JUST SAID THERE IS NO PLAN FOR
COMPLETING THIS PROJECT.
THERE'S NO PLAN FOR
APPROPRIATELY FUNDING THE
PROJECT.
IT'S IT'S SORT OF A WE'RE GONNA
KEEP GOING TO JUST HOPE THAT
SOMETHING GOOD HAPPENS --
INTO I APPRECIATED THAT CANDOR
BUT IT SHOULD BE FRIGHTENING
THAT WHAT WE MIGHT BE PROPOSING
IS TO TAKE AWAY OVERSIGHT AND
TAKE AWAY APPROVAL PROTECTIONS.
THE SECOND POINT THAT CAME
FORWARD IN THESE VERY HEARINGS
ON HIGH SPEED RAIL IS THAT IT
WILL NOT BE HIGH SPEED.
THE INDEPENDENT OVERSIGHT
AUTHORITY ACTUALLY SAID THERE IS
NO WAY. FOR THIS PROJECT AS IT
IS CURRENTLY GOING FORWARD TO
EVER GET NEAR THE TWO HOURS I
THINK FORTY MINUTES.
THE DID OF CONNECTING THE MAJOR
DESTINATIONS THAT WAS SOLD TO
OUR CONSTITUENTS.
AND I JUST ADD A THIRD POINT THE
INDEPENDENT STATE AUDITOR ELAINE
HOW JUST CAME OUT WITH A REPORT.
I WAS ACTUALLY ON A DIFFERENT
MAJOR TRANSPORTATION PROJECT OF
THE SEISMIC RETROFIT OF THE BAY
BRIDGE.
AND HER NUMBER ONE
RECOMMENDATION WAS TO MAKE SURE
THERE ARE RISK MANAGEMENT
CONTROLS AND REVIEW THE NUMBER
ONE THING SHE SAID WE HAVE TO DO
IS WE NEED MORE RISK MANAGEMENT.
WE NEED MORE OVERSIGHT NOT LESS.
AND SO I NO WE WE HAVE A A GREAT
DISAGREEMENT ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT THIS PROJECT SHOULD GO
FORWARD I VERY MUCH RESPECT FOR
OUR COLLEAGUE WHO'S CARRYING THE
STATE HAS A SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC
IMPACT IN HIS AREA.
I DO THINK ANY TIME YOU BUILD
SOMETHING BIG IN THEIR YOUR FOR
A WHILE GOING TO HAVE AN
ECONOMIC IMPACT.
BUT THE OVERALL MESSAGES THAT WE
ARE GETTING FROM EVERY
INDICATION.
THE THE CEO OF HIGH SPEED RAIL.
THE CHAIR OF THE INDEPENDENT
AUTHORITY AND THE INDEPENDENT
NONPARTISAN STATE AUDITOR ALL
SAY THIS IS NOT THE WAY TO GO WE
NEED MORE OVERSIGHT NOT LAST I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU KNOW
VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK GOD SPEAKER MEMBERS OF I'M
I'M NOT GOING TO REITERATE THE
AYE COMMENTS UP --
BUT JUST WANNA.
UP SUGGEST SOMETHING HERE THAT.
THIS BILL DOESN'T HELP OR FIX OR
IN ANY WAY.
SOLVER IDENTIFIED THE KINDS OF
PROBLEMS THAT THIS PROJECT IS
FACING.
WE HAVE BEEN PROMISED A LOT IN
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA AND WHAT DO
WE HAVE.
WE ESSENTIALLY HAVE A RUMP
RAILROAD.
THAT WILL GO FROM JUST OUTSIDE.
MADERA.
THE JUST OUTSIDE BAKERSFIELD.
THERE IS NO MONEY AND NO PLAN TO
CONNECT THE THREE DISPARATE
PIECES OF THIS.
WE ARE SPENDING A LOT OF MONEY
IN THE BAY AREA A LOT OF MONEY
IN CENTRAL CALIFORNIA A LOT OF
MONEY.
SOME MONEY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
AND BY THE ADMISSION OF THE
BUSINESS PLAN.
OF THIS VERY ARE ARE
[inaudible]
THE OPERATION.
THEY HAVE ADMITTED.
THEY DO NOT HAVE THE MONEY AND
THEY DON'T KNOW HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO CONNECT.
THIS MULTI BILLION DOLLAR.
PROJECT.
PROMISES ONE THING PERFORMANCE
IS SOMETHING ELSE WE HAVE BEEN
PROMISED ONE THING WE ARE BEING
GIVEN SOMETHING ENTIRELY
DIFFERENT.
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA IS GETTING
CHEWED UP [inaudible]
BY.
A THE THE CONSTRUCTION.
CONSTRUCTION IN THESE HIGH OF
CONCENTRATED CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS DOES THAT.
THE QUESTION HOUSE BE WHAT IS
LEFT.
AFTER WE RIP UP THOUSANDS OF
ACRES OF PRIME MAG AFTER WE RIP
UP NEIGHBORHOODS THROUGHOUT.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA YES
THERE ARE SOME JOBS YES THERE IS
SOME MONEY.
BUT WHAT IS MOST IMPORTANT IS
WHAT DO WE HAVE LEFT AFTER WE
EXPAND LITERALLY BILLIONS AND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS. TWO AUDITS
ARE COMING [inaudible] TWO
AUDITS ONE OF FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND THE FEDS ARE GOING TO AUDIT
AS WELL THAT IS COMING
[inaudible]
MEMBERS [inaudible]
I I CAN APPRECIATE THE EFFORT IN
THE ATTENTION.
ON THIS BILL IT DOESN'T SOLVE
[inaudible]
ANYTHING [inaudible]
YOUR ATTENTION.
AND YOUR FOCUS BETTER BE ON
HOLDING THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
ACCOUNTABLE [inaudible] FOR
COMPLETING.
THE MULTI BILLION DOLLAR PROJECT.
AND NOT LEAVING ICE WITH A RUMP
RAILROAD.
AND UNTIL SOMEBODY CAN SHOW ME
THE PRINTING PRESS IN THE
BASEMENT OF THIS.
BUILDING THAT WILL SPEW OUT THE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS NECESSARY TO
COMPLETE IT.
WHAT THE PEOPLE OF CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA ARE LEFT WITH?
IS AYE ON COMPLETED MULTIBILLION
DOLLAR UPGRADE TO AMTRAK.
THAT'S NOT GOOD ENOUGH I URGE A
NO VOTE BUT I ALSO URGE YOUR
ENERGY. TO BE STEERED AWAY FRM
EXCUSE MAKING AND COVER UP.
TOWARD MAKING THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE FOR
DELIVERY OF WHAT THEY PROMISED
AND IF THEY CAN'T.
THEN TAKE IT BACK TO THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIANS SAY WE MESSED IT
UP WE CAN'T GET IT DONE.
HERE'S WHAT WE CAN DO HERE'S HOW
MUCH IT'S GONNA COST WILL YOU
GIVE US PERMISSION TO DO IT
AGAIN.
BUT I DOUBT THAT THAT IDEA WOULD
SEE THE LIGHT OF DAY.
MEMBERS YOUR OVERSIGHT IS
NECESSARY YOUR CAUTION IS
ABSOLUTELY APPROPRIATE IT IS
TIME TO BE TOUGHER ON HIGH SPEED
RAIL NOT EASIER.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
[inaudible]
NOT.
TO OVERLY ECHO THE REMARKS OF
ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES FROM FRESNO --
BUT WE NEED JOBS.
WE NEED INCREASE THE ECONOMY WE
NEED TO DO SMART THING.
BUT WE DON'T.
NEED TO PULL AWAY FROM OVERSIGHT.
AS A BODY.
ALL I'VE HEARD THIS LAST LITTLE
BIT A SESSION.
IS REMOVAL OF OVERSIGHT.
THAT'S ONE OF OUR PRIMARY JOBS
IS LEGISLATURE'S.
IS OVERSIGHT IS THESE AUDITS TO
GET THESE THINGS DONE.
WE'VE BLOCK THE NOT AT A DMV NOW
WE'RE GONNA PULL OVERSIGHT FROM
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL EVEN THOUGH.
THE FOLKS BEHIND ICE BUREAU OF
ALREADY TOLD US.
THEY'VE SCREWED IT UP AND DON'T
HAVE THE MONEY.
I SHOULD ON THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE I BEEN IN THOSE
HEARINGS HAVE BEEN IN THE CLOSED
DOOR HEARINGS.
THIS PROJECT DOES NOT AT ALL. TO
WHAT ARE VOTERS VOTED ON KNOW
WHERE I COME FROM WE GOT A REAL
SIMPLE SAYING.
DAMS NOT TRAINS.
WILL YOU BE A DOWNFALL TO VOTE
ON THIS ASK FOR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE I'M GONNA
RETURN TO HOME NUMBER ARAMBULA
FIRST CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS.
WELL T'S NO SURPRISE THAT THERE
ARE SOME PEOPLE IN THIS ASSEMBLY
WHO ARE NOT BIG PROPONENTS OF
THIS PROJECT.
THIS PROJECT MUST CONTINUE TO
BUILD MOMENTUM.
AND FOR US TO BUILD THAT
MOMENTUM WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO HELP TO STREAMLINE THIS
PROCESS.
AND DO SO MY COLLEAGUES ACROSS
THE AISLE I WANT TO SAY THAT
THIS DOES NOT REMOVE OVERSIGHT
THIS REMOVES BUREAUCRACY.
ARE YOU IN FAVOR OF MORE
BUREAUCRACY OR LESS.
I WOULD ASK THAT WE HELPED TO
STREAMLINE THIS PROJECT BECAUSE
TIME IS MONEY AND WE HAVE TO
HELP FIGURE OUT HOW TO MAKE THIS
MORE EFFICIENT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MADAM CLERK WAS OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLL AND HOLLY THE VOTES EYES
FORTY ONE NO TWENTY FOUR THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
WE MOVE NOW TO ITEM ONE SEVENTY
FOUR I'M SORRY WE'RE GOING TO
MAC MOVE BACK IN FILE ORDER.
BRIEFLY TO ITEM OF ONE FORTY
FOUR S. B. FOURTEEN TWELVE MADAM
FOR PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN TWELVE BY
SENATOR BRADFORD ACT NATURALLY
TO EMPLOYMENT THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THURMAN PURE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES ARE RISE TO PRESENT
S. B.. FOURTEEN TWELVE S.
CLARIFIES THAT EMPLOYERS SHOULD
ONLY USE BACKGROUND CHECKS TO
SCREEN JOB APPLICANTS FOR
RELEVANT EXPUNGE CONVICTIONS THE
BILL DOES NOT.
REINVENT THE WHEEL OR UP AND ANY
EXISTING RULES AMENDMENTS TAKEN
LAST WEEK HAVE REMOVED ALL
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
THESE AMENDMENTS ARE THE PRODUCT
OF STAKEHOLDER NEGOTIATIONS AND
REMOVE THE OPPOSITION OF THE
BANKING INDUSTRY.
I'M PLEASED TO REPORT THAT WITH
THESE AMENDMENTS OPPOSITION HAS
BEEN REMOVED BY THE CALIFORNIA
BANKERS ASSOCIATION.
THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE THE
CREDIT UNION LEAGUE THE
COMMITTEE BANKING NETWORK THE
MORTGAGE BANKERS ASSOCIATION AND
THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF CITIES
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU AND I SEE NO REQUEST
TO SPEAK MADAM PURPOSE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
BENEFIT YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY ONE KNOWS TWENTY THREE
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE MOVING NOW.
OUT OF FILE ORDER TO ITEM ONE
FORTY NINE S. B..
SEVEN TWENTY METAPHOR PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL SEVEN TWENTY BY
SENATOR ALLEN AND OTHERS AND I
PLAINTIFF BY MENTAL EDUCATION.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THURMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AND PLEASED
TO PRESENT SB SEVEN TWENTY WHICH
INCORPORATES ENVIRONMENTAL
PRINCIPLES INTO FUTURE CORE
CURRICULUM UPDATES. FOR K.
TWELVE EDUCATION STUDENTS IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE OUR STATE PASSED
THE FIRST ENVIRONMENTAL
EDUCATION LAW.
IN THE U. S. CREATING A SET OF
PRINCIPLES AND CONCEPTS FOR THE
GOAL OF FOSTERING KNOWLEDGE
ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT AMONG
SCHOOL CHILDREN.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE WAS NO
REQUIREMENT THAT THESE
PRINCIPLES BE INTEGRATED INTO
FUTURE CONTENT STANDARDS AND
CURRICULUM THIS BILL REINFORCES
OUR COMMITMENT. TO
ENVIRONMENTALLY LITERATE
POPULATION BY INCLUDING THESE
PRINCIPLES IN FUTURE CURRICULUM
UPDATES THE BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
BUT APART PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
ENTIRELY THE VOTES I SIXTY NO
FOUR THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE NOW RETURNING TO ITEM ONE
SEVENTY FIVE S. B..
ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE THE CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL ELEVEN EIGHTY
ONE BY SENATOR HUESO AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY TO EMERGENCY
SERVICES.
THANK YOU SOME EVER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER GOOD AFTERNOON SPEAKER
MADAM SPEAKER.
S. B. ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE WOULD
AUTHORIZE THE CALIFORNIA OFFICE
EMERGENCY SERVICE TO ENTER INTO
AN AGREEMENT WITH CERTIFIED
COMMUNITY CONSERVATION CORPS TO
PERFORM EMERGENCY OR DISASTER
RESPONSE SERVICES.
BY ALLOWING CAL O. YES TO
DIRECTLY CONTRACT WITH UTILIZE A
PREPARED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
DURING EMERGENCIES.
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE TIMELY AND
EFFECTIVE RESPONSE TO DISASTERS
WHILE SUPPORTING AT RISK YOUTH.
THIS AND BILL ENJOYS BROAD
SUPPORT AND HAS NOT RECEIVED A
NO VOTE I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE YOU KNOW REQUEST
TO SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON I MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THEIR AUNT
TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTEEN NINE
NO ONE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEMS ONE SEVENTY SIX THROUGH
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT PASS
TEMPORARILY ITEM.
ONE SEVENTY NINE S. B. TWELVE
NINETY TWO MEN APART PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWELVE NINETY TWO BY
SENATOR HUESO ACTUALLY TO
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE THANK YOU OF
SOME EVER KALRA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TO PRESENT SENATE BILL
TWELVE NINETY TWO THAT RELATES
TO ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE AND IS
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
CERTAIN COMMUNITIES.
S. B. TWELVE MONEY TO ACQUIRE
THE SENATE CENTER FOR HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES TO UPDATE THE
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE FACTS AND
FIGURES REPORT.
IN CALIFORNIA AND QUANTIFY THE
BURDEN OF THE HOUSE AS
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE ON AFTER
AMERICANS.
ASIA PACIFIC ISLANDERS LATINOS
AND WOMEN.
CALIFORNIA CERTAINLY A DIVERSE
STATE AND OUR LOW POPULATION
CONTINUES TO GROW PRICKLY WITH
THE ELDERLY AND THOSE AT SUPPER.
WITHOUT TIMERS DISEASE WHICH IS
WHY WE NEED INCREASE DATA
COLLECTION WITHIN ITS DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES.
EXPAND A RESOURCE FOR THOSE
AFFECTED WILL HELP CALIFORNIA
CAREFULLY CRAFT SOLUTIONS.
THAT ARE SPECIFICALLY TAILORED
TO THEIR NEEDS WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I BUILT ON
S. B. [inaudible]
TWELVE NINETY TWO THANK YOU.
I SEE NO REQUEST TO SPEAK THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE RIGHT ON
MEMBERS BOTH THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
BUT A PART PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TIDE THE BOATS I SEVENTY
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE WILL PASS TEMPORARILY AND
ITEM ONE EIGHTY AND MOVED ITEM
ONE EIGHTY ONE SP THIRTEEN
TWENTY ONE MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE
BY SENATOR MONNING AND OTHERS
AND I PLAYED A SCHOOL FINANCE
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CUNNINGHAM.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
S. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE
AUTHORED BY SENATOR MINING WILL
CLARIFY.
THE EXISTING ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS FOR RURAL SMALL
SCHOOLS THAT SEEK TO QUALIFY FOR
THE QUOTE NECESSARY SMALL
SCHOOLS FUNDING ALLOWANCE.
SOME OF THESE SCHOOLS FACE
UNIQUE CHALLENGES IN MY DISTRICT
ALONE AS ONE EXAMPLE THERE'S A
SCHOOL CALLED CARISSA PLAINS
ELEMENTARY.
IF GREECE A PLAINS ELEMENTARY
CLOSE DOWN STUDENTS WOULD HAVE
TO TRAVEL AN AVERAGE OF FORTY
MILES TO GET TO THE CLOSEST
SCHOOL.
S. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE WILL
ADD FLEXIBILITY.
AND ALLOW MORE SCHOOLS TO
QUALIFY FOR THIS IMPORTANT
FUNDING ALLOWANCE BE GOOD FOR
OUR STUDENTS AND RURAL DISTRICTS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEEN NO DISCUSSION THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
I MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW THE VOTES I SEVENTY TWO NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
AND ITEMS ONE EIGHTY TWO AND ONE
EIGHTY THREE AND MOVE TO ITEM.
ONE EIGHTY FOUR S. B. FOURTEEN
TWENTY TWO METAPHOR PLEASE READ
SEVERAL FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AND ACTUALLY
DRINKING WATER THANK YOU ASSERT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
I RISE TO PRESENT SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR PORTANTINO.
WHICH WILL REQUIRE THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
TO ADOPT REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
TESTING AND REPORTING THAT THE
AMOUNT OF MIGHT MICRO PLASTICS
IN DRINKING WATER FOR FOUR
CONSECUTIVE YEARS.
CURRENT WATER TREATMENT EFFORTS
DO NOT ACCOUNT FOR ALL MY TRUE
MICRO PLASTICS.
WHICH IS HOW THE FIBERS AND UP
IN DRINKING WATER.
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD ADOPTS IMPLEMENTING
REGULATIONS TO CONDUCT STUDIES
TO DETERMINE THE QUALITY OF
WATER.
THIS BILL WOULD ADD MICRO
PLASTICS TO THE LIST OF
CONTAMINANTS MONITORED BY THE
BOARD.
OUR IT WOULD NOT SET ANY LIMITS
ON THE MICROCLIMATE STICK.
THIS BILL IS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
THROUGHOUT THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS AND FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK.
MADAM PURPOSE OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE COULD SIRED.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLL
AND TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY
TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE ON ITEM ONE EIGHTY FIVE
SP.
FOURTEEN FORTY SIX CLERK WILL
READ CYNICAL FOURTEEN FORTY SIX
BY SENATOR GLAZIER AND OTHERS AN
AFFLUENT CAL WORKS THANK YOU
SUMMER BAKER YOUR RANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I PRESENT S. B.
FOURTEEN FORTY SIX BY CENTER
GLAZER TO GUARANTEE THAT CAO
WORKS BENEFITS TO CAO WORKS
RECIPIENTS THAT ARE.
MEETING THE FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS
CAN CONTINUE YOU MAY KNOW
FEDERAL LAW SETS THE AMOUNT OF
HOURS THAT SOMEONE RECEIVING CAO
WORKS BENEFITS MUCH WORK IN
ORDER -- TO
ATTEND SCHOOL IN RECEIVE THE
BENEFITS OR WORK FOR EXAMPLE A
SINGLE PARENT WITH A CHILD OVER
THE AGE OF SIX MUST WORK THIRTY
HOURS A WEEK IN ORDER TO RECEIVE
BENEFITS.
AND THEY HAVE TO ALSO HAVE A SO
CALLED WELFARE TO WORK PLAN IN
ORDER TO GET BACK ON THEIR OWN
FEET.
SOMETIMES WHAT HAPPENS IS THEY
ARE UNDERTAKING THAT PLAN THEY
GET A JOB THEY GET INTO SCHOOL
PROGRAMS AND THEY HOWEVER MISS
OF MEETINGS WITH SOME OF THE
LOCAL COUNTY AGENCIES BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT DURING BUSINESS
HOURS.
AND THEY ARE SANCTIONED AND AS A
RESULT EVEN THOUGH THEY'RE
MEETING THE FEDERAL WORK
REQUIREMENTS OTHER UNABLE TO
RECEIVE THE BOWL FULL BENEFITS
UNDER CAL WORKS WE WANT TO BE
SURE TO HELP PEOPLE.
I GET BACK ON THEIR OWN FEET AND
COMPLY WITH FEDERAL LAW I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROUTE.
MEMBERS WROTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
I MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
MEN APART PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TELL THE THE VOTES I SEVENTY
THREE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
WE ARE PASSING TEMPORARILY IN
ITEM ONE EIGHTY SIX AND MOVING
TO ITEM ONE EIGHTY SEVEN S. B.
FOURTEEN FORTY NINE METAPHOR
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN FORTY NINE
BY SENATOR LEYVA AND OTHERS
ACTUALLY EVIDENCE THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES I RISE TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
FORTY NINE BY SENATOR LEYVA.
THE BILL'S VERY SIMPLE BUT IT
WILL HAVE A TREMENDOUS IMPACT ON
THE LIVES OF VICTIMS AND
SURVIVORS AND ALSO HELPED PUT
RAPISTS BEHIND BARS.
THIS BILL SIMPLY CHANGES ONE
WORD IN EXISTING LAW BY SAYING
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCES
AND FORENSIC LABORATORIES SHALL
FOLLOW INSTEAD OF SHOULD FOLLOW
LISTA TIME FRAMES FOR SUBMITTING
AND ANALYZING RAPE KIT EVIDENCE.
ALL SURVIVORS DESERVE TO HAVE
THEIR RAPE KITS TESTED PROBABLY
WHICH IN TURN CAN HELP ENSURE
JUSTICE FOR SURVIVORS
IDENTIFYING ZERO PERPETRATORS
AND EVEN EXONERATING.
THE WRONGFULLY CONVICTED AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
I SEE NO REQUEST TO SPEAK MEDI
PURPOSE OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES I SEVENTY
THREE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
WE OUR ON ITEM ONE EIGHTY EIGHT
S. B. FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR THE
CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR BY SENATOR HELL AND
ACTUALLY THE TRANSPORTATION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR ALLOWS THE CPUC TO CONTRACT
WITH THE SIEGE PURE SHERIFFS TO
FORCE IMPOUNDMENTS.
A NUMBER OF AUDITS OF THE CPU
SEES TRANSPORTATION ENFORCEMENT
BRANCH OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS
OF INCLUDED.
THE BRANCH DOES NOT ADEQUATELY
ENSURE THE VEHICLES COMPLY WITH
STATE LAW.
OTHER AGENCIES LIKE THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD ALSO OF
STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO CONTRACT
WITH THE SIEGE PURE SHERIFF FOR
IMPOUNDMENT SO IT SEEMS
APPROPRIATE TO ALLOW.
THE CP YOU SEE TO DO SIMILARLY.
I WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS MEASURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I SEE YOU KNOW REQUEST
TO SPEAK MCCORKLE OPEN THE ROAD.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS OUR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM QUICKLY IS CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES I SEVENTY
TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM ONE EIGHTY
NINE SP.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ SENATE HEALTH
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR BY SENATOR
HERNANDEZ AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TAXATION TO AFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY.
THANK YOU SOME MEMBER CHEN
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT SP FOURTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR FOR MY COLLEAGUES IN
THE SENATE.
SP FOURTEEN BEFORE EXTEND THE
SUNSET ON TAX EXEMPTION FOR
RETAIL ITEMS SOLD INTEREST WORSE
OPERATED BY NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS.
PROVIDE COST FOR ME TO
CALIFORNIANS ARE LIVING WITH HIV
OR AIDS THE EXTENSION WILL BE
UNTIL JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY NINE LONG TERM
CARE CAN BE VERY EXPENSIVE AND
BECAUSE OF THAT TO PREVENT SOME
FROM SEEKING TREATMENT.
THE SALES TAX EXEMPTION HAS BEEN
STATUTES SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
SIX AND THAT'S THAT WE SENATE
SUNSET SO NONPROFITS CAN
CONTINUE PROVIDE THE MUCH NEEDED
FUNDING FOR CARE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN A NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES I SEVENTY NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES ITEM
ONE NINETY PASS TEMPORARILY ITEM
ON NINETY ONE PASS TEMPORARILY.
LIVING OUT ITEM OF ONE NINETY
TWO SP FOUR THIRTY NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL FOUR THIRTY NINE BY
SENATOR MITCHELL AND OTHERS
NATALIE TO JUVENILES THANK YOU
SOME MEMBER KAMLAGER-DOVE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I RISE TO PRESENT SENATE BILL
FOUR THREE NINE BY SENATOR
MITCHELL WHICH WOULD EXCLUDE
CHILDREN YOUNGER THAN THE AGE OF
DELINQUENCY JUVENILE COURT.
AND OVERWHELMING AMOUNT OF DATA
HAS SHOWN THAT CHILDREN UNDER.
TWELVE ARE INHERENTLY LESS
CULPABLE UNDER CRIMINAL LAW
GIVEN THEIR DEVELOPMENTAL
IMMATURITY.
pALL KIDS GO WITHOUT
REPERCUSSIONS FOR COMMITTING
CRIMES.
INSTEAD SERVICE IS NEEDED WILL
BE PROVIDED TO HELP THE CHILD
NOT TO SIMPLY PUNISH THEM.
THE MOST COMMON OFFENSE THAT CAN
THAT'S COMMITTED BY THESE
CHILDREN ARE MISDEMEANOR ASSAULT
AND BATTERY WHICH CAN BE SCHOOL
YARD FIGHTS.
IN HIGHER PROFILE CASES CHILDREN
CAN STILL BE WORDS OF DEPENDENCY
COURT WHERE THEY CAN BE REFERRED
TO SERVICES BY A JUDGE.
THIS YEAR THE BUDGET ALLOCATED
TWENTY EIGHT POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR YOUTH DIVERSION
PROGRAMS THAT WILL TARGET THIS
VERY POPULATION. FOR COUNTIES
THAT MAY NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES
TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO CHILDREN
UNDER TWELVE THESE FUNDS WILL
HELP BUILD THAT NEEDED
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THESE CHILDREN ARE STILL YOUNG
ENOUGH TO WHERE WE CAN SHIFT
THEIR TENDENCIES THROUGH
DIVERSION PROGRAMS.
WE MUST STOP CRIMINALIZING
CHILDHOOD ELEMENTARY AGE
CHILDREN HAVEN'T DEVELOPED THE
FULL CAPACITY TO MAKE
INTENTIONAL AND THOUGHT OUT
DECISIONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
YEAH THANK YOU MEMBERS S. B..
FOUR THIRTY NINE DEFTLY GOES WAY
TOO FAR.
ELIMINATES JUVENILE COURT
JURISDICTION FOR OFFENDERS UNDER
THE AGE OF TWELVE ALTOGETHER.
EXCEPT FOR THOSE CHARGED WITH
MURDER ENFORCEABLE SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
IT PROVIDES A LAN FORSTMANN IS
REQUIRED TO TURN A JUVENILE
UNDER THE AGE OF TWELVE OVER TO
THEIR PARENT OR GUARDIAN NO
MATTER HOW MUCH HARM THE CHILD
IS CAUSED.
NO MATTER HOW MANY VICTIMS WERE
INVOLVED.
NO MATTER HOW MUCH THE JUVENILE
NEEDS REHABILITATION SERVICES.
THINK ABOUT WHAT THAT INCLUDES.
THE LOS ANGELES DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
HAS A CASE WHERE ELEVEN YEAR OLD
WAS CHARGED WITH CONTINUALLY
SEXUALLY ASSAULTING. TWO OF HIS
COUSINS WHO WERE AGE SEX AND AGE.
TWELVE THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
THAT THIS JUVENILE RETURNED TO
THEIR PARENTS [inaudible]
BECAUSE THE ASSAULT IS NOT
CONSIDERED FORCIBLE.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT TRYING
THESE OFFENDERS AS ADULTS ARE
SENDING THEM TO LONG SENTENCES
TO JUVENILE HALL.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TAKING AWAY
THE TOOLS FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
HOLD THESE OFFENDERS ACCOUNTABLE.
AND PROVIDE THEM WITH
REHABILITATION SERVICES BEFORE
THEY BECOME HARDENED
[inaudible]
JUVENILE OFFENDERS.
THIS BILL JEOPARDIZES PUBLIC
SAFETY AND ELIMINATES THE
ABILITY OF THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM TO PROVIDE THEM WITH THE
APPROPRIATE REAL BILL
REHABILITATIVE SERVICES.
AND I CERTAINLY URGE OR NO VOTE
ON THIS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
CARILLO.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL FOUR THIRTY NINE IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A DIVERSION
SERVICES THAT EXIST.
THAT EXISTS OUTSIDE OF THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT ARE
BETTER DESIGNED TO ADDRESS THE
MENTAL HEALTH AND WELLNESS NEEDS
OF OUR CHILDREN.
YOUTH RECEIVE TREATMENT THROUGH
DIVERSION PROGRAMS HAVE AN 11%
RECIDIVISM RATE FOR A NEW
MISDEMEANOR OR FELONY ARRESTS
WITHIN ONE YEAR AFTER COMPLETION
OF SERVICES.
ADDITIONALLY 7072% OF YOUTH WHO
COMPLETED CLINICAL CASE
MANAGEMENT SERVICES LOWERED
THEIR RISK OF RECIDIVISM WITH
JUST THREE TO SIX MONTHS OF
SERVICE WE SHOULD CONTINUE TO
REFER CHILDREN IN NEED TO THE
SERVICES WHICH HAVE PROVEN.
HIGHLY EFFECTIVE WE NEED TO LOOK
BEHIND THE SCENES IN THE TERM
AND WHAT IS THE REAL STORY IN
OUR CHILDREN'S LIVES IN ORDER TO
DETERMINE THE BEST APPROACH. TO
ADDRESS THEIR NEEDS.
ALTERNATE SYSTEMS AND SERVICES
OUTSIDE OF THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM ARE BETTER SUITED TO MEET
THE NEEDS.
OF OUR VULNERABLE YOUTH WHILE AT
THE SAME TIME MAINTAINING PUBLIC
SAFETY WE DISCUSSED ON THIS
FLOOR.
THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE HAVE AND HOW SOMETIMES
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
INCARCERATE CY YOUNG PEOPLE AT
RATES MUCH HIGHER THAN REALLY
WHAT WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT AND
SO I I THINK THIS IS A STEPIN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION FOR
CALIFORNIA AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
YES MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB --
FOUR THIRTY NINE YOU KNOW WHEN
WE TALKING ABOUT A CHILDREN
OFTENTIMES WE DON'T LIKE TO TALK
ABOUT THE FACT IT.
OF HURTING OUR CHILDREN AND THIS
IS A BILL THAT BASICALLY HELPS
US TO BASICALLY RESTORE THEIR
LIVES THESE NOT ABOUT CORRUPT
PEOPLE THESE ARE CHILDREN.
AND THEY NEED OUR HELP WE NEED A
RESOURCE AREAS THAT WE SHOULD BE
REMOVING RATHER THAN PUTTING
MORE OF THEM UP --
WE CAN PROVIDE THESE CHILDREN
MORE APPROPRIATE SERVICES THAT
WILL SHIFT THEIR BEHAVIOR AND
PUT THEM ON A PATH TO PRODUCTIVE
MEMBERS OF SOCIETY.
BECAUSE IT IS EVIDENT THAT THE
SYSTEM IS NOT IMPROVING THE
LIVES OF THESE CHILDREN.
ACOSTA AFFILIATED WOULD
PROSECUTING A CHILD IS EXTREMELY
HIGHEST HIGHEST TO AND SEVENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER CHILD JUST
TO HOUSE THEM IN A CORRECTIONAL
FACILITY.
SO NOT ONLY IS IT A PROSECUTION
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED THE LIVES OF
THESE CHILDREN IS ALSO COSTING
US A HUGE AMOUNT OF MONEY AND
RESOURCES IS NOT VERY EFFECTIVE --
AS MEMBERS IT LET'S REMEMBER
THAT THESE ARE ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
CHILDREN OF CHIU A CHILDHOOD
AGED THEY HAVE WHAT THEY WERE
TALKING ABOUT.
AND WE NEED TO START TALKING
ABOUT REDUCING THE CRADLE TO
PRISON PIPELINE.
I'D LIKE TO SIMPLY ASK THOSE OF
YOU WHO ARE PARENTS AND
GRANDPARENTS A THINK ABOUT THE
FACT THAT THESE ARE ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL CHILDREN.
AND ADD YOUR OWN CHILDREN AND IF
THEY HAPPEN TO HAVE DONE
SOMETHING THAT WAS WRONG.
WHAT WOULD YOU WANT THEM TO DO
WOULD YOU WANT THEM TO BASICALLY
INITIALLY HAVE THEIR FIRST
ENCOUNTER WITH THE?
WITH BUDGET WITH THE U. OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM FIND
THEMSELVES IN A DIFFERENT SIGN
OF SITUATIONAL WOULD YOU RATHER
HAVE THAT SYSTEM WORK WITH YOU
AND YOUR CHILD YOUR FAMILY. TO
RESTORE THEM BACK TO CLOSE THAT
TO BE BASICALLY TOOK INDIVIDUALS
WHO CAN BE PRODUCTIVE.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU
AYE VOTES WITH THIS NOT ONLY FOR
THESE CHILDREN THAT WE DON'T
THINK ABOUT BUT MORE IMPORTANT
ABOUT YOUR OWN CHILDREN YOU OWN
GRANDCHILDREN YOU HOW YOU WOULD
LIKE THEM TO BE.
HANDLE IF SOME OF THIS HAPPENED
FOR THE SITE RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I VOTE FOR S. B..
FOR THIRTY NINE THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SCHABAS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
IT'S LIKE TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS -- BILL.
NO MEMBERS WE TALKED ABOUT THIS
WILL BE YESTERDAY NINE TO
RESTATE IT.
OUR SOCIETY IS REALLY SET.
GO TO THE PRESIDENCY WAS GOING
ON AND SEE ALL THE PEOPLE
PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE AND THERE
WERE WE HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
SOCIETY.
LOOK AT OUR SOCIETY IS WE
INCARCERATE TO ANY OTHER WESTERN
NATION.
WE HAVE A PROBLEM.
WE KNOW IN EDUCATION THAT BY
THIRD GRADE WE COULD SEE THE
CHILDREN THEY CAN'T READ CAN'T
KEEP UP.
THAT IF THEY DON'T CHECK IN BY
THEN IN EDUCATION THEY'RE
PROBABLY GONNA START HAVING
PROBLEMS THEY PUT THAT ANOTHER
WAY THAT'S AN EIGHT YEAR OLD AN
EIGHT AND NINE YEAR OLD CHILD.
WHO IS ALREADY FAILING THAT
THEY'RE NO LONGER HAVE A FUTURE
IN OUR SOCIETY?
BECAUSE THEY'RE BEING TOLD BY
OUR SCHOOLS THAT THEY CAN'T MAKE
THE GRADE.
WHEN I WAS A AYE COUNCILMEMBER
IN OCEANSIDE I TOOK PART IN THE
PROGRAM?
AND WE TALKED ABOUT PREVENTION.
THE VERSION AND INCARCERATION.
THIS PROGRAM WAS DESIGNED TO
MEET WITH YOUNG KIDS BETWEEN.
EIGHT AND FOURTEEN AND TALK TO
THEM ABOUT THE PATH THEY'RE
GOING.
AND YOU SAID IN A LITTLE ROOM
WITH THEM AND YOU JUST SHARE
YOUR STORIES AND LISTEN TO HIM
TALK AND I CAN TELL YOU IN DOING
THAT. FOR THE SEVEN YEARS I WAS
A COUNCIL MEMBER.
THAT I'D ALWAYS COME AWAY FROM
THEIR THINK IN.
IN MY CITY WE HAVE CHILDREN THAT
ARE BEING LOST.
YOU NO MEMBERS WE TALK ABOUT
SOCIETIES.
WHERE THE PARENTS?
THE MAJORITY OF THESE CHILDREN
THAT I SAW.
THERE ARE KNOW FATHERS INVOLVED
WITH THESE BOYS.
OUR FAMILY STRUCTURE WE JUST
THIS MESS.
AND WHAT'S HAPPENING IS OUR
CHILDREN YOU'RE JUST FALLING
THROUGH THE CRACKS.
WE HAVE A SERIOUS PROBLEM IN OUR
BRING.
THAT'S WHY I'M A BIG SUPPORTER
BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB.
ANY THOSE YMCA THINGS THAT WOULD
CHILDREN GO IN THEY CAN FIND OUT
SOMEBODY CARES ABOUT HIM
[inaudible]
THAT'S DIVERSION [inaudible]
THAT'S GIVE CHILDREN AN
OPPORTUNITY THINK JUST BECAUSE I
CAN'T READ AND WRITE AS WELL AS
THEIR BI ELSE IN THIRD GRADE.
MAYBE THERE'S SOMETHING I CAN DO
AND ARTS AND MUSIC OR OR
TECHNOLOGY OR GAME YOU OR
SOMETHING.
WE NEED TO INVESTED MORE THOSE
PROGRAMS DIVERSION SOCIAL
WORKING GIVING KIDS OPPORTUNITY
IN EDUCATION. TO WRITE OFF THE
TRIAL.
AND PUT HIM IN A CORD IN THE
JUVENILE SYSTEM WITH OTHER KIDS.
WHO KNOW ABOUT TATTOOS AS I JOB
BROWN WAS SOMEBODY I KNEW HOW TO
TAKE I KNOW HOW TO USE A NICE?
MUCH BETTER THAN A PENCIL WHEN I
WAS A KID.
THAT'S ABOUT THE LESSON YOU NEED
TO BE LEARNING.
YOU NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT YOU
DON'T HAVE TO BE THE ONLY KID
WITH THE FAT PENCIL ON THE END
TRYING TO DO YOUR LETTER REYES
WHILE THE OTHER KIDS HAD THE
MEISEL PENCILS WITH THE RACERS
AND THEY COULD.
THEY COULD THEY CAN ALREADY
RIGHT.
WE NEED TO REACH OUT TO THESE
KIDS.
I SOUGHT IN OCEANSIDE.
IT'S MUCH BETTER.
PUT PROGRAMS FOR DIVERSION.
AS DATA INCARCERATION IT'S MUCH
BETTER TO KEEP KIDS OUT OF THE
SYSTEM THEN PUT AMENDED THE
SYSTEM AND BRING IT BACK IN THE
SCHOOLS.
I STRONGLY RECOMMEND WE DO THIS
I'M GOING TO BE SUPPORTING IT.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
THESE ARE ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
CHILDREN.
AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL CHILDREN
GET IN TROUBLE WHEN THEY'RE
ACTING OUT.
BECAUSE OF THE TRAUMA THAT THEY
HAVE INTO WORD AS LITTLE KIDS.
CANNOT SOLVE A PROBLEM FOR A
CHILD BY LOCKING THEM UP.
BY.
JUST TRYING TO LOOK AT THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THEIR LIVES
WITHOUT ADDRESSING THE ISSUE OF
THEIR ENTIRE FAMILY WHAT SP FOUR
THIRTY NINE REALLY DOES IS IT
PUSHES THE FOCUS BACK ON THE
FAMILY AND THE SERVICES.
THAT CAN ADDRESS THE CAUSES THAT
PUT THE CHILD IN A POSITION TO
HAVE MADE THE MISTAKE THAT THEY
DID.
THAT THEY DON'T EVEN NECESSARILY
UNDERSTAND WHY OR WHAT THEY DID
TO LOCK UP A KID TO THROW THEM
IN COURT IS GOING TO TURN THAT
CHILD AWAY FROM THE THERAPEUTIC
REMEDIES THAT ARE GOING TO BE
NECESSARY TO ADDRESS.
THE THINGS IN THEIR LIVES THAT
HAVE GONE WRONG.
ADVERTISEMENT EXPERIENCES OR A
DRIVER OF SO MANY NEGATIVE
HEALTH IMPACTS NEGATIVE SOCIETAL
IMPACTS SO MUCH COST ON OUR
JUVENILE SYSTEM AND OUR COURT
SYSTEM DOWN THE LINE.
UNLESS WE AND THAT PROCESS THAT
HAS PUT US IN THAT PLACE UNLESS
WE FOCUS ON CHILDREN AND THE
THERAPIES THAT CAN HELP THEM AND
THE FAMILY SUPPORT THAT THEY
NEED THAT THOSE FAMILIES NEED.
TO PUT THE CHILD IN THAT
SITUATION BACK ON TRACK WE'RE
JUST GOING TO KEEP SPENDING MORE
MONEY MORE RESOURCES ON IS THIS
NEVER ENDING CYCLE THIS BILL IS
A IS A STEP IN THAT DIRECTION I
HIGHLY.
RECOMMEND IT AND AYE VOTE AS
BEFORE.
THIRTY NINE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MANAGE SPEAKER I THINK
ONE THING IS MISSING FROM THIS
DEBATE IS --
YOUR NEPHEW READ SOME OF THE
ANALYSIS IF YOU LOOK AT DOJ'S
OWN STATISTICS CHILLER TWELVER
RARELY EVER.
INCARCERATED IN A LOCKED
FACILITY IN THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
AND IN FACT BEING UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OF THE OF JUVENILE
DETENTION.
OF THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM
ALLOWS.
FOR REFERRALS TO SERVICES.
IN FACT SOME PLACES WILL NOT
EVEN TAKE SOMEONE.
THESE CHARITABLE GROUPS THESE
THESE THESE HOMES USED TO PLACES
WHERE THERE ARE SERVICES TO HELP
YOUNG PEOPLE.
THEY WON'T EVEN TAKE SOMEONE
UNLESS THERE IS A COURT REFERRAL.
AND IN THIS BILL THERE'S NOTHING
THAT PROVIDES FOR THOSE SERVICES.
ALL IT SAYS IS THAT THEY'RE JUST
NOT GOING TO BE UNDER THE
JURISDICTION.
OF THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM
IN THIS STATE SO IT DOESN'T
ACTUALLY PROVIDE THOSE OTHER
WAYS OTHER DIVERSION
[inaudible]
PROGRAMS.
IT JUST SAYS ARE NOT GOING TO BE
UNDER THE JURISDICTION ANY
LONGER OF THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM SO IT DOESN'T SOLVE THE
PROBLEM THAT I THINK.
MANY PEOPLE WHO STOOD UP AND
SAID -- IS
THE REASON FOR THIS BILL DOESN'T
SOLVE THAT ISSUE AND SO
[inaudible] TO ME.
WE SHOULD BE FOCUSED ON HEY HOW
DO WE IMPROVE THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM HOW DO WE ENSURE
THAT PEOPLE ARE GETTING IN THOSE
[inaudible]
PROPER SERVICES WE SHOULDN'T
JUST TAKE THEM OUT OF THE SYSTEM.
AND HAVE NO WAY FOR PROVIDING
THOSE COULD TYPE OF SERVICES. TO
TO THESE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO MAY BE
ON ALERT A WRONG PATH THAT
EVERYBODY IN THIS ROOM WANTS TO
SEE THEM GET ON THE RIGHT PATH --
AND IT ALSO DOESN'T TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THERE ARE SOME VERY
SERIOUS CRIMES --
OFTEN THAT THEY CAN BE THE CASE
HERE AND IF WE DON'T.
DO SOMETHING ABOUT THAT THERE'S
NOT CONSEQUENCES AND THERE'S NOT
THE APPROPRIATE SERVICES.
WE AREN'T GOING TO GET THOSE
PEOPLE BACK ON THE RIGHT PATH SO
I WOULD URGE A NO VOTE ON THIS
BILL TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MELINDA'S YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER --
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN I'D.
I DON'T DISAGREE THAT WE NEED --
TO LOOK DIFFERENTLY AT CHILDREN
WHO ARE TWELVE AND UNDER WITH
RESPECT --
TO BEHAVIOR IN CRIMES HE MAY
HAVE COMMITTED.
BUT I'VE I LISTEN TO THE
COMMENTS ON THE ONE HAND PEOPLE
ARE SAYING YOU NEED TO VOTE FOR
THIS BILL BECAUSE YOU DON'T KNOW
WHAT TYPE OF EXPERIENCE THAT
THESE KIDS HAVE HAD.
THEIR HOME LIFE A A LOT OF TIMES
IS DYSFUNCTIONAL THERE'S
VIOLENCE THERE'S DRUGS THERE'S A
WHOLE HOST OF THINGS THAT CAUSE
THEM TO ACT OUT IN THIS WAY WE
NEED TO HELP THEM IN THE SAME
BREATH.
THE BILL'S SUGGESTS THAT THOSE
ARE THE EXACT PEOPLE.
WHO WE WILL NOW IN TRUST TO
ADDRESS THOSE VERY PROBLEMS YOU
CANNOT HAVE IT BOTH WAYS?
YOU CAN'T SAY IT'S BECAUSE OF
THEIR HOME LIFE THAT THEY BEHAVE
THIS WAY.
AND ALSO SAY AND WE NEED TO
SWITCH WE RETURN THEM TO THAT
EXACT HOME LIFE SAID THEY CAN
FIX THE PROBLEM THAT DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE.
I AM I DON'T [inaudible]
I AGREED.
THAT SOME SERVICES NEED TO BE
PROVIDED THAT SOME INTERVENTION
CERTAINLY NEEDS TO TAKE PLACE.
BUT JUST DURING OUR HANDS IN THE
AIR AND SAYING GO BACK TO YOUR
PARENT OR GUARDIAN --
AND YOU FIX IT APPARENTLY ISN'T
WORKING [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEK HELP I'M SORRY IT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I KNOW.
I THINK WE ALL ALREADY KNOW HOW
WE'RE GOING TO VOTE ON THIS BILL
AND SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE.
THAT BEFORE WE CAST THE VOTE
THAT WE ALL UNDERSTAND.
THE FULL IMPLICATIONS OF THIS
BILL IN A PEOPLE SEVERAL PEOPLE
MENTIONED THE VALUE OF DIVERSION
PROGRAMS.
WELL HOW DO YOU THINK PEOPLE GET
REFERRED TO THOSE DIVERSION
PROGRAMS THROUGH THE JUVENILE
COURT.
YOU KNOW WE DON'T WANT TO PAINT
THIS FULL PICTURE WHERE.
I MEAN I I COMPLETELY.
AGREE WITH THE THEIR THERE THEY
THE THAT THE BASIC --
IMPETUS FOR THIS BILL THAT WE
SHOULDN'T BE PROSECUTING ó
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL KIDS.
I EN AND SYSTEMS BUT IF IT'S
COMPLETED THIS IGNORING THE FACT
THAT THE JUVENILE COURT SYSTEM.
IT IS A SYSTEM WHERE YOU HAVE.
JUVENILE COURT JUDGES MANY OF
WHOM ARE PUBLIC DEFENDERS MANY
OF WHOM ARE FORMER SOCIAL
WORKERS WHO TRIED TO MATCH UP
THE KIDS WITH THE SERVICES THAT
THEY NEED.
AND SO TO ENTIRELY EXEMPT YOU
KNOW ALL CHILDREN UNDER.
SEVEN AT TWELVE YEARS OLD FROM
THIS DEVELOP SYSTEM THAT TRIES
TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT IT THAT IS
THE MOMENT OF THE STATE
INTERVENTION TO EVALUATE WHETHER
THE SERVICES INCLUDING DIVERSION
PROGRAMS.
ARE APPROPRIATE FOR THE CHILD
AND SO [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS AT THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS
YOU'RE RECOGNIZE THE YOU
MINISTER YOUR MEMBERS THE YOU
KNOW I I HAVE TO AGREE WITH A
LOT OF THE PROBLEMS THAT I'M
HEARING.
YOU KNOW WE WE TALK ABOUT.
THE THE ROOT OF THE BECAUSE WE
TALK ABOUT THE HOME LIFE.
WE WHERE THESE CHILDREN ARE
COMING FROM.
BUT LET'S GET INTO THE DEEP
ROOTED THAT.
THAT THE FACT IS IS THEIR
PARENTS OR STOCK WORKING TWO AND
THREE JOBS BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
AFFORD TO PUT A ROOF OVER THEIR
HEAD AND FEED THEIR KIDS.
SO THEY'RE NOT HOME GIVEN THAT
QUALITY TIME WITH THE CHILDREN.
NOW WHY IS THAT MEMBERS.
MAYBE THAT'S BECAUSE WE KEEP
PASSING MORE AND MORE
REGULATIONS WE KEEP LAYERING ONE
THING AFTER ANOTHER AFTER
ANOTHER.
INCREASING THE COST OF LIVING ON
THESE FAMILIES WE'RE INCREASING
THE COST OF ELECTRICITY WE
INCREASED THE GAS COST
RECRUITING FOOD COST WE KEEP
THROWING ALL THIS STUFF ON THESE
PARENTS.
AND THEN WE TURN AROUND AND
BLAME SOCIETY.
IN THE LOCAL CULTURE BECAUSE ITS
SHELL BAD.
MEMBERS IS BAD BECAUSE WE AS
LEGISLATORS ARE MAKING BAD
CHOICES UP HERE IN VOTING FOR
NONSENSE BILLS THAT INCREASE THE
COST OF LIVING.
LET'S THINK ABOUT THE TRUE ROOT.
STOP TRYING TO BLAME IT ON
SOCIETY.
LET'S DO THE RIGHT THING HERE
LET'S KEEP THESE PROGRAMS GOING
THERE WE NEED BETTER PROGRAMS
FOR KIDS WE ALL AGREE ON THAT.
BUT MOVING A PROGRAM AWAY AND
BLAME IT ON SOCIETY.
LIFE SHOCKS WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
OUR PARENTS CAN BE THERE FOR
THEIR KIDS.
STOP BLAMING IT ON EVERYTHING
ELSE [inaudible]
VOTE NO.
THANK YOU MEMBERS IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK PLEASE RAISE YOUR
MICROPHONE.
SOME MEMBER THURMOND YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THE COMMENCEMENT KERR.
YOU KNOW MEMBERS ARE GOING TO DO
WHAT THEY'RE GOING DO ON THIS
BILL AMENABLE.
FOR BUT I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT.
TO S. B. REALLY DIRECT ABOUT
SOME OF THE STATEMENTS THAT ARE
BEING MADE ON THIS FLOOR RIGHT
NOW. TO SAY THAT WE HAVE A
JUVENILE SYSTEM THAT IS
DEVELOPED.
IS A MISREPRESENTATION.
YOU SAY THAT WE HAVE A JUVENILE
SYSTEM THAT IS SERVICE RICH THAT
HELPS ARE KIDS.
IS A FLAT OUT.
BOLD FACE LIE.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENS TO
YOUNG PEOPLE IN THIS STATE.
WHO IN A CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM?
BEING IN THE JUVENILE SYSTEM.
PUTS THEM INTO A CYCLE.
WITH A MORE LIKELY TO RE OFFEND
AND WHERE THEY ARE LIKELY TO END
UP AS ADULTS IN PRISON
[inaudible]
FACT.
THE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO HAVE
TOUCHED THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM IN THE STATE.
WE HAVE A RECIDIVISM RATE OF 70%.
OR MORE DEPENDING ON WHERE YOU
LIVE.
AND LET'S BE CLEAR IF YOU LOOK
AT A DISPROPORTIONATELY ALL OF
WHICH YOUNG PEOPLE END UP IN THE
SYSTEMS.
THE DECISION FOR WHO ENDS UP IN
THE SYSTEMS.
AND WHO GETS DIFFERENT TREATMENT.
IS MORE LIKELY TO BE BASED ON
YOUR ZIP CODE.
YOUR FINANCIAL SITUATION AND
WHAT YOU LOOK LIKE.
SO MEMBERS YOU GONNA DO WHAT YOU
GONNA DO.
I DON'T COME UP IN HERE AND SAY.
THERE WE HAVE A JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM THAT TAKES CARE OF OUR
KIDS.
IT IS A FAILED SYSTEM THAT NEEDS
REFORM.
AND THIS IS A MEASURE THAT IS
SAYING WE HAVE TO FIND WAYS TO
HELP YOUNG PEOPLE WHO'VE MADE A
MISTAKE TO LEARN FROM THAT
MISTAKE AND TO GET A CHANCE. TO
MAKE UP FOR WHAT THEY'VE DONE
AND TO LEARN TO LIVE A DIFFERENT
LIFE.
LET'S BE CLEAR I SPENT.
THE BETTER PART OF LAST YEAR
WORKING WITH A GROUP OF
TEENAGERS WHO ARE INCARCERATED
IN A JUVENILE CAMP.
THEY WORKED ON A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION TO PROVIDE BETTER
WRAPAROUND SERVICES FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE WHEN THEY LEAVE A
JUVENILE CAN'T.
THE PROBATION DEPARTMENT.
WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
EDUCATING THEM.
BROUGHT THEM WITH ME TO THE
CAPITOL TO INTRODUCE THE BILL.
PROBATION OFFICERS.
THERE ARE MANY WHO TRY.
THE BE SUCCESSFUL BUT DON'T EVER
SAY.
THAT THEY ARE THE SOCIAL WORKERS
AND EDUCATORS AND CARETAKERS OF
THESE KIDS.
THEY ARE NOT.
THEY'RE NOT TRAINED TO BE THAT.
AND THEY HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
DO THAT.
DO WHAT YOU GONNA DO.
DO IT BASED ON TRUTH AND BACKED.
IN THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS IF
YOU PUT YOUNG PEOPLE TO THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
IT IS CONTRIBUTING TO A LIFETIME
POTENTIALLY OF CRIME AND MORE
CONTACT WITH THE COME A JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
I'M VOTING FOR THIS AND I HOPE
YOU WILL.
TOO SOME MEMBER KALRA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I I JUST WANT RESPOND TO THE
SUGGESTION.
THAT THE ONLY WAY WE CAN GET
HELP FOR THESE CHILDREN THAT
DESK WE NEED HELP IS TO THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT
THEY MUST BE WARDS OF THE COURT
THEY MUST BE BUILT INTO THE
KERNEL JUSTICE SYSTEM AS OUR AB
COLLEAGUE JUST MENTION.
WE ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THESE
CHILDREN THERE'S A LOT OF
DIFFERENT REASONS WHY THEY END
UP POTENTIALLY OF IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM BUT WE
KNOW IT'S NOT THEIR FAULT WE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO BE ABILITY
TO BE A BILL TATUM THE BILL
ITSELF RIPPERS ARE BACK THAT
IT'S NOT LIKE THESE KIDS ARE
JUST.
GOING TO GO BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY AYE AND NOT BE
ACCOUNTED FOR THE REALITY IS WE
NEED TO BE RESOURCES TO THEM AND
SO INSTEAD OF SPENDING RESOURCES
LOCKING THEM UP.
OR HAVING TO GO THROUGH A VERY
EXPENSIVE COME A JUSTICE SYSTEM
INSTEAD WE CAN USE THOSE SAME
RESOURCES TO BRING SOCIAL
SERVICES TO THEM TO BRING
RESOURCES TO THEIR FAMILIES --
AND RECOGNIZE THAT THESE ARE
CHILDREN AND THAT UNLESS WE WANT
THEM TO GO DOWN A PATH THAT AT
THAT LEAVES THEM INTO PRISON
[inaudible]
OR WORSE.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
TAKE CARE OF THEM AT THE AGE AT
WHICH WE HAD THE BEST ABILITY.
TO AND LET'S TREAT THEM LIKE THE
CHILDREN THAT THEY ARE AND
RECOGNIZE THAT THEY CAN BE
REDEEMED IN SUCH A WAY.
THAT.
ONLY IF WE PUT THE RESOURCES
INTO THEM AND NOT INTO A FIELD
COLONEL JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT IS
BUILT.
FAR TOO MANY CHILDREN OVER MANY
GENERATIONS.
THANK YOU ALL DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE HAVING CEASED ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KAMLAGER-DOVE.
YOU IT YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
THE DIVERSE AND BIPARTISAN
CONVERSATION WE JUST HAD SOME
CLARIFYING POINTS IN MY CLOSING
IF YOU WILL THE VAST MAJORITY.
OF YOUNG CHILDREN CALIFORNIA WHO
HAVE BEEN ACCUSED OF AN OFFENSE
ARE EITHER EXHIBITING NORMAL
CHILD BEHAVIOR.
OR MINOR BEHAVIORS DID THAT DID
NOT REQUIRE ANY JUSTICE
INVOLVEMENT.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN SIX HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY SEVEN REFERRALS WERE
MADE IN CALIFORNIA TO PROSECUTE
CHILDREN UNDER THE AGE OF TWELVE
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE NUMBER OF
REFERRALS WAS SLIGHTLY LOWER.
AT SIX FIFTY TWO OF THESE
REFERRALS ABOUT 85% WERE CLOSED
OR DIVERTED AT THE OUTSET SO
DIVERSION WORKS BUT CHILDREN ARE
STILL BEING PROSECUTED.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
DEVELOPMENTALLY YOUNGER CHILDREN
ARE EVEN MORE VULNERABLE AND
SUSCEPTIBLE TO INFLUENCE AND
LESS MATURE THAN ADULTS AND
ADOLESCENTS.
IN THE MOST SERIOUS CASES THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
INDEPENDENCY COURTS ALREADY HAVE
THE DISCRETION.
TAKE JURISDICTION AND PROVIDE A
RANGE OF SERVICES AND SUPPORT
INCLUDING OUT OF HOME AND
REHABILITATIVE PLACEMENTS THIS
BILL DOES NOT INCLUDE SEX CRIMES
AND MURDER.
ONCE YOU'RE WELCOME [inaudible]
ONCE TOUCHED.
BY THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
YOU ARE FOR EVER TOUCHED BY THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
I DARE TO SAY THAT MANY OF US.
HAVE NEVER HAD THE EXPERIENCE OF
BEING ARRESTED OR PROSECUTED OR
JAILED.
AND WE SHOULD ALL BE VERY LUCKY
THAT WE HAVEN'T HAD THE
EXPERIENCES OF BEING TOUCHED BY
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM BUT
IT SHOULDN'T BE OUR PRIVILEGE.
THAT WE ARE PROTECTING.
IT SHOULD BE THE PRIVILEGE.
AND THE FUTURES OF OUR CHILDREN
SO WITH THIS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WITHOUT MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROOM ON MEMBERS BOTH THE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE COULD DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FORTY ONE KNOWS TWENTY ONE THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
SOME MEMBER CALDERON.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
PROMOTIONS AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE MOVE OUT OF ONE
SIXTY ONE SP FIVE EIGHTEEN
BERRYHILL TO THE ENACT FILE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND JOINT WILL SIX TO EIGHT
OF ALL NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO
ALLOW THE FOLLOWING COMMITTEES
TO ME TODAY.
UPON CALL OF THE CHAIR DURING
OUR LUNCH BREAK.
THAT ATLAS COMMITTEES ARE
AGRICULTURE TO HEAR AB TWENTY
FOUR SEVENTY GRAYSON IN ROOM ONE
TWENTY SIX BANKING AND FINANCE
TO HEAR AB TWO THIRTY SEVEN
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OF TO HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TO
HEAR AB FIVE SIXTY FIVE BLOOM IN
AB.
THIRTY SIXTY SIX STONE IN ROOM
ONE TWENTY SEVEN HUMAN SERVICES
TO HEAR AB FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
PATTERSON AND ROOM.
FOR THIRTY SEVEN JOBS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND THE ECONOMY TO
HEAR A. B. SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN
QUIRK SILVA AND ROOM.
FOR FORTY FOUR WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY
SIX ANDORRA SIXTY TWO A THE FONG
NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE
PROCREATION.
COMMITTEE TO HEAR AB TO THIRTY
SEVEN GONZALEZ FLETCHER TODAY
UPON ADJOURNMENT OF BANKING AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE.
AND ROOM FORTY TWO WILL DO THIS
BILL IS PENDING RE REFER OFTEN
BANKING AND FINANCE COMMITTEE
AND JUST TO CLARIFY THAT THE
PROPRIOCEPTIVE IT IS GONNA BE
ASKING TO MEET.
AT THE END OF SESSION.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER
.
MEMBERS THE FOLLOWING COMMITTEES
WILL MEET DURING THE LUNCH BREAK
LISTEN UP FOR THE ROOM NUMBERS
I'M NOT SAYING IT TWICE
AGRICULTURE ROOM ONE TWENTY SIX
BANKING AND FINANCE ROOM.
FORTY TWO OH TO HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT ROOM ONE
TWENTY SEVEN HUMAN SERVICES ROOM
FOR THIRTY SEVEN JOBS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND THE ECONOMY ROOM
FOR FORTY FOUR AND
APPROPRIATIONS WILL MEET UPON
ADJOURNMENT.
IMAM FORTY TWO A TWO MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO RECESS UNDER CALL.
ONLY THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEES.
MAY LEAVE DURING THE RECESS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS WILL IT WILL BE
RETURNING AT ONE FIFTEEN BY
ORDER OF THE MAJORITY LEADER
.
ONE FIFTEEN MEMBERS WE ARE BACK
IN SESSION PLEASE RETURN. TO THE
ASSEMBLY CHAMBERS
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
IF YOU WANT TO GET OUT OF HERE
TONIGHT.
AT A SOMEWHAT REASONABLE HOUR.
PLEASE RETURN TO THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBERS
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM
ONE NINETY THREE SB SEVEN EIGHTY
TWO MISTER CLERK PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL SEVEN EIGHTY TWO BY
SENATOR SKINNER AND ACCOLADES
ENERGY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER OR
WHEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER
CALIFORNIA'S ENERGY SECTOR IS
I'M GOING UNDERGOING
TRANSFORMATION BY BROADENING
ACCESS TO ENERGY INFORMATION.
NEW INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGIES AND
STRATEGIES WILL BE NEEDED TO
MEET CALIFORNIA'S ENHANCE
RENEWABLE GENERATION.
ENERGY EFFICIENCY TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION AND G. H. G.
GOALS AND S. B. SEVEN EIGHT TWO
WILL SPUR INNOVATION BY ENABLING
THE STATE'S ENERGY REGULATORS TO
UNLOCK ENERGY DATA BY REQUIRING
UTILITIES TO ACCEPT YOU
SIGNATURE INSTEAD OF WHAT
SIGNATURE. TO PROVIDE THIRD
PARTY ACCESS TO CUSTOMERS DATA.
AND CLARIFYING THAT COTTAGE
STYLE APARTMENTS FALL UNDER
CALIFORNIA'S BUILDING EFFICIENCY --
BENCHMARKING LAW.
AND THERE IS NO OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THINK YOU.
SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MISTER QUIRK WAS OPEN THE
ROLL-ON ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTES.
I WAS FORTY ONE NO ZERO R. I.'S
FORTY TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEM ONE NINETY FORCED PASS
TEMPORARILY MOVING TO ITEM ONE
NINETY FIVE S. B. TEN TWENTY
NINE MISTER QUICKLY ST.
SENATE BILL TEN TWENTY NINE BY
CENTER MCGUIRE ADEQUATELY
TRANSPORTATION TO MAKE THE
APPROPRIATION OF FOUR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY PRESENT SP.
TEN TWENTY NINE AFTER MONTHS OF
RESEARCH AND DISCUSSION LAST
YEAR.
WE WERE SAD TO CONCLUDE THAT THE
REBUILDING OF OF MUCH OF THE
DEFUNCT NORTH COAST RAIL LINE
WAS SIMPLY NOT FEASIBLE NOT
FEASIBLE ALTERNATIVE BOTH
FINANCIALLY OR PHYSICALLY.
THE REMOTENESS OF THE LINE THE
LACK OF SHIPPERS IN THE EXTREME
GEOTECHNICAL CHALLENGES ALL
COMBINE TO MAKE RAIL IMPOSSIBLE.
AFTER THIRTY YEARS OF TRYING
IT'S OBVIOUS THAT THE NORTH
COAST RAIL AUTHORITY HAS NO
ABILITY TO DEAL WITH THESE
CHALLENGES.
THEY RACKED UP NINE MILLION
DOLLARS IN DEBT.
HAVE VIRTUALLY NO STAFF THEIR
TRACKS IN CROSSINGS ARE
DISINTEGRATING AND THEY'RE
LISTED BY THE STATE IS A HIGH
RISK AGENCY.
WITH VERY LIMITED INCOME THEY
ARE FUNCTIONALLY BANKRUPT.
WE KNOW WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
MAKE THIS RIGHT AWAY INTO
SOMETHING SPECTACULAR FOR THE
NORTH COAST AND EVERYONE ELSE.
AND THAT'S WHAT IS BEFORE US
TODAY.
THIS DISTRICT THIS THIS DISTRICT
BILL RESOLVES A THIRTY YEAR OLD
ISSUE THAT IS ONLY GETTING WORSE
AND MAKE AND MORE EXPENSIVE THE
LONGER WE WAIT.
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES INCOME ANY COMMITTEE THIS
YEAR.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HARPER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I'M JUST GONNA
SAY IT'S GLAD TO SEE WHEN FOLKS
RECOGNIZE WHEN A PROJECT GETS
TOO BIG WHEN RAIL.
GETS TOO OUT OF CONTROL AND IT'S
TIME TO PULL THE PLUG ON THE
PROJECT WISH WE COULD DO THIS
WITH A HIGH SPEED RAIL AS WELL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEEING NO FURTHER
REQUEST TO SPEAK TO SOME EVER
WOULD WOLD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WITHOUT MISTER CLERK
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
SO MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
MISTER CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY FOUR NO ONE THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEM ONE NINETY SIX PASS
TEMPORARILY WE ARE MOVING NOW TO
ITEM ONE NINETY SEVEN SB ELEVEN
FIFTY FIVE MISTER CLERK PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE
BY CENTER HUESO ANOTHER CYNICAL
IN THE COURTS.
I'M SORRY WE ARE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON THIS ITEM.
PASS TEMPORARILY AN ITEM OF ONE
NINETY EIGHT MOVING OUT I AM ONE
NINETY NINE S. B. TWELVE TWENTY
EIGHT MISS QUICKLY ST.
SENATE BILL TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT
BY CENTER LARA ACCOLADE THE
PUBLIC HEALTH.
SOME NUMBER BLOOM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE TWENTY
EIGHT WHICH CONFRONTS THE
GROWING PROBLEM OF PATIENT
BROKERING AFFECTING PEOPLE IN
RECOVERY FROM SUBSTANCE USE.
DISORDERS AND IT WOULD PREVENT
TREATMENT FACILITIES FROM MAKING
OR RECEIVING PAYMENT OF ANYTHING
OR ANYTHING OF VALUE FOR THE
REFERRAL OF A PATIENT.
PATIENTS HAVE BEEN RECRUITED BY
UNSCRUPULOUS PROVIDERS WITH THE
OFFER OF CASH PAYMENTS OR DRUGS.
INDIVIDUALS WITH ACUTE MEDICAL
NEEDS HAVE A SADLY EVEN DIED
AFTER BEING REFERRED TO
FACILITIES.
THAT DID NOT MEET THEIR NEEDS.
INSURANCE FRAUD AND OVERBILLING
FOR MEDICAL SERVICES CAN ALSO
RESULT FROM PATIENT BROKERING.
IF THE DEPARTMENT INVESTIGATES
AND FINDS BROKERING IS OCCURRING
IT MAY TAKE ACTION AGAINST.
THE PROGRAMS LICENSE OR
CERTIFICATION.
CALIFORNIA BANS PAYMENTS IN
NEARLY EVERY OTHER AREA OF OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM AND IT'S TIME
FOR US.
TO STEP IN AND STOP PATIENT
BROKERING AND SUBSTANCE USE
TREATMENT AS WELL AND THEREFORE
AYE ELSEVIER AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK WAS OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
A DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TELLY THE VOTES ICE FIFTY NINE
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
MOVING OUT ITEM.
TWO HUNDRED S. B. TWELVE SEVENTY
TWO MISTER CLERK PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWELVE SEVENTY TWO
BY SENEGAL'S ANOTHER TONIGHT
LATE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ARAMBULA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
SENATE BILL TWELVE SEVENTY TWO
WOULD PERMANENTLY ESTABLISH A
TAX RECOVERY AND CRIMINAL
ENFORCEMENT TASK FORCE BETTER
KNOWN AS TRACE.
A TRACE TASK FORCE IS A STATE
WIDE MULTI AGENCY EFFORT THAT
FOCUSES ON INVESTIGATING AND
PROSECUTING INDIVIDUALS INVOLVED
IN THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY.
THE TASK FORCE WHICH ORIGINATED
AS A PILOT PROGRAM ONLY CONSISTS
OF TWO TEAMS HEADQUARTERS IN
SACRAMENTO.
RESPONSIBLE FOR INVESTIGATIONS
FROM BAKERSFIELD TO THE OREGON
BORDER AND LOS ANGELES
RESPONSIBLE FOR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
S. B. TWELVE SEVENTY TWO WILL
ADD THREE ADDITIONAL
HEADQUARTERS IN SAN DIEGO THE
BAY AREA AND FRESNO.
IT IS ESTIMATED THAT THE STATE'S
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY IS AS LARGE
AS A HUNDRED AND FORTY BILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
AND AS A RESULT THE STATE LOSES
AN ESTIMATED EIGHT POINT FIVE
BILLION IN CORPORATE PERSONAL
AND SALES AND USE TAXES EACH
YEAR.
THAT AMOUNT IS EQUIVALENT TO THE
RAINY DAY FUND.
SENATE BILL TWELVE SEVENTY TWO
IS VITAL GIVEN THE PERSISTENT
AND SIGNIFICANT NEGATIVE EFFECTS
OF THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY
INCLUDING LABOR LAW VIOLATIONS
CONSUMER RESTS UNFAIR
COMPETITION AND LOST TAX REVENUE.
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
WAS RECENTLY AMENDED TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS REGARDING THE SHARING
OF CONFIDENTIAL TAX INFORMATION
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIVEAU.
THANK YOU.
I SEE NO REQUEST TO SPEAK MISTER
QUICK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO GO.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND HOLLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
I AM SURE ONE WE WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY MOVING NOW TO ITEM
TO GO TO S. B. THIRTEEN TEN
MISTER QUIRK PLEASE HURRY.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN TEN BY
SENATE MCGUIRE ANOTHER SOME
ACCOLADE FISHING MAKING
APPROPRIATION OF FOUR TO CLEARLY
YOU SEE THERE UPS THAT PICKED
IMMEDIATELY SOME NEVER STONE.
THINK ABOUT SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
THAT DOESN'T IT'S CRAP FISHERY
IS THE TOP FISHERY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA GIVEN ITS
IMPORTANCE IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT DUNGENESS CRAB TASK FORCE.
WAS PUT INTO PLACE TO LOOK AT
ISSUES LIKE TO MARK AS SAID THE
SURVIVABILITY THE ISSUES AROUND.
THE DOZEN AS CRAB FISHERY THAT
REPORT ADDED THERE'S A REPORT
FROM THE TASK FORCE IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN S. B.
THIRTEEN TEN IS IMPLEMENT THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE FISHERY AND ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS I ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE ON SB.
THIRTEEN TEN THANK YOU I SEE NO
REQUEST TO SPEAK A QUICK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
MEMBERS THIS REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR
VOTES.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO RECOUP
DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY
EIGHT NINE NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY EYES FIFTY NINE NO ZERO
ON THE MEASURE THAT MEASURE.
WE ARE MOVING NOW. TO ITEM TWO
OR THREE SB THIRTEEN FORTY THREE
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN FORTY THREE
BY SENATOR MITCHELL AND OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE TO EMPLOYMENT SOME
EVER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER S. B. THIRTEEN FORTY
THREE REQUIRES THAT EMPLOYERS
WITH FIVE OR MORE EMPLOYEES
PROVIDE TRAINING ON SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PREVENTION TO NON
SUPERVISORY EMPLOYEES.
CURRENTLY NON SUPERVISORY
EMPLOYEES ARE ONLY INFORMED
ABOUT SEXUAL HARASSMENT
PREVENTION POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES THROUGH A POSTER THAT
NOBODY READS.
THIS IS LEAD TO MILLIONS OF
WORKERS NOT RECEIVING ANY
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR RIGHTS
THE TYPES OF BEHAVIORS THEY
SHOULD REPORT OR THE PROCEDURES
IN PLACE TO REMEDY THEIR
GRIEVANCES.
THIS BILL GIVES WORKERS THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO
ADVOCATE FOR THEIR RIGHTS TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES FROM SEXUAL
HARASSMENT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN KNOW DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MISTER CORPORATE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES WE ARE
GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY AND
ITEMS TO A FOUR AND TO ALL.
FIVE AND MOVED ITEM TO A SIX S.
B. FORTINO TO MR QUICKLY.
THREE SUITABLE FORTINO TO BUY
SEVERAL ARE ANOTHER SNACK LEAD
TO EMPLOYMENT SOME AMERICANS
ALSO FLETCHER.
THANK YOU I RISE TODAY TO
SUPPORT OUR TO ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT SB FOURTEEN NO TO THIS
BILL SEEKS TO AND THE
EXPECTATION.
A PORT TRUCK DRIVERS FOR BEING
LEFT BEHIND EVEN THOUGH
AMERICA'S ECONOMY WOULD NOT RUN
WITHOUT THEM.
SOME TRUCK DRIVERS END UP OWING
SO MUCH MONEY TO THE COMPANY
THEY'RE WORKING FOR FOR FOR THAT
THEY'RE BASICALLY WORKING FOR
FREE.
THEY'RE DRIVING PAST THE POINT
OF EXHAUSTION JUST TO FEED THEIR
FAMILIES AND THEY HAVE BEEN MANY
TIMES TO FIX THE MISTREATMENT OF
PORT TRUCKERS INCLUDING BY THIS
LEGISLATURE BUT TO DATE BASED
ALLOWED.
APPROPRIATE PROTECTIONS.
S. B. PORT YOU KNOW TO WILL
CLEAN UP OUR PORTRAIT CAN
INDUSTRY IN A WAY THAT IS FAIR
FOR EVERYONE.
IN ORDER THE DIVISION OF LABOR
STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT TO CREATE
A LIST OF COMPANIES WITH FINAL
JUDGMENTS FOR LABOR VIOLATIONS
INCLUDING WAGE THAT AN ILLEGAL
DEDUCTIONS.
THE COMPANIES ON THIS LIST HAVE
EXHAUSTED THEIR APPEALS BUT THEY
REFUSE TO PAY DRIVERS WHAT THEY
ARE OWED SP FORTUNATE TO WILL
HOLD RETAIL COMPANIES AND
SHIPPERS.
LIABLE WHEN THEY USE A TRUCKING
COMPANY ON THIS LIST LET ME BE
CLEAR IT'S NOT AUTOMATIC
LIABILITY AS THE FORTUNATE TO
GIVE THE TRUCKING COMPANY DUE
PROCESS AND AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PAY WHAT IT OWES BEFORE IT
APPEARS ON THIS LIST.
S. B. FORTINO TO GIVES THE
RETAILER THE OPPORTUNITY HER
COMPANIES THAT FOLLOW ARE LAWS
IN RESPECT THEIR WORKERS.
IT IS A MEASURED APPROACH TO
SOLVING A PROBLEM THAT HAS
PERSISTED FOR MORE THAN A DECADE
OUR PORT TRUCK DRIVERS ARE
CRITICAL IN THE GLOBAL SUPPLY
CHAINI KNOW THAT THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN BY THE AUTHOR HAS REMOVE
MUCH OF THE OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MISTER QUICK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE THE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
MR.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY TWO KNOWS TWENTY ONE THAT.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK. TO
ITEM.
ONE NINETY SEVEN S. B. ELEVEN
FIFTY FIVE MR CLERK PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL OF FIFTY FIVE BY
SOONER HUESO AND OTHERS AND I
BELIEVE THE COURTS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TO PRESENT ELEVEN EIGHT
SB LIVE FIFTY FIVE ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR HUESO.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT
REMOVES VARIOUS BARRIERS TO
HAVING?
APPROPRIATE INTERPRETIVE
SERVICES IN.
SMALL CLAIMS COURTS IN
CALIFORNIA IN COURT BECAUSE OF
THE RECENT BUDGET RESTRICTIONS
THAT THE COURTS HAVE SEEN REALLY
STRUGGLING TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE
WHO SHOW UP IN COURT.
ARE ADEQUATELY REPRESENTED AND
INTERPRETIVE SERVICES LANGUAGE
SERVICES ARE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT INSURE THAT JUSTICE
GETS DONE EVEN IN SORT OF THE
WORKHORSE OF THE DAY TO DAY
COURT SYSTEM OR DATED A CUT
PROCEDURES THAT WE HAVE IN OUR
COURT SYSTEMS.
THIS IS AN EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
BILL FOR CALIFORNIA AND FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION OF JUSTICE I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON S. B.
[inaudible]
ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE THANK YOU.
SEEING THAT NO DEBATE.
THE COURT PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS BOTH.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND HOW THE VOTES ICE FORTY NINE
NO.
ONE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE MOVE NOW MEMBERS TO ITEM TOOL
FOR S. B. THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT
BY SENATOR PAN ACCOLADE THE POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT S. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
PAT.
ALLIED HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
ACCOUNT FOR MORE THAN HALF.
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH CARE WORK
FORCE OF ONE POINT TWO MILLION.
WITH EMPLOYMENT EXPECTED TO GROW
TO A MILLION BY THE YEAR.
TWENTY THIRTY DRAMATIC WORKFORCE
SHORTAGES IN THE ALLIED HEALTH
PROFESSIONS ARE PREDICTED WOULD
ESTA MANY BEST ESTIMATES
PREDICTING A SHORTFALL.
A THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND ALLIED HEALTH WORKERS
BY.
TWENTY THIRTY IN ORDER FOR
DECISION MAKERS TO CRAFT
[inaudible]
SEVERAL STRATEGIES ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIANS ARE NOT DENIED
CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE AND
NECESSARY HEALTH CARE.
AND TO ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA IS
SUCCESSFULLY LEVERAGING EXISTING
RESOURCES. TO PROMOTE PATHWAYS
FROM LOW TO MIDDLE INCOME
PROFESSIONS.
STATE REQUIRES ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW ALLIED
HEALTH CARE EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS
OPERATE.
THE BILL PROVIDES UNNECESSARY
REPORTING. TO HELP IMPROVE OUR
PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS AND REACT
THOUGHTFULLY TO GROWING
WORKFORCE NEED.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEING THAT NO DISCUSSION.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK MAKE CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELE THE VOTES EYES FORTY ONE
KNOWS.
TWENTY ONE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING NOW TO
ITEM.
TWO OH EIGHT S. B. FOURTEEN
FORTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN
BY CENTER HERNANDEZ ANOTHER
TONIGHT RELATE HEALING ARTS
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES EXISTING LAW
ALLOWS FOR THE USE OF AUTOMATED
DRUG DELIVERY SYSTEMS.
DISPENSED MEDICATION TO PATIENTS
HOWEVER THE CURRENT LAW LIMITS
THE TYPE OF HEALTH CARE SETTINGS
IN WHICH AUTOMATED DRUG DELIVERY
SYSTEMS ARE UTILIZED.
SB FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN SIX TO
IMPROVE THE BOARD OF PHARMACY'S
ABILITY TO REGULATE AUTOMATED
DRUG DELIVERY SYSTEMS.
IT IS SPECIFICALLY ESTABLISHES
OUR LICENSING FRAMEWORK WHICH
WOULD ALLOW THE BOARD TO TRACK
AND ENSURE THAT APPROPRIATE
PROTOCOLS ARE BEING FOLLOWED TO
PROTECT PATIENT SAFETY ACCESSED
A PHARMACIST CARE.
AND PREVENT DOUGLAS THIS BILL
WILL ALLOW FOR GREATER ACCESS TO
PHARMACY SERVICES AND IMPROVE
CARE FOR PEOPLE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I SEE NO REQUEST TO SPEAK MISTER
QUICK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
A DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE HER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE ON
TELLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY EIGHT
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
I AM SURE NINE PASS TEMPORARILY
MOVING TO ITEM TWO TEN S. B.
FOURTEEN OF SIXTY FIVE MISTER
QUICKLY.
THREE SENATE BILL FOURTEEN SIXTY
FIVE BY CENTER HILL AND OTHERS
AND ACT LIKE A PROFESSIONS AND
VOCATIONS SENATE MEMBER EGGMAN
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED THINK VERY
MUCH MAN SPEAKER MEMBERS.
AFTER THE TRAGIC BERKELEY
COLLAPSE IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
TO LEGISLATE LET LEGISLATURE
REQUIRED THERE CONTRACTOR STATE
LICENSING BOARD TO STUDY.
WHETHER OR NOT THEY WOULD
BENEFIT FROM RECEIVING
CONSTRUCTION DEFICIT SETTLEMENTS
FROM THEIR LICENSEES.
THIS BILL IMPLEMENTS THAT
RECOMMENDATION BY REQUIRING
CONTRACTORS REPORT CONSTRUCTION
DEFICIT SETTLEMENTS OVER A
MILLION DOLLARS ON APARTMENT
BUILDINGS.
THIS BILL WILL HELP THE
CONTRACTOR STATE LICENSING BOARD
FULFILL THEIR MISSION.
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC ALL
OPPOSITION HAS BEEN REMOVED AND
I WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN NO DISCUSSION THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY FOUR
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM TWO ELEVEN S.
B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY BY
CENTER HILL ANOTHER SNACK LATER
PROFESSIONS AND LOCATIONS OF
MAKING APPROPRIATION OF FOUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MENACE YOU CAN MEMBERS THIS IS A
SERIES OF SENSE THAT CLEAN UP
BILLS S. B.. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DEBATE THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED ZIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
A TALLY THE VOTES EYES FORTY SIX
NO.
TWELVE THAT MEASURE PASSES
MOVING TO ITEM TWO TWELVE SP
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE MISTER
QUICKLY ST.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE
BY CENTER HILL ANOTHER'S AND
ACTUALLY THE STRUCTURAL PEST
CONTROL ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MINISTER CAN
MEMBERS THIS IS THE STRUCTURAL
PEST CONTROL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
SUNSET BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM THE CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY SIX
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM TWO THIRTEEN S.
B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE MISTER
COR PLEASE THREE SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE BY CENTER
HILL AND I PLAYED PROFESSIONS
VOCATIONS.
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MINUTES SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS IS
THE BUREAU OF ELECTRONIC AND
APPLIANCE REPAIR HOME
FURNISHINGS AND THERMAL
INSULATION SUNSET BILL
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I SEE NO REQUEST TO SPEAK THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK AND
FILE ORDER TO ITEM ONE FIFTY S.
B.. TEN OVER.
ONE MR CLERK FISHERIES.
SENATE BILL TWO NO ONE BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG AND OTHERS AND
I PLAY THE BOTS THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
SP.
ONE THOUSAND ONE MAKES IT
UNLAWFUL FOR A PERSON TO USE A
BOT.
WITHOUT DISCLOSING THAT THE
ACCOUNT BEING USED.
TO COMMUNICATE ON AN ONLINE
PLATFORM IS A BOT WHEN SELLING
SOMETHING OR INFLUENCING A VOTE
IN ELECTIONS.
WHAT'S CAN MASQUERADE THEMSELVES
AS UNIQUE INDIVIDUALS AND BE
WEAPONIZED TO SPREAD MISLEADING
INFORMATION THIS BILL SHED SOME
LIGHT ON THESE AUTOMATED
ACCOUNTS BECAUSE ANY PERSON
DESERVES TO KNOW.
WHEN THEY'RE INTERACTING WITH
THE PLOT OR WITH ANOTHER PERSON?
BOTS WHEN PROPERLY IDENTIFY CAN
EXIST POSITIVELY IN A SOCIAL
MEDIA ECOSYSTEM I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE MISTER OBERNOLTE.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER IN COMMITTEE I
VIGOROUSLY OPPOSE THIS BILL --
SENATOR HERTZBERG MADE A
COMMITMENT TO WORK WITH ME TO
TRY AND IMPROVE THE BILL AND TO
HIS CREDIT HE DID THAT.
RECENT AMENDMENTS MAKE THIS BILL
SUPPORTABLE AND REMOVE MY
CONCERNS THAT THE SCOPE OF THE
BILL EXPANDS BEYOND WHAT THE
SENATOR OUR CAUSE --
TO OF THE PROBLEM THE SENATOR
HOPE TO SOLVE AN URGENT AYE VOTE
WITH THOSE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU SEEN NO FURTHER
REQUEST TO SPEAK THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS BOTH
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTES ICE FIFTY FIVE
KNOWS NINE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE MOVING OUT UP BACK IN
FILE ORDER TO ITEM.
TO FOURTEEN S. B. FIVE THIRTY TO
THE PURPLE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTY TWO BY
SENATOR DODD NATALIE INTO
EMERGENCY SERVICES THANK YOU S.
I NEVER AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
I THINK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
A LOT S. B. FIVE THIRTY TO ADS
CYBERTERRORISM TO THE LIST OF
CONDITIONS THAT ARE NAMED IN THE
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY SERVICES
ACT.
WHICH CONSTITUTES A STATE OF
EMERGENCY.
A CYBER TERRORISM BECOMES MORE
OF A THREAT TO OUR GOVERNMENTS
AND PRIVATE BUSINESSES IT IS
IMPORTANT AS CYBERTERRORISM BE
ADDED TO THE LIST.
THIS BILL PROVIDES THE GOVERNOR
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WITH THE
NECESSARY TOOLS TO QUICKLY
RESPOND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE.
ON S. B..
FIVE THIRTY TWO THANK YOU
EXACTLY OCCURRED.
SAYING NO DISCUSS HER DEBATE ON
THE ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
THIS ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
HAD A VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE.
CALVET I SIXTY FOUR KNOWS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM.
TO FIFTEEN AND WE ARE GOING TO
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ADAMS
TO SEVENTEEN AND TO EIGHTEEN
MEMBERS I BELIEVE WHERE IT FILE
ITEM.
TO NINETEEN S. B..
THIRTEEN OH THREE CORPORATE
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN NO THREE BY
SENATOR PAN AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
THANK YOU MISTER AND SPEAK
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT SP THIRTEEN HO
THREE ON BEHALF OF SENATOR PAN.
S. B. THIRTY NO THREE WOULD
REQUIRE THAT THE OFFICE OF THE
SHERIFF CORONER BE REPLACED BY
MEDICAL EXAMINER'S OFFICE IN
COUNTIES WITH A POPULATION OF
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND OR REQUIRE
THOSE COUNTIES TO INSTITUTE A
POLICY.
WHEREBY CASES INVOLVING CONFLICT
OF INTERESTS WITH THE SHERIFF
ARE REFERRED TO AN ADJACENT
COUNTY WITH A MEDICAL EXAMINER
MODEL.
S. B. THIRTY NO THREE IS THE
SENSUAL TO ENSURE INTEGRITY IN
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AND ENSURE THAT MEDICAL
DETERMINATIONS REGARDING DEATH
INVESTIGATIONS ARE SAFEGUARDED
FROM UNDUE INFLUENCE BY NON
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS.
UNDER OUR CURRENT SYSTEMS
CORONERS AND MEDICAL EXAMINERS
ARE OFTEN CONSTRUED AS THE SAME
PROFESSION WHEN IN FACT THEY ARE
QUITE DIFFERENT.
THE SHERIFF CORONER IS AN
ELECTED POSITION THAT DOESN'T
REQUIRE ANY MEDICAL OR POLICE
TRAINING.
IN SHERIFF CORONER MODELS THE
MEDICAL EXAMINER CONDUCTS THE
AUTOPSY AND DETERMINES THE CAUSE
OF DEATH LIKE CARDIAC FAILURE
DROWNING.
BLUNT FORCE TRAUMA EXCEPT AROUND
BUT THE SHERIFF RETAINS THE
FINAL SAY OVER MANNER OF DEATH
Y. HOMICIDE.
ACCIDENT NATURAL CAUSES EVEN IF
THE MEDICAL EXAMINER DISPUTES
THE SHERIFF'S FINDINGS. FOR MANY
THIS NOTION IS INSANE IN THE
MEMBRANE.
AND THIS IS WHY TRUE STORY.
DOCTORS BENNETT I'M A LIEU AND
SUSAN PARSON RESIGNED LATE LAST
YEAR AS SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
MEDICAL EXAMINER'S ALLEGING THAT
SHERIFF STEVE MOORE UNDULY
PRESSURED THE PHYSICIANS TO
CHANGE THEIR MEDICAL
DETERMINATIONS.
INTO THE CAUSES OF DEATH OF
INDIVIDUALS INVOLVED IN OFFICER
RELATED SHOOTINGS TO ACCIDENTS
THE PHYSICIANS KEPT HUNDREDS OF
PAGES OF MEMOS.
DETAILING THE ALLEGED ABUSES
COMMITTED BY THE SHERIFF'S
OFFICE WHICH INCLUDE PRESSURE
FROM THE SHERIFF TO CHANGE
HOMICIDE DETERMINATIONS TO
ACCIDENT.
IN ADEQUATE INVESTIGATIONS
WITHHOLDING OF INFORMATION AND
BODY DISMEMBERMENT WITHOUT
POSITION APPROVAL.
THE ROLE OF THE CORONER OR
MEDICAL EXAMINER IN OUR CRITICAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM REQUIRES THAT
THESE INDIVIDUALS ETHICALLY.
CARRY OUT THEIR JOB TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE THE NECESSARY FACTS
TO DETERMINE FAULT AND DELIVER
JUSTICE IT HAS BECOME CLEAR THAT
THE SHERIFF CORNER MODEL
FRUSTRATES THIS GOAL BY PLACING
THE SHERIFF IN A CONFLICTED
POSITION.
OF INVESTIGATING ONE OF THEIR
OWN MEMBERS.
SWITCHING TO A MEDICAL EXAMINER
MODEL ONLY IN COUNTIES WITH THE
RESOURCES TO DO SO INSURES THAT
POSITIONS PROFESSIONAL JUDGMENT
IS NEVER COMPROMISED AND
CALIFORNIANS ARE PRESENTED WITH
THE TRUTH WHATEVER THAT MAY BE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS KAMLAGER-DOVE
SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
[inaudible]
I'M SORRY [inaudible]
DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN OH THREE
AND I WANTED TO SHARE A THE CASE
THAT WE REFERENCED EARLIER IN
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY.
THAT OCCURRED IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WITH DR AMALA.
IN THIS SPECIFIC CASE THE
SHERIFF USED HIS POLITICAL
OFFICE AS THE CORNER TO
INFLUENCE THE MEDICAL FINDINGS
OF THE CHIEF FORENSIC OFFICER.
IN CASES WHERE OFFICERS WERE
INVOLVED IN THE PERSON'S DEATH.
THIS POWER OF THE SHERIFF
CORONER ALLOWED HIM TO OVERRIDE
THE AUTHORITY OF THE CHIEF
FORENSIC PATHOLOGIST TASKED WITH
PERFORMING THE AUTOPSIES IN THIS
COUNTY.
EVEN THOUGH THE SHERIFF CORNER
POSITION DOES NOT REQUIRE ANY
MEDICAL OR POLICE TRAINING.
HOW CAN WE ALLOW? FOR ANY
OUTSIDE THIRD PARTY INFLUENCE TO
INTERFERE WITH OUR MEDICAL
EVIDENCE BASED EXAMINATIONS
ESPECIALLY IN CAUSES OF DEATH.
THIS BILL REPLACES THE OFFICE OF
THE CORNER WITH THE OFFICE OF
THE MEDICAL EXAMINER WHO IS A
LICENSED PHYSICIAN WHO PERFORMS
MEDICAL AUTOPSIES.
AFTER SUSPICIOUS DEATHS BY
ENACTING THIS BILL WE WILL
REMOVE ANY POTENTIAL CONFLICT OF
INTEREST BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND MEDICAL DETERMINATIONS IN
THE CASE OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER RELATED DEATHS.
BY ENACTING THIS BILL WE WILL
ALLOW PROFESSIONALLY TRAINED
MEDICAL EXAMINERS TO DO THEIR
JOB WELL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE [inaudible]
DOCTOR EGGMAN.
BUT THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS ESSENCE EVERYONE'S
TALKING ABOUT MY COUNTY TODAY I
THOUGHT I'D GET UP AND SAY
SOMETHING AS WELL --
SB THIRTEEN OH THREE CERTAINLY
CAME FROM A SITUATION MY COUNTY
IN WHICH WE GET A FULL
INVESTIGATION AND THERE WERE
CERTAINLY ISSUES TO BE FOUND ON
BOTH SIDES OF THIS ISSUE.
I THINK ANY TIME YOU HAVE BUT TO
AND AM AND MAYBE THE ISSUE IS WE
NEED A LOT MORE WOMEN IN
LEADERSHIP I THINK.
ANY TIME YOU HAVE A VERY STRONG
POWERFUL MEN HOLDING TO
POSITIONS SOMETIMES THERE ARE
CONFLICTS A AROUND TERRITORY
EMPOWER --
AND SO THERE WERE FINDINGS THAT
THAT WERE LESS THAN CONCRETE I
THINK ABOUT.
A IF THERE WAS A WRONG THAT
DOING BEING DONE UP BUT IN LIGHT
OF THAT MY COUNTY TOOK IT UPON
THEMSELVES TO DO A FULL
INVESTIGATION AND LOOK INTO IT
AND HAVE SEPARATED THE TWO
OFFICES AND ARE SETTING UP.
A A SEPARATE CORNERS OFFICE
SEPARATE FROM THE SHERIFF'S
OFFICE UP WE HAVE DONE THAT WE
ARE WORKING ON DOING THAT AS
ANYBODY WHO KNOWS WHO HAS SERVED
IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT THOSE THINGS
YOU CAN'T JUST.
FIRE TWITCH HER NOSE AND CREATE
A WHOLE NEW DEPARTMENT IT TAKES
WILL BE A TIME OF IT WHICH IS
WHY WE HAVE BEEN OPPOSED TO THIS.
I DON'T THINK THE OF DID
IMPLEMENT.
DOUBLE AS WE CAN DO IT IN THE
MANNER A THAT THE OPPONENTS
WOULD BE ARGUING THAT THEY
WANTED DONE WELL AND
PROFESSIONAL ó AND I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT THOSE THINGS TAKE
A LITTLE TIME.
SO WE'RE ALREADY MOVING DOWN
THIS PATH I APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY'S CONCERNED ABOUT MY
COUNTY A AND I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS TODAY BUT I
AGAIN I THINK AB I THINK
EVERYBODY FOR THEIR CONCERN.
SAY NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
ON THE ITEM.
MISS KAMLAGER-DOVE YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS
BILL SIMPLY OFFERS A WAY TO HAVE
AN ETHICAL AUTOPSIES CURRENTLY
NO SHARE HALF.
ALSO HAS A PRACTICING MEDICAL
LICENSE I WANT TO REITERATE THAT
THIS IS NOT A MANDATE BUT SAYS
THAT WHERE THERE ARE FUNDS TO DO
SO AND WITH POPULATIONS OVER.
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND THAT THIS
BILL WOULD ALSO ONLY IMPACTS SIX
COUNTIES IN THE STATE ONCE AGAIN
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
AND WITHOUT THE CLERK LOCAL
ROLL-ON VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
MAN IS KAMLAGER-DOVE DOVE MOVES
TO CALL.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK [inaudible] TO
RECONSIDERATION ITEMS THIS IS
FILE ITEM.
ONE TWENTY SEVEN S. B. NINE
FIFTY EIGHT THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL NINE THIRTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR GOT ACCOLADES SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
IS ANY MEMBER OF JACKED. TO
HEARING THIS ITEM [inaudible]
ON RECONSIDERATION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
RECONSIDERATION IS GRANTED.
CARPOOL READ THE BILL.
SENATE BILL NINE FIFTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR DOT MAC LEGAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
MS AGUILAR CURRY.
WE DOES SIMPLY ASK FOR IVAN SP
NINE FIFTY EIGHT A BILL FOR THE
DAVIS UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEE NO DISCUSSION [inaudible]
QUIRK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE IS THERE TO
VOTE
.
MS AGUILAR CURRY.
MOVES A CALL.
WE ARE GOING. TO ALLOW MS BURKE
TO TAKE UPPER ITEMS.
ITEM SINGULAR THIS IS.
FILE ITEM.
TO SIXTEEN S. B. TWO THIRTY
SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL TWO THIRTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG AN ACCOLADE TO
LECTURE CITY THIS PARK THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS SP TWO
THIRTY SEVEN DIRECTS THE QC TO
EXPAND THE VERY POPULAR DIRECT
ACCESS PROGRAM BY FOUR THOUSAND
GIGAWATT HOURS.
OR FIFTEEN HUNDRED MEGAWATTS
THIS BILL ALSO REQUIRES A PC TO
PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
ON IMPLEMENTING FURTHER DIRECT
TRANSACTIONS FROM NON
RESIDENTIAL CUSTOMERS BY JUNE
FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY THE
ELECTRICITY PRODUCED THROUGH
DIRECT ACCESS IS JUST AS CLEAN
AS I YOU POWER IT NEEDS ALL THE
OUR PSG EACH YEAR MISSION AND
CRITERIA POLLUTANT LAWS.
CUSTOMERS CAN SAVE SUBSTANTIAL
AMOUNTS OF MONEY RIGHT NOW
THROUGH DIRECT ACCESS PROGRAMS
IMAGE SIZE MANUFACTURE CONCEDE
ANYWHERE FROM A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND TO THREE HUNDRED
SEX AND SIXTY THOUSAND PER YEAR.
THE LARGEST USERS CAN SAVE TWO
MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR A
TYPICAL YOU SEE OR CSU SAVES
CLOSE TO ONE MILLION DOLLARS PER
CAMPUS.
DIRECT ACCESS HAS NOT BEEN RE
OPEN SINCE TWO THOUSAND NINE
WHICH WAS KEY HOA AS B..
SIX NINETY FIVE THERE'S A LARGE
WAITING LIST OF CUSTOMERS
BUSINESSES HIGHER EDUCATION K.
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
HOSPITALS AND PUBLIC AGENCIES
WHO WANT TO BUY MORE ELECTRICITY
THROUGH DIRECT ACCESS.
THE COMPANIES TO PROVIDE THE
POWER THROUGH DIRECT ACCESS
ENERGY SERVICE PROVIDERS HAVE TO
COMPETE FOR BUSINESS.
THIS COMPETITION FORCES THEM TO
FIND THE BEST DEAL THEY CAN'T A
RIGOROUSLY COMPETE WITH EACH
OTHER THIS CREATES DOWNWARD
PRESSURE ON PRICES.
AS BE TO THIRTY SEVEN HAS BROAD
SUPPORT FROM LABOR AND BUSINESS
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AIBO.
THEY MISS BURKE MISTER O'DONNELL.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED US THANK YOU
I MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SP.
TO THIRTY SEVEN WHICH ALLOWS FOR
A MODEST EXPANSION IN THE NUMBER
OF CUSTOMERS THAT CAN
PARTICIPATE IN THE DIRECT ACCESS
PROGRAM.
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
COLLEGES IN PARTICULAR WOULD
GREATLY BENEFIT FROM SUCH AN
EXPANSION.
BY REDUCING THE ARBITRARY LIMITS
ON COMPETITION THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE SCHOOLS WITH THE ABILITY
TO SHOP FOR COST EFFECTIVE
ELECTRICITY THAT MEETS THEIR
FINANCIAL NEEDS AYE URGING AYE
VOTE ON SP.
TWO THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU
MISTER O'DONNELL.
MISTER PATTERSON HERE RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS UP I
RISE ALSO UP IN SUPPORT.
A DIRECT ACCESS ALLOWS --
OUR BUSINESSES TO SHOP FOR
ENERGY IN A COMPETITIVE MARKET.
S. B. TWO THIRTY SEVEN INCREASES.
ARE THE EXISTING CAP ON DIRECT
ACCESS TO ALLOW MANUFACTURERS
AND FARMERS FOOD PROCESSOR
SCHOOLS EVEN.
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES. TO SAVE
SOMEWHERE IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF
TEN TO FIFTEEN DOLLARS PER
MEGAWATT HOUR AT THAT IS A
SIGNIFICANT.
SAVINGS AND DEPENDING ON THE
SIZE OF THE JYJ USER COULD
AMOUNT TO LITERALLY HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS.
OR EVEN MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
SAVINGS [inaudible]
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS
PARTICULARLY PAY INDUSTRIAL
ELECTRICITY RATES 86% ABOVE THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE AND THIS BILL
WOULD PROVIDE THEM WITH A
COMPETITIVE OPPORTUNITY TO
SIGNIFICANTLY A DECREASED A A
COSTS BANK THE SENATOR.
FOR AUTHORING THE BILL AN URGE
AYE AYE VOTE.
MISTER MURSHID SHE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO SP.
TWO THREE SEVEN WE HEARD THE
SPELL AND THE UTILITIES AND
ANSWER COMMITTEE AND BASICALLY
THE PROBLEM HERE IS THAT SOME OF
THE BIG PLAYERS.
ARE THAT THE BIG MANUFACTURERS
ARE GOOD BE ABLE PULL OFF THE
GRID LEAVING THE REST OF US
BEHIND.
WE HAVE A PROBLEM HERE WHERE WE
HAD A DISCUSSION IN THE
COMMITTEE WHERE A READY THE THEY
ELECTRICITY GRID AND ITS
RELIABILITY AND ITS IMPACT ON
THE RATE PAYERS WHO COULD BE
LEFT BEHIND.
AS THE BIG PLAYERS ARE DEVELOP
THEIR OWN DIRECT ACCESS YOU KNOW
OUR WHERE WE'RE GOING TO BE LEFT
BEHIND.
WE ALREADY HAVE AN UNSTABLE
ELECTRIC GRID TO DEAL WITH.
THIS IS ALSO AN AS ACCORDING TO
CLIMB IN ACTION CAMPAIGN THAT'S
A THREAT TO THE COMMUNITY CHOICE
AGGREGATION PROGRAMS FOR THAT
REASON I OPPOSE.
MR LEVINE.
AT THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS THIS BILL.
I URGE NOT A NO VOTE ON THIS
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN THE
AMOUNT OF ELECTRICITY DIRECT
ACCESS PROVIDERS COULD SELL. TO
LARGER ENEMY ENERGY CONSUMERS IN
CALIFORNIA BUT GIVEN THE RECENT
FINDINGS OF THE PEW SEE.
THAT WE DON'T HAVE A PLAN TO
ENSURE GREATER RELIABILITY.
AS WE MOVE FURTHER INTO
DECENTRALIZED ELECTRICITY MARKET
THIS BILL IS PREMATURE AT BEST
UNLIKE I OWE USE OR CCA'S YES
PIECE ELECTRICITY SERVICE
PROVIDERS.
LIKE ENRON HAVE NO OBLIGATION TO
SERVE ANY CUSTOMER AND CAN
RETURN THEIR CUSTOMERS TO
BUNDLED I OWE YOU SERVICE AT ANY%
TIME.
WHICH ESSENTIALLY MAKES EVERY
RATE PAYER FOR AN I OWE YOU THE
INSURANCE POLICY HOLDER FOR ALL
OF THOSE OTHER CUSTOMERS.
YES PIECE IN AGAIN ENRON IS AN
EXAMPLE OF WHAT AN E. S. P. IS
ALSO RELIES ON SHORT TERM
CONTRACTS TO GAIN A COMPETITIVE
ADVANTAGE.
OVER OTHER ELECTRICITY PROVIDERS
THAT HAVE ENTERED INTO LONG TERM
CONTRACTS THAT BUILD NEW POWER
SOURCES LIKE THE ONES THAT WE
HOPE WILL BE BUILT BECAUSE OF S.
B. ONE HUNDRED THAT WE VOTED ON
THIS WEEK TO GET US TO A GREENER.
CLEANER FUTURE THAT THEY ARE NOT
INVESTED IN THAT THAT YES PEAS
ARE NOT INVESTED IN US PEACE
THEREFORE DO NOT HELP US WITH
OUR CRITICAL ELECTRICITY
INFRASTRUCTURE THEREFORE.
I URGE A NO VOTE [inaudible]
STIR BERMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES ARE RISING RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO SB --
TO THIRTY SEVEN JOINING WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL ADVOCATES RATE
PAYER ADVOCATES GRASSROOTS
GROUPS AND OTHER PUBLIC --
POWER SERVICE PROVIDERS --
IN OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL --
UNFORTUNATELY --
INCREASING THIS CAP WILL SHIFT
COSTS A LOT OF RESIDENTIAL
CUSTOMERS AT ALL SHIFT COSTS ON
TO LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES THAT
CAN LEAST AFFORD --
TED TO HANDLE THAT BURDEN I AND
IT AND IT ALSO DOES NOT --
IT WILL BACKSLIDE ON
CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENTAL
POLICY GOALS --
YES PLEASE AS OTHERS HAVE SHORT
TERM PROCUREMENT CONTRACTS --
AND FOR EXCESS CAPACITY IN
ENERGY FROM PROJECTS BILL UNDER
LONG TERM CONTRACTS.
AND THAT PROCUREMENT STRATEGY
ó IS BASED ON THE FACT THAT
YES P. SERVE THEIR CUSTOMERS
UNDER SHORT TERM CONTRACTS
LOOKING FOR THE CHEAPEST --
ELECTRICITY POSSIBLE I'M NOT
NECESSARILY THE MOST
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY OF THIS
IS BAD FOR OUR COMMUNITIES IS
BAD FOR RATEPAYERS I
RESPECTFULLY URGE A NO VOTE.
DOCTOR QUIRK YOUR RECOMMENDS.
ON I ALSO URGE YOU KNOW VOTE FOR
THE REASONS ARE GIVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEMBERS ALL DEBATE AND
DISCUSSION HAVING SEIZE.
MS BURKE YOU MAY CLOSE I'M HAPPY
TO RESPOND TO SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES COMMENTS I'M ABOUT
THE CLEANLINESS OF THE POWER
DIRECT ACCESS PROVIDERS DO HAVE
TO MEET THE SAME RPF
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS AS
UTILITIES.
AND LABOR IS ALSO A SPONSOR SO
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS IN STATE
POWER.
AS WELL I HAVE CCA'S IN MY
DISTRICT I AM SUPER SUPPORTER OF
AND THIS IS NOT A HUGE DRAIN AS
WHAT'S SPOKEN THIS IS FIFTEEN
HUNDRED MEGAWATT STATE WIDE
WHICH IS NOT ENOUGH LOW TO HURT
SEC A CCA'S ARE CONSTANTLY
TALKING ABOUT THAT THEY HAD THE
CHOICE AND COMPETITION.
IS GOOD THIS JUST PROVIDES A
LITTLE MORE OF THAT AND REDUCES
RATES WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
AND WITHOUT THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY
ONE KNOWS.
FIFTEEN THE MEASURE PASSES
[inaudible]
BACK IN [inaudible]
FILE ORDER.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
TO TWENTY S. B. [inaudible]
NINE EIGHTEEN KERKORIAN.
SENATE BILL NINE EIGHTEEN BY
CENTER WE HEAR ANOTHER
CYANOACRYLATE HOMELESS YOU.
MS RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY OF THE
PRINCIPLE CO AUTHOR OF S. B..
NINE EIGHTEEN THIS BILL COMES
OUT OF THE JOINT HEARING SENATOR
WIENER AND I HAD LAST FALL ON
THE ISSUE OF YOUTH HOMELESSNESS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
S. B. NINE EIGHTEEN REQUIRES THE
HOMELESS CORD MAYES COORDINATING
AND FINANCE FINANCING COUNCIL TO
SET SPECIFIC MEASURABLE GOALS TO
PREVENT AND THEN YOU'D
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND TO MONITOR OUR PROGRESS
TOWARDS THOSE GOALS.
THE REASON AMENDMENTS RECOGNIZE
THE EFFORTS MADE THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS INCLUDING FUNDING
FOR HOMELESS YOUTH.
AND INCORPORATE FEEDBACK FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION.
S. B. NINE EIGHTEEN WILL PUT
CALIFORNIA AND A PATH TO ADDRESS
THE SHAMEFUL PROBLEM WHERE ON
ANY GIVEN NIGHT OUR STATE IN OUR
STATE MORE THAN FIFTEEN THOUSAND
YOUTH ARE LIVING ON OUR STREETS.
HOMELESS YOUTH HAVE NEEDS AND
RISKS THAT ARE STARKLY DIFFERENT
THAN THE GENERAL HOMELESS
POPULATION.
AND THEY ARE INCREASED RISK UPS
THERE ARE.
AND AN INCREASED RISK OF SEXUAL
VICTIMIZATION.
EVEN THOUGH WE KNOW THAT YOU
PROVIDE SERVICES THAT ARE NOT
TAILORED FOR HOMELESS YOUTH.
ONLY ONE THIRD OF THE COUNTIES
IN CALIFORNIA OFFER YOUTH
SPECIFIC SERVICES.
THAT'S WHY S. B. NINE EIGHTEEN
DIRECTS THE HOMELESS
COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL TO TAKE STEPS TO
DECREASE THE NUMBER OF YOUTH WHO
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS AND
ENSURE.
THAT THEIR AGENCY IS COLLECTING
THE NECESSARY NECESSARY DATA
FROM COUNTIES TO MEASURE THE
IMPACT. TWO THAT EXPECT TO THE
EXTENT THAT FUNDING IS AVAILABLE
THE HOMELESS COORDINATING A
FINANCING COUNCIL WILL ALSO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
AREAS OF THE STATE THAT HAVE NO
YOUTH SPECIFIC SERVICES.
S. B. NINE EIGHTEEN RECOGNIZES
THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF YOUNG PEOPLE
LIVING ON THE STREETS AND
ENSURES THAT OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
FOCUSING ON THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF
HOMELESS YOUTH.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS RUBIO.
MISTER THURMOND YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES --
ARISES SUPPORTIVE S. B. NINE ONE
EIGHT AS A PROUD CO AUTHOR I
LIKE TO THINK OF THE SENATOR
FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
AND ALL THE AUTHORS FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS MEASURE --
THIS STATE HAS HAD A GOOD
HISTORY OF CREATING PROGRAMS TO
SUPPORT HOMELESS YOUTH.
ESPECIALLY YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE
TRANSITIONING OUT OF FOSTER CARE
IN GREAT PROGRAMS LIKE THE T. HP
PLUS PROGRAM.
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PLUS BUT
YET ARE YOU STILL STRUGGLE.
AND HOMELESS YOUTH AND UP BEING
VICTIMS OF CRIME BEING HOMELESS
BEING UNDEREMPLOYED BEING
MISTREATED.
AND AN UNFORESEEN WE ENDED UP IN
ARKHAM ADDRESS THE SYSTEM AND SO
WE MUST DO MORE WE MUST BUILD
THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT ALLOWS
US TO ADDRESS YOUTH HOMELESSNESS
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE.
SOME COUNTIES MAKE GREAT USE OF
THEIR DOLLARS AND OTHERS HOLD ON
TO THAT --
WHAT IS TRUE IN MOST CASES MOST
COUNTIES DON'T EVEN HAVE
ADEQUATE OUR HOUSING AND
TEMPORARY SHELTER FOR YOU?
ARE HOMELESS YOUTH DESERVE
BETTER THAN SHELTER THEY DESERVE
BETTER THAT WAS BEING PROVIDED
FOR THEM ON BEHALF OF OUR YOUTH
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
ON S. B..
NINE ONE EIGHT THEY MISS THEIR
INDUCTED CHOI.
THEIR RECOGNIZE THANK YOU
SPEAKER AND THE MEMBERS I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
ENACTING VIA HOME SO YOUTH ACT
OF THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN IS
A GOOD IDEA.
I BELIEVE THAT --
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT AND A TIME
THE A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION IN ADDRESSING THE
CRISIS OFF WELL WOMAN ASKED YOU
WITH OUR IN OUR CALIFORNIA.
A I SAID THIS IS A GOOD IDEA
BECAUSE THE YEAH AIMING.
AT THE PREVENTING AND ENDING THE
HOMELESSNESS AMONG MARK
CALIFORNIA ARE YOU WITH.
I ISN'T SOMETHING THAT THE WE
SHOWED DOT IN FOR A AND THEN I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE ORANGE
COUNTY AND THE MY DISTRICT I
HAVE BEEN ON DEALING WITH.
A GROWING ISSUE SO HOMELESSNESS
AS I KNOW NOT THE MOST OF OUR
ROADS OUR COMMUNITY IS TO HAVE
ALL EXPERIENCED.
AN INCREASE IN THIS AREA.
ACCORDING TO THE CORPORATION FOR
SUPPORTIVE ALL [inaudible]
HOUSING CALIFORNIA NOW PASSED
THE LARGEST A POPULATION OF OUR
ONE ACCOMPANIED THE YOUTH
[inaudible]
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS ARE
ARE IN THE NATION [inaudible]
A DISTINCTION. FOR WHICH ARE.
WE CANNOT BE PROBLEM.
I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT THE STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS
ALONE. TEN SOFT A PROBLEM MOBILE
HOME LAST.
HOMELESSNESS TO YOU ARE FOR NOW
AMONG YOUTH PEOPLE.
WE NEEDED A PARTNERSHIP ARE MORE
UP WITH THE COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS ARE AND THE
COMMUNITIES SOME OF FAITH.
AND THE FAMILIES.
S. BE.
NINE A TEAM.
HOME LAST YEAR WITH ACT ALL OF
OUR TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN IT'S
NOT OUR SINGULAR SOLUTION BUT IT
IS SAW A ONE IMPORTANT STEP BY.
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK MY COLLEAGUES
TO JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING AS
BEING.
NINE EIGHTEEN TAKE TAX CHOI HAS
MATHIS.
THIS SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I I WANTED THE THIS OPPORTUNITY
IN FIRST GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO A
DIFFERENT MIND KATHY ADJUSTING
LUPER.
WHO FOUNDED A GROUP CALLED THE
GENESIS HOUSE --
MICHIGAN WE ORDER ON THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO MR MATHIS.
THANK YOU THE AS I WAS SAYING
THAT THEY FOUNDED IN
[inaudible]
GENESIS HOUSE.
AND WOOD GENESIS HOUSE IS IS
IT'S A HOME. FOR OUR TEENAGERS
WHO ARE HOMELESS.
WE'VE HAD TO LEAVE THEIR HOMES
FOR WHATEVER REASON.
GIVE THEM A PLACE TO STAY TO
GIVE THEM DIRECTION TO HELP GIVE
THEM GUIDANCE AND WE NEED MORE
OF THIS.
IN THE STATE.
S. B. NINE EIGHTEEN IS A GREAT
STEP. TO HELP EFFORTS LIKE
GENESIS HOUSE OUT. TO HELP OUR
TEENAGE YOU.
WHO THROUGH THE SYSTEM THROUGH
SOCIETY THROUGH EVERYTHING ELSE?
HAVE YOU GOT A BAD DEAL.
AND IT'S GREAT TO SEE THESE
GREAT NONPROFITS COME OUT AND
IT'S GREAT TO SEE THIS STATE.
FINALLY STEP UP AND RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE'S A NEED I ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
ALL DISCUSSION HAVING CEASED.
HIS RUBIO YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
WHO DESIRED VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLL ANTI THAT I SEVENTY
ONE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM [inaudible]
TO TWENTY ONE MISTER CALDERON.
WELL I'M TO TWENTY ONE SB ELEVEN
NINETY ONE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN NINETY ONE BY
CENTER HUESO ANOTHER CYNICAL
INTO OLDER INDEPENDENT ADULT
ABUSE [inaudible]
KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AND PLEASE PRESENT SB ELEVEN
NINETY ONE IMPORTANT BILL THAT
HELPS IMPROVE THE AWARENESS AND
ENFORCEMENT OF ELDER ABUSE LAWS.
THIS BILL WILL PLACE A MODEST
YET IMPORTANT REQUIREMENT ON
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAMS. TO
REVISE OUR POLICY MENUS TO
INCLUDE REFERENCES TO EXISTING
ELDER AND DEPENDENT ADULT ABUSE
LAWS.
IN SO DOING WILL HELP TO ENSURE
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENTS
ACROSS THE STATE ARE AWARE OF
THE CRITICAL LAWS AND
PROHIBITIONS. TO BETTER PROTECT
ONE OF OUR STATE'S MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AS
HAD NARY A NO VOTE THROUGHOUT
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA.
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CARP WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS SO.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON AMBER'S
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
WORK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE BUT EYES
SIXTY SIX KNOWS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES THIS IS
FILE ITEM.
TO TWENTY TWO S. B. THIRTEEN OH
FIVE CORKERY.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN OH FIVE BY
SENATOR GLAZER ANOTHER SNACK
WILLING TO EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICE PROVIDERS MS BAKER YOU
MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT SB
THIRTEEN A FIVE BY MY CO AUTHOR
SENATOR GLAZER REGARDING
IMMUNITY FOR FIRST RESPONDERS.
OF VOLUNTARILY TREAT ANIMALS AN
EMERGENCY SITUATION ABOUT FORTY
THOUSAND PETS DIE IN HOUSE FIRES
EVERY YEAR IN THE UNITED STATES.
AND ONE A DOG OR CAT IS INVOLVED
IN THE FIRE ONE OF THE BEST
THINGS WE CAN DO TO HELP WITH
THIS OXYGEN BUT RIGHT NOW FIRST
RESPONDERS ARE ACTUALLY
PROHIBITED FROM PROVIDING ANY
FIRST AID TO DOGS AND CATS.
AND THIS BILL WAS BROUGHT TO
CENTER GLAZER --
WHEN A VETERINARIAN IN THE
DISTRICT SAID IF HE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP THESE PETS
AND MAKE SURE THAT FIRST
RESPONDERS COULD AT LEAST DO
FIRST AID OXYGEN MOST IMMEDIATE
STABILIZING FIRST AID?
A LOT OF FAMILY PETS WOULD BE
SAVED OF THIS IS A NO NO VOTES
GREAT BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS BAKER.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF US.
CLERK WILL CLOSER ALL.
AND SALAS VOTE I SIXTY SIX KNOWS
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
TO TWENTY THREE S. B.
[inaudible]
EIGHT TWO TWO CORPORATION.
SENATE BILL A TWENTY TWO BY
SENATOR WIENER ANOTHER PERSON
ACCOLADE TO COMMUNICATIONS
[inaudible]
MR SANTIAGO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THE MOMENT YOU'VE ALL BEEN
WAITING.
FOR BEFORE US IS A VERY SIMPLE
QUESTION [inaudible]
SHOULD CALIFORNIA.
HAVE THE NET NEUTRALITY RULES.
THE VERY SIMPLE QUESTION.
IN FACT BEFORE YOU ARE PRESENT.
S. B..
EIGHT TO TWO THE STRONGEST NET
NEUTRALITY LEGISLATION IN THE
COUNTRY.
AND WHAT IT TRIES TO DO.
IS ENSURE THAT IS ESTABLISHES
COR PROTECTION.
OUR THE TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN
NET NEUTRALITY RULES UNDER
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
IT'S PRETTY SIMPLE [inaudible]
NO BLOCKING [inaudible]
NO THROTTLING.
NO PAPER IS ASIAN.
AND NO ACCESS SPEED.
A FREE AND OPEN INTERNET.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO.
WE ALL KNOW WHY WE'RE HERE
[inaudible]
PRETTY CLEAR [inaudible]
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
DROID THE INTERNET AS WE KNOW IT.
PLAIN AND SIMPLE.
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. TO LEAD THE NATION.
BY VOTING YES FOR THIS BILL.
THIS IS IMPERATIVE.
IN THE FIGHT. FOR A FREE AND
OPEN INTERNET.
THAT DOES NOT DISCRIMINATE
[inaudible]
CONTENT [inaudible]
USERS.
BASED ON HOW MUCH MONEY THEY
HAVE OR WHO CAN PAY [inaudible]
FOR IN FACT.
IT ALLOWS US. TO MAKE THE
DECISION.
BECAUSE WE CHOOSE.
THE INFORMATION THAT WE GET FREE
OF ANY SORT OF DISCRIMINATION.
THIS IS ESSENTIAL TO OUR
DEMOCRACY.
LET'S BE CLEAR [inaudible]
TODAY'S BILL.
IS THE STRONGEST.
NET NEUTRALITY BILL IN THE
NATION.
IN IT WILL RESTORE.
THE CORE PROTECTIONS
[inaudible]
LOST [inaudible]
TRUMP'S FEC.
REMOVED THE NET NEUTRALITY RULES
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
[inaudible] TO REINSTATE.
STRONG THAT MAY TELL YOU RULES.
THE SAME RULES.
THAT PRESIDENT OBAMA'S. TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN RULES AND
ORDERS PUT IN PLACE.
DAYS BILL IS ALSO ENDORSED.
BY FORMER FCC CHAIRMAN
[inaudible]
TOM WHEELER WHO LED THE SEC IN
TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN ONE
THESE RULES WERE ESTABLISHED
[inaudible]
I URGE STRONG AYE VOTE.
SO WE NOT ONLY SEND THE MESSAGE
TO THE REST THE NATION.
BUT WE ALSO STAND STRONG HERE
AND MAKE A STATEMENT.
THAT A FREE AND OPEN INTERNET.
IS ESSENTIAL TO OUR DEMOCRACY
AND WE HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY TO
DO THAT NOW.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
LET'S GO MISTER [inaudible]
HARPER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
THROUGHOUT THIS DISCUSSION I
THINK THAT THE AUTHOR HAS
ACTUALLY FRAME THE QUESTION WELL.
NETS SHOULD CALIFORNIA HAVE ITS
OWN INTERNET RULES SHOULD
CALIFORNIA HAVE ITS LAWS THAT
GOVERN THE INTERNET.
OR SHOULD IT BE.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
OR SHOULD BE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
IF INDEED YOU'RE UPSET WITH HOW
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
HANDLED THIS THIS ISSUE IS THIS
SIMPLY VENUE SHOPPING.
TRY TO GET TO WHERE YOU THINK
YOU HAVE THE VOTES. TO BE ABLE
TO DECIDE HOW TO GOVERN THE
INTERNET.
AND IF NOT HERE.
WHY SHOULDN'T IT BE HANDLED AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL PERHAPS WHY
SHOULD THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
[inaudible]
HABITS.
SHOULD THEY SHOULD OR SHOULD
THEY NOT HAVE THEIR OWN RULES
WHY SHOULD OR SHOULD NOT THE
CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO THE CITY
OF OAKLAND.
WITH THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO OR
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO OR ANY
OTHER MAJOR CITY.
OR MINOR CITY.
WITHIN THE STATE.
SHOULD THERE IN FACT BE A
PATCHWORK OF MAYBE THREE HUNDRED
OR SO MAYBE FIVE THOUSAND OR SO.
DIFFERENT WAYS TO BE ABLE TO
GOVERN THE INTERNET THROUGHOUT
THE UNITED STATES BECAUSE WE
HAVEN'T MADE THE ARGUMENT
PROPERLY.
THAT SHOULD BE A FEDERAL LOCAL
OR NATIONAL ISSUE.
SO THAT I THINK REALLY IS THE
FIRST QUESTION THAT WE REALLY
NEED TO SOLVE IN THE DISCUSSION
THAT WE HAVE HERE NOT BE
LISTENING TO WHAT FOLKS HAVE TO
BE ABLE TO SAY AND I'VE BEEN
LISTENING TO WHAT.
OUR CONSTITUENTS AND OTHERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN HAVE BEEN
HAVING TO SAY BUT I'M NOT YET
PERSUADED.
AT THIS TIME BUT I'M WILLING TO
LISTEN. TWO WHY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE THE
ULTIMATE GOVERNING BODY ON THIS
ISSUE.
RATHER THAN LOCAL GOVERNMENTS OF
THE NATIONAL GOVERNMENTS.
AND THAT OF COURSE THE SECONDARY
QUESTION IS.
IS THIS BILL S. B..
EIGHT TWENTY TWO INDEED THE BEST
SOLUTION [inaudible]
IF.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS THE
WAY TO BE ABLE TO GOVERN THIS
ISSUE.
SO WITH THAT I'LL BE LOOKING
FORWARD TO HEARING.
OF WHAT THE AUTHOR AS WELL AS
OTHER MEMBERS HAVE TO SAY ABOUT
THIS ISSUE.
BUT LET'S BE LET'S BE VERY
MEASURED IN OUR IN OUR
DISCUSSION.
IS THIS SIMPLY VENUE SHOPPING
BECAUSE THIS IS WHERE YOU GOT
THE VOTES.
OR IS THIS REALLY THE RIGHT
THING TO DO.
THANK YOU MISTER HARPER
[inaudible]
MISTER OBERNOLTE.
THE TOPIC OF NET NEUTRALITY IS
VERY COMPLEX AND VERY TECHNICAL
BUT IT'S ALSO VERY EMOTIONAL AND
WILL USE EMOTIONAL WORDS WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT IT.
AND I'VE HAD MANY CONSTITUENTS
COME TO BE AND SAY HOW CAN YOU
NOT SUPPORT NET NEUTRALITY.
HOW CAN YOU NOT SUPPORT A FREE
AND OPEN INTERNET?
AND RATHER THAN GET INTO THE
TECHNICAL DETAILS WITH THEM I
EXPLAIN MY OPPOSITION USING A
METAPHOR IN WITH YOUR INDULGENCE
I'D LIKE TO SHARE IT HERE.
I TOLD THEM I IMAGINE.
BUT THERE'S A VILLAGE BESIDE A
RIVER.
AND ONE DAY A COMPANY COMES
ALONG AND BUILDS A BRIDGE OVER
THE RIVER AND CHARGES CARS A
TOLD ACROSS THE BRIDGE.
IN THIS PRE CHEN SNOW BEING OF
GREAT BENEFIT TO THE VILLAGERS
IN THE VILLAGE THRIVES UNTIL
MUCH OF THE COMMERCE OF THE
VILLAGE INVOLVES CARS CROSSING
THE BRIDGE.
AND THAT LEADS TO CONGESTION ON
THE BRIDGE THE BRIDGE OPERATOR
ONE DAY SAYS WE'RE GOING TO
INSTITUTE A DIFFERENTIAL TOLL
WHERE WE CHARGE LARGE COMMERCIAL
VEHICLES HIGHER TOOL THAN
PASSENGER CARS.
AND A GROUP OF ANGRY VILLAGERS
GETS TOGETHER AND SAYS YOU CAN'T
DO THAT WE DEMAND BRIDGE
NEUTRALITY ALL TRAFFIC ON THE
BRIDGE SHOULD BE TREATED THE
SAME.
AND THE BRIDGE COMPANY IS A
LITTLE BAFFLED BECAUSE THEY
POINT OUT THE BRIDGE IS BUILT TO
SUPPORT ONLY A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
WEIGHT AND IF YOU HAVE LARGER
COMMERCIAL VEHICLES CROSSING THE
BRIDGE THAT MEANS FEWER
PASSENGER CARS CAN BE ON THE
BRIDGE AT THE SAME TIME.
BUT THEY SAY OKAY HABA WE SOLVE
THE PROBLEM A DIFFERENT WAY
WE'RE GOING TO CONSTRUCT NEW
LANES ON THE BRIDGE.
THEN PEOPLE CAN PAY A HIGHER
TOLL TO USE THE NEW LANES OR
THEY COMPETE EXISTING TOLL TO
USE THE LANES THAT ARE ALREADY
THERE THAT WILL BENEFIT NOT JUST
THE PEOPLE WHO PAY THE HIGHER
TOLL.
BUT THE PEOPLE WHO PAY THE
EXISTING TOLL AS WELL SINCE
THEIR LANDS WILL BE LESS CROWDED.
BUT THE ANGRY VILLAGERS SAY NO
YOU CAN'T DO THAT THAT'S PAID
PRIORITIZATION THAT SHOULD BE
ILLEGAL.
SO BRIDGE COMPANY SAYS OR CAMP
OUT THIS WILL COME UP WITH A
PASS.
AND IF YOU HAVE A PASS THEN YOU
DON'T HAVE TO PAY A TOLL AT ALL.
AN ANGRY VILLAGERS SAY ONCE
AGAIN THAT IS ZERO RATING YOU
CAN'T DO THAT WE'RE GONNA MAKE
THAT ILLEGAL.
TO IF YOU ASK THE ANGRY
VILLAGERS WHY ARE YOU SO ANGRY
HERE'S WHAT THEY'LL SAY.
THEY'LL SAY YOU DON'T REALIZE
HOW MUCH CONTROL THE BRIDGE
COMPANY HAS OVER THE VILLAGE WHY
IF THE BRIDGE COMPANY WANTED.
TO THEY COULD PREVENT CARS FROM
CROSSING THE BRIDGE AT ALL THEY
COULD PREVENT TRUCKS FROM A
CERTAIN COMPANY FROM CROSSING
THE BRIDGE.
BUT HERE'S THE CRUX OF THE STORY
ALL THAT YOU NEED. TO DO TO
PREVENT THAT FROM OCCURRING TO
BREAK THE POWER OF THE BRIDGE
COMPANY OVER THE VILLAGE IS MORE
BRIDGES.
ALL YOU NEED IS LOTS A BRIDGES
CROSSING THE RIVER AT DIFFERENT
POINTS AND THEN THE VILLAGERS
CAN DECIDE WHICH BRIDGE THEY
WANT TO USE AND NO BRIDGE
COMPANY CAN TAKE UNFAIR
ADVANTAGE AND YOU GET SOMETHING
THAT YOU CAN'T GET ANY OTHER WAY
WHICH IS FAIR PRICING.
ON THE TOLLS [inaudible]
UNFORTUNATELY THIS BILL ENACTS
THE HARSHEST REGULATION ON
INTERNET OF ANY STATE IN THE
COUNTRY.
AND WHEN YOU DO THAT WE'VE SEEN
AGAIN AND AGAIN AND AGAIN THAT
YOU DON'T GET MORE BRIDGES YOU
GET FEWER BRIDGES.
I WANNA TAKE JUST A MOMENT AND
TALK ABOUT BUT ESPECIALLY
PERNICIOUS COMPONENT OF THIS
BILL AND THAT IS THE BAN ON ZERO
RATING.
AND THAT BAND GOES WELL BEYOND
WHAT WAS IN THE TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN FCC REGULATIONS ON NET
NEUTRALITY. ZERO RATING IF
YOU'RE NOT FAMILIAR WITH THE
LINGO.
IS THE PRACTICE WHERE A COMPANY
PAYS INTERNET PROVIDER DO NOT
HAVE DATA INVOLVED WITH A
COMPANY COUNT TOWARDS CUSTOMERS
DATA PLAN SO FOR EXAMPLE.
IF YOU USE OUR NETFLIX TO WATCH.
NETFLIX ON YOUR A MOVIE ON YOUR
CELL PHONE.
AND YOU PROBABLY WILL NOT PAY I
HAVE THAT DATA COUNT TOWARDS
YOUR DATA CARE.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH THAT.
IF WE DO AWAY WITH OUT FOR MOST
OF US THE VALUE OF THAT DATA IS
ONLY A FEW DOLLARS A MONTH BUT
THAT IS NOT TRUE.
OF THE MOST DISADVANTAGED
MEMBERS OF OUR SOCIETY THE DATA
SHOWS THAT MANY OF THAT
POPULATION CAN'T AFFORD MULTIPLE
ACCESS POINTS OF THE INTERNET SO
THEY USE ONLY THEIR MOBILE PHONE
TO ACCESS THE INTERNET.
AND THAT IT ALSO SHOWS THAT THE
IMPACT TO THAT SEGMENT OF THE
POPULATION IS MUCH MORE
DEVASTATING HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS
A YEAR.
AND BECAUSE MOST OF THOSE PEOPLE
CAN'T AFFORD IT THEY'RE GONNA
HAVE TO PICK BETWEEN PAYING
HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS IN HERE OR
NOT WATCHING NETFLIX AT ALL OR
NOT USING THOSE OTHER SERVICES.
WHY WOULD YOU TAKE THAT AWAY
FROM THEM?
WHY ON EARTH WOULD YOU TAKE THAT
AWAY FROM THEM?
THIS BILL IS BAD FOR THE POOR.
IT'S BAD FOR THE MIDDLE CLASS IN
CALIFORNIA'S BET FOR CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS.
IT'S BAD FOR CALIFORNIA I URGE A
NO VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE
MISTER FLORA YOUR RECCA.
THEY GIVE US SPEAKER QUEST OF
THE AUTHOR [inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THAT THE AUTHOR'S INTENT THAT
THE OTHER CONNECTION AGREEMENT
PROVISIONS UP OF THIS BILL APPLY
ONLY TO EXISTING AGREEMENTS.
OR TO ONLY TWO AGREEMENTS.
FUTURE INTERCONNECTION
AGREEMENTS.
ALEX OF JURY ANSWERS I INTO
CLOSE TO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS CLARK DR QUIRK.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER.
THIS BILL DOES REFLECT.
THE OBAMA ORDER.
NO WITH THE OBAMA ORDER SAN
ABOUT INTERCONNECTION FEES IS
THERE WASN'T GOING TO BE ONE
REGULATION.
ON THE INTERCONNECTION FEES
INSTEAD IT WOULD LOOK AT THE
ISSUE ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT IS BEING
DONE HERE.
SO ONE CAN IMAGINE [inaudible]
FOR EXAMPLE.
YOU HAVE THE INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDER THAT'S DOING THE LAST
MILE.
YOU HAVE A MIDDLE MODEL PROVIDER
THAT GOES FROM [inaudible]
ST TAKE SOMETHING FROM THE FIRST
MILE IN NEW YORK TO THE LAST
MILE IN CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
SHOULD [inaudible]
THE INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDER.
CHARGE THAT MIDDLE MINOR MIDDLE
MILE PROVIDER. TO ME AT LEAST.
THAT WOULD SEEM.
TO BE A VERY DANGEROUS THING
BECAUSE IT COULD SLOW DOWN THE
INTERNET.
ON THE OTHER HAND [inaudible]
IF NETFLIX.
WHERE TO DO SOME SORT OF
DRAMATIC NETWORK OF ITS OWN AND
THAT NEED A SPECIAL PIPE
[inaudible]
CONNECT TO THE INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDER AND THEN INTERNET
SERVICE PROVIDER HAD TO BUILD A
SPECIAL PIE.
THEN IN THAT CASE I BELIEVE YOU
COULD CHARGE.
THAT ALL WOULD BE DETERMINED BY
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO'S IN
CHARGE OF ENFORCEMENT SAID THIS
BILL DOES HAVE FLEXIBILITY.
DOES ALLOW FOR SOME CHARGES WHEN
THEY ARE JUSTIFIED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK MISTER
PATTERSON.
A THANK YOU MEMBERS OF LET ME
LET ME START FIRST OF ALL.
OF ON WHAT REALLY IS I THINK
IT'S GOING TO BE AT THE HEART OF
THIS.
WHICH IS OUR THIS [inaudible]
IT'S CLEARLY.
A FEDERAL ISSUE.
A JURISDICTION WHERE PREEMPTION
IS GOING TO BE.
A BIT THE DISCUSSION AND IT'S
GOING TO END UP BEING.
NOT LITIGATED IF THERE WAS EVER
ANYTHING AS UBIQUITOUS AND
INTERSTATE COMMERCE.
AS THE INTERNET I CAN'T THINK OF
ANYTHING.
A GROUP MORE DIRECTED WITH
RESPECT TO THAT EXAMPLE.
THIS WILL IN FACT BE LITIGATED
AND IT WILL BE LITIGATED UP.
PRESUMABLY TO THE SUPREME COURT.
AND Y. BECAUSE IT TRAMPLES
FUNDAMENTALLY.
ON THE KINDS OF SEPARATED POWERS
AND ENUMERATED POWERS AND POWERS
THAT HAVE BEEN THROUGH A COURTS
AND AND AND JURISDICTIONS AND
AND RULE MAKING.
THE FACT IS THAT THE WORST
POSSIBLE THING.
THAT WE COULD DO [inaudible]
IT'S BUT I HAVE CREATED
[inaudible] FIFTY DIFFERENT
STATE [inaudible]
FCC'S.
SO FIRST OF ALL.
WHAT IS AN EFFORT HERE I THINK A?
SO WHAT POLITICAL.
AND I THINK DUBBED QUITE SHORT
SIGHTED.
WILL TRIP LITIGATION THAT I
THINK THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WILL BE.
UNSUCCESSFUL [inaudible]
IN DEFENDING.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN IT MEANS
UNCERTAINTY?
IN CALIFORNIA FOR AS LONG AS THE
LITIGATION.
PROCEEDS IT COULD VERY THEM
HIGHLY PROBABLY.
LEAD TO THE UP SUPREME COURT
ESSENTIALLY SAYING THAT IT
CALIFORNIA THIS IS AN AREA THAT
IS RESERVED. FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
SO I THINK THE BIGGER POINT HERE
IS IF YOU ARE REALLY INTERESTED.
I IN THAT NEUTRALITY UP THE
PLACE TO HAVE THIS --
FLASHED OUT IS AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL WITH FEDERAL ELECTIONS IN
FEDERAL ACCOUNTABILITY.
WE ARE GOING TO I THINK IN MANY
RESPECTS CHILL.
ARE THE INTERNET IN CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE ABOUT LITIGATION AND THE
UNCERTAINTY THAT IT CREATES.
AND I KNOW THERE MAY BE SOME
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO SUGGEST
THAT -- WELL
HOW CAN YOU.
PRESUME WHAT A COURTS GOING TO
DO IN THE UNCERTAIN IT'S AFTER.
I'M ALL I CAN TELL YOU IS NOT
HAD THIRTY YEARS OF BROADCAST
EXPERIENCE OWNING AND OPERATING.
BROADCAST PROPERTIES AND BEING
REGULATED UNDER THE FEDERAL
COMMUNICATIONS COMMISSION. TEN
YOU IMAGINE WHAT LIFE WOULD HAVE
BEEN LIKE.
IF I WHAT WERE REGULATED BY
EVERY --
THAT LOOKED OUT.
WANNABE FCC THAT MIGHT HAPPEN TO
BE IN THE JURISDICTION WHERE I
COVER.
REPEATEDLY AN AND OVER AGAIN.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS WHEN
THIS HAS BEEN TESTED.
WHEN STE THE STATE'S OUR
COMMUNITIES HAVE TRIED TO SAY TO
A FEDERALLY REGULATED DUBBED?
A A CARRIERS IN MY INSTANCE IN
OVER THE AIR BROADCASTING IT TO
HAVE BEEN HAS BEEN.
UP SHUT DOWN.
AND IT'S BEEN THE INTERSTATE
COMMERCE CLAUSE AND ITS
APPLICATION BATS.
THAT'S COMING OUR WAY.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT ALSO
UNDER DISPUTE THE FACT THAT THIS
IS JUST THAT THE OBAMA AIRONET
NEUTRALITY.
AND WE HAD A A VOTE ON THAT BILL
IN.
THE COMMITTEE THAT WAS PRECISELY
THAT.
AND FOR SOME REASON OF THAT
DIDN'T COUNT THAT DID MATTER NOW
WE'RE LOADING UP.
A VERY SIGNIFICANT.
A SET OF ADDITIONS.
OF REGULATIONS AND AND HOOPS AND
THANKS TO JUMP THROUGH.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO
JUST TO CLAIM THAT THIS IS.
OUR ONLY OBAMA ERA I THINK IS
EXHIBITED HUGE EXAGGERATION.
HAD IT BEN.
THE OBAMACARE REGULATIONS.
I WOULD HAVE BEEN GLADLY
STANDING HERE.
ASKING FOR YOU TO SUPPORT IT.
BUT I CANNOT BECAUSE IT TAKES
SEVERAL STEPS.
WAY TOO FAR.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE SOMETHING
THAT THERE WAS A PERIOD OF TIME.
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND AND NINE
AND TWO THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN
WHEN AND THE AND THE FACT IS
THAT THE CAPITAL INVESTMENT.
ARE -- EACH
YEAR.
ARE FROM ARE THE END OF THE
RECESSION UNTIL TWENTY FOURTEEN
WAS VERY ROBUST VERY STRONG.
AND THE FACT IS THAT WHEN TO
FIFTEEN ARRIVED AND THE LIGHT
TOUCH ON THE INTERNET WAS
REPLACED BY THE HEAVY TOUCH.
THURMOND AND YET INTERNET
CAPITAL INVESTMENT BROADBAND
PROVIDERS DECLINE FOR THE FIRST
TIME SINCE THE END.
OF THE RECESSION AND INVESTMENT
LOW STEAM DOWN MORE THAN THREE
OR 4% FROM TWENTY FOUR TO LOOK.
THE BAD THE BOTTOM LINE HERE IS.
THAT THE LIGHT TOUCH INTERNET
HAS EXPLODED AND THE FLOURISHED
AND HAS HUGE COMPETITION AND
GREAT BENEFIT FOR PEOPLE ACROSS
THE UNITED STATES AND IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE OVER REACH THE GOING TOO FAR
HERE IS GOING TO BE CHALLENGED
IN COURT CONSTITUTIONALLY THAT
WE'RE GOING TO FIND OURSELVES IN
VERY UNCERTAIN TERRITORY.
WITH AN UNCERTAINTY AND A
CHILLING.
OFF THE INTERNET.
WHAT HAS BEEN SO SUCCESSFUL SO
UBIQUITOUS AND SO IMPORTANT
CALIFORNIA?
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE A
FRAUGHT WITH LITIGATION
UNCERTAINTY AND THAT'S GOING TO
MEAN THAT OUR CONSTITUENTS ARE
GOING TO HAVE AN INTERNET THAT
IS GLASS.
I ROBUST LESS INVESTED IN THEM
THAN WE'VE HAD BEFORE THAT'S
WHAT HEAVY REGULATION DOES.
TIMELY MIGHT REGULATION IS THE
ANSWER BAD AND I'M GOING TO ASK
THAT THAT YOU VOTE NO
[inaudible]
YOUR KILEY.
THANK YOU SPEAKER.
CLEAR THAT THERE IS OVERWHELMING
SUPPORT IN THIS BODY AND
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR THE PRINCIPLES OF
NET NEUTRALITY.
THAT CONTENT ON THE INTERNET
SHOULD BE NEITHER WALKED NORTH
THROTTLED NOR TREATED IN A
DISCRIMINATORY MANNER.
BUT SUPPORTING THOSE PRINCIPLES
DOES NOT MEAN SUPPORTING THIS
PARTICULAR BILL.
I DO NOT BELIEVE.
THAT PASSING THIS BILL WILL
RESULT IN NET NEUTRALITY IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND THEIR TWO MAIN REASONS WHY.
THE FIRST REASON IS THAT WHEN
LOOKING AT THE BEST DEFINITION
OF NET NEUTRALITY THAT WE HAVE
THE F. C. C.'S TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN ORDER.
THIS BILL DIVERGES FROM IT DOES
NOT.
RE ENACT THAT ORDER THIS WAS
PROPOSED BY THE ASSEMBLY PRIVACY
COMMITTEE.
BUT THE BILL WENT IN ANOTHER
DIRECTION.
IMPOSING NEW UNPRECEDENTED
RESTRICTIONS ON THE INTERNET
THAT WERE NOT PART OF NET
NEUTRALITY AS THE OBAMA ERA FCC.
UNDERSTOOD IT.
BUT YOU KNOW IF YOU TAKE MY WORD
FOR THAT.
IN COMMITTEE WE HEARD FROM THE
ARCHITECT OF THIS BILL THE
PROFESSOR WHO ALSO HAD A HAND IN
THE FCC ORDER.
AND SHE EXPLAINED TO US OUR
VARIOUS POLICIES THAT ARE IN
THIS BILL THAT WERE PROPOSED TO
THE FCC BUT WERE NOT INCLUDED IN
THE FCC'S ORDER AS PART OF NET
NEUTRALITY.
AND THESE NEW UNPRECEDENTED
RESTRICTIONS ON THE INTERNET
PROVISIONS DEALING WITH NETWORK
MANAGEMENT ZERO RATING
INTERCONNECTION SPECIALIZED
SERVICES.
NOT ONLY ARE EXTRANEOUS TO NET
NEUTRALITY BUT ACTIVELY WORK
AGAINST ITS GOAL OF A FREE AND
OPEN INTERNET FOR ALL.
BY RAISING COSTS PARTICULARLY
BURDENING THE POOR BY REDUCING
ACT REDUCING ACCESS ESPECIALLY
FOR RURAL AREAS BY LIMITING
CHOICES BY THROTTLING THE
BREATHTAKING INNOVATION THAT HAS
BEEN A HALLMARK.
OF THE INFORMATION AGE.
BUT THE SECOND REASON THAT THIS
BILL WILL NOT RESULT IN NET
NEUTRALITY IN CALIFORNIA IS THAT
IT IS PREEMPTED BY FEDERAL LAW
NOW THIS TERM FEDERAL PREEMPTION
I KNOW IT SOUNDS LEGALISTIC.
BUT IT'S AT THE HEART OF
AMERICAN FRIENDLY FEDERALISM.
JUST AS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
CANNOT INFRINGE UPON OUR SPEAR
OF LAWMAKING AS A STATE SO TO WE
AS A STATE.
CANNOT LEGISLATE IN A WAY THAT
CONFLICTS FEDERAL LAW AND HERE
THE PREEMPTION CASE IS REALLY
CLEAR.
THE RELEVANT FEDERAL LAW THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN FCC ORDER
THAT'S THE ONE NET NEUTRALITY
SUPPORTERS DON'T LIKE.
HAS A PROVISION IN PARAGRAPH.
ONE NINETY FOUR THAT EXPRESSLY
PREAMPS STATE AND LOCAL LAW
MAKING ON THE MATTER.
BUT YOU MIGHT SAY WAIT A MINUTE
IS NOT TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
FCC ORDER ITSELF BEING
CHALLENGED IN COURT RIGHT NOW.
AND THAT'S TRUE IT IS.
BUT EVEN OF THAT ORDER.
WERE SOMEHOW INVALIDATED THERE
STILL A PROBLEM AND THAT'S OF
THE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN FCC
ORDER THE ONE THAT NET
NEUTRALITY SUPPORTERS LIKE.
ALSO PREEMPTED STATE AND LOCAL
LAW MAKING WITH PERMISSION TO
READ MISTER SPEAKER [inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
PARAGRAPH FOUR THIRTY THREE OF
THE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN ORDER
STATES THE COMMISSION IS USE
PREEMPTION TO PROTECT FEDERAL
INTEREST WHEN A STATE REGULATION
CONFLICTS WITH FEDERAL RULES OR
POLICIES.
AND WE INTEND TO EXERCISE THIS
AUTHORITY TO PREEMPT ANY STATE
REGULATIONS OF A CONFLICT WHICH
CONFLICT WITH THIS COMPREHENSIVE
REGULATORY SCHEME.
OR OTHER FEDERAL LAW SO THE
PREEMPTION CASE IS REALLY CLEAR
AND AGAIN YOU DON'T HAVE TO TAKE
MY WORD FOR THAT.
THE LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
ONE OF THE NATION'S LEADING
PROPONENTS OF NET NEUTRALITY AND
SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL.
HAS SAID THERE'S A 10% CHANCE
THAT THE STATE'S DIRECT
REGULATION OF ISPS ON NET
NEUTRALITY WILL SURVIVE A LEGAL
CHALLENGE [inaudible] 10%.
AND OF COURSE ON THE OTHER HAND
THERE'S A 1100% CHANCE.
PASSING THIS BILL WILL CREATE
PROTRACTED REGULAR OUT
LITIGATION AND REGULATORY
UNCERTAINTY THE PRICE OF WHICH
WILL BE BORNE BY CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS.
I WANTED TO PUT OUT CLOTHES JUST
WITH WORD ABOUT THE PUBLIC
INTEREST THIS BILL IS GENERATED
BECAUSE I'VE MET WITH A LOT OF
FOLKS WHO ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE
THE BILL AND IT'S BEEN GREAT TO
SEE IT'S CLEAR THAT PEOPLE FEEL.
A POWERFUL STAKE IN THIS ISSUE
AND THE FUTURE OF THE INTERNET
AND RIGHTLY SO.
FEW TECHNOLOGIES IN HUMAN
HISTORY HAVE PRODUCED SUCH A
PERVASIVE AND SWEEPING SOCIAL
CHANGE SO QUICKLY HAVE BECOME SO
DEEPLY INTEGRATED INTO ALL
DIMENSIONS OF OUR PERSONAL.
AND PROFESSIONAL LIVES THIRTY
SECOND AND THE INTERNET IS NOT
THE PROPERTY OF ANY ONE PERSON
OR COUNTRY OR COMPANY BUT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BUILT
TOGETHER AND BELONGS TO ALL OF
US.
WHICH IS WHY IT'S BEEN AYE SO
GREAT TO SEE THE LEVEL OF PUBLIC
INTEREST IN THIS DEBATE.
BUT IT'S ALSO WHY I BELIEVE
THERE IS A FUNDAMENTAL MISMATCH
BETWEEN THE PUBLIC INTEREST IN
THIS ISSUE AND THE POLICY IMPACT
OF THIS BILL.
IF YOU BELIEVE IN THAT ITS ROWDY
THIS IS NOT THE BILL FOR YOU IT
WILL INITIALLY DO MUCH MORE AND
WILL EVENTUALLY DO NOTHING AT
ANK YOU MISTER KILEY
MISTER KALRA YOUR READINESS.
THANK YOU MISS SPEAKER MEMBERS
OF I STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB EIGHT TWENTY TWO AND I THINK
THE AUTHOR WHO SAN FRANCISCO IN
OUR COLLEAGUE.
OF HER BRING THIS FORWARD --
THIS AFTERNOON.
AND THE TO OUR COLLEAGUES ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE --
THAT AT THE PARTY OF STATES
RIGHTS I GUESS YOU SHOULD GET TO
CHOOSE WHEN YOU WON THE WAY THAT
BETTER WHEN YOU DON'T.
BECAUSE THE REALITY IS THAT WHEN
IT COMES TO OUR CONSUMERS WHEN
IT COMES TO CALIFORNIA'S WE
SHOULD NEVER ABDICATE OUR
RESPONSIBILITY. TO FIGHT FOR
CALIFORNIA'S INTO BITE FOR
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS AND WE'VE
ALREADY SEEN WHAT THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION THAT THEY DO NOT
HAVE AN INTEREST AND IN
PROTECTING CONSUMERS.
WE HAVE SEEN IN THE LAST YEAR TO
HAVE A THE ROLLING BACK OF
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS.
OF IN WIDE RANGE OF INDUSTRIES
NOT JUST ON THIS ISSUE IN
BANKING.
AND HEALTH CARE.
IMMIGRATION RIGHTS YOU NAME IT
THEY'RE ROLLING BACK PUT.
AND IT'S UP TO US TO STAND UP
AGAINST THEM DOING THAT AND
WE'VE BEEN DOING SO IN OUR
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS BEEN DOING
SO AND RIGHTFULLY SO
[inaudible]
NOW.
IN MY COUNTY SANTA CLARA COUNTY
AYE DURING THE MENDOCINO COMPLEX
FIRE.
UP TO JUST LIKE MANY OTHER
COUNTIES AROUND THE STATE.
THEY SENT FIREFIGHTERS OUT THERE
TO HELP WITH MUTUAL AID.
WHEN THEY DID THAT?
A WIRELESS COMPANY LIMITED.
SOCCER COUNTIES FIRE DEPARTMENTS
DID ACCESS BY TONGLING THEIR
SERVICE IN THE MIDST OF A WILD
WILDFIRE.
THE COMPANY ADMITTED.
BUT THEY DID THAT.
AND ACCORDING TO THE COUNTY FIRE
CHIEF.
ANTHONY BODEN THE DATA SERVICE
PROVIDER FAILED TO LIVE UP TO
THEIR POLICY OF THE TEAM DID A
CAPS IN EMERGENCY SITUATIONS.
WHEN THE DEPARTMENT ASKED FOR
HELP WHETHER A BATTLING THE
MENDOCINO COMPLEX FIRE
[inaudible]
NOW.
DURING THE FIRE ONE VEHICLE IN
PARTICULAR WAS AFFECTED ONLY US
BY.
TWO SIX TWO PAST THE DEPARTMENT
EMPLOYER THOUGH THE VEHICLE
DEPLOYED BY THE DEPARTMENT TO
TRACK ORGANIZE AND PRIORITIZE
ROUTING OF RESOURCES FROM AROUND
THE STATE AND COUNTRY. TO THE
SITE.
THE SITES WHERE THEY ARE MOST
NEEDED DURING THE BLAZE.
THE DEPARTMENT'S PLAN CALLED FOR
THEIR DATA SPEEDS TO BE SLOWED
IF THEY USE MORE THAN TWENTY
FIVE GIGABYTES A MONTH.
IN THE MIDST OF THE RESPONSE THE
COUNTY FIRE DISCOVERED THE DATA
CONNECTION BUT THIS RIG WAS
BEING THROTTLED BY THE COMPANY
AND DATA RATES HAVE BEEN REDUCED
TO ONE TO HUNDREDS.
OR LESS THAN THE PREVIOUS SPEEDS.
NOW WHEN THE DEPARTMENT ASKED
THE COMPANY. TO LIFT THIS
RESTRICTION THEY REJECTED IT.
AND THEY SAID THEY'D HAVE TO BUY
A NEW DATA PLAN WHICH COST TWICE
AS MUCH IN THE MIDDLE.
OF THIS FIRE [inaudible]
SO.
WE TALK ABOUT NET NEUTRALITY A
WHAT IT REALLY MEANS IN TERMS OF
SAFETY OF OUR COMMUNITY IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT INTERNET ACCESS WHICH
BY ITSELF.
IS ABOUT ENOUGH ARGUMENT FOR NET
NEUTRALITY.
BUT THIS IS ABOUT OUR ABILITY TO
MAKE SURE THAT NOT ONLY IS OUR
LOVING THAT'LL THAT'LL PLAY BILL
FOR A CONSUMERS.
BUT THAT OUR PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND OTHERS THAT RELY.
ON THE INTERNET.
DON'T FIND THEMSELVES IN THE
SITUATION THAT ARE COUNTY
FIREFIGHTERS FOUND THEMSELVES IN.
DURING THE BIGGEST WILDFIRE IN
THE STATE'S HISTORY.
UP THE PERMISSION TO READ.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THANK YOU.
COUNSEL FOR THE COUNTY STATED
[inaudible]
THE THIS COMPANIES THROTTLING
HAS EVERYTHING TO DO WITH THAT
NEUTRALITY IS SHOWS THAT THE
ISPS WILL ACT IN THEIR ECONOMIC
INTERESTS EVEN AT THE EXPENSE.
A PUBLIC SAFETY.
SO I URGE NOT ONLY ONE THE COMES
TO SAVE YOU AND NOT JUST FOR
CONSUMER EQUITY.
BUT BEING FROM SILICON VALLEY.
IN TERMS OF ENSURING NOT ONLY
THAT WE DON'T JUST THROTTLE
CONSUMER ACCESS BUT WE DON'T
THROTTLE SILICON VALLEY
INNOVATION.
I URGE YOU ABOUT AYE ON THIS
BILL [inaudible]
SURE LEVINE [inaudible]
YOU'RE RECOMMENDS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I STAND IN
SUPPORT OF NET NEUTRALITY AND I
STAND IN SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
THIS BILL THIS ISSUE IS EXACTLY
WHERE.
PUBLIC POLICY AND PUBLIC
INTEREST COLLIDE AND CAN ALIGN
WITH ONE ANOTHER THIS IS AN ERA
WHERE WE MUST NOT.
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST CONTENT
THIS IS AN ERA WHERE WE ACTUALLY
NEED TO HAVE MORE CONTENT WHERE
IF WE WANT TO LEARN ABOUT THE
SOCIETY THAT WE LIVE IN WE MUST
READ.
AND HEAR FROM MULTIPLE SOURCES
TO DISCERN WHAT IS REALLY
HAPPENING AROUND US AND TO
SOCIETY.
AND WE SEE TRENDS THAT ARE
TROUBLING OF COURSE WE'VE SEEN
SINCE PRESIDENT TRUMP TOOK
OFFICE THIS CHANGE I WITH THE
REVERSAL OF NET NEUTRALITY.
WE ALSO HEARD JUST THIS PAST
WEEK ABOUT HOW UPSET HE WAS
BECAUSE WHEN HE DID A SEARCH
ABOUT HIMSELF.
HE DIDN'T LIKE THE CONTENT.
THAT CAME BACK IN HIS SEARCHES.
WE ALSO KNOW.
THAT FOX NEWS HAS THIS
ESSENTIALLY BECOME STATE RUN
MEDIA.
WERE ONLY CONTENT THE PRESIDENT
LIKES IS BEING DELIVERED. TO
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE AROUND THE
WORLD.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT FACEBOOK WHICH
HAS BEEN SO IRRESPONSIBLE.
DURING THIS MOMENT IN TIME.
IS NOW IN PARTNERSHIP WITH VOX
PRODUCING MORE CONTENT TO BE ON
ITS PLATFORM.
WE MUST MAKE SURE THAT ALL
CONTENT IS EQUAL ON THE INTERNET
SET THIS CONTENT IS NOT BE ALL
THAT ONLY MEETS THE PRESIDENT'S
[inaudible]
STANDARDS I IS NOT THE ONLY
CONTENT TO POINT THAT PEOPLE
RECEIVE.
I WOULD I WOULD ASK THE MEMBER
WOULD STICK TO THE FACTS HE'S
TRYING TO EDITORIALIZE TRYING TO
SAY THAT FOX NEWS IS AN OUTLET
OF ON THE STATE RUN MEDIA OR THE
GOVERNMENT.
THIS IS THE SAME THING AS SAYING
THAT MSNBC AND CNN IS THE IS THE
TOOL OF THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
OR THE CLINTON ADMINISTRATION
THIS IS YOU KNOW CAN YOU PLEASE
KEEP IT TO THE MERITS OF THE
BILL.
AND NOT EDITORIAL COMMENT.
MISTER ALAN POINT ORDERS NOW
WILL TAKE A MISTER LEVINE IS
SPEAKING TO CONTENT AND CONTENT
DISTRIBUTION I BELIEVE IT'S
RELEVANT TO THE BILL BEFORE THE
BODY MITCHELL BEING TO MAKE
CONTINUE.
THANK YOU I THINK THAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SOMEWHERE INLAND
FROM HUNTINGTON BEACH MADE MY
POINT FOR ME I STAND IN SUPPORT
OF A S. B..
EIGHT TWENTY TWO SHE BONTA
DIRECTLY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES COLLEAGUES S. B.
EIGHT TWENTY TWO WILL GIVE.
CALIFORNIA WHAT CALIFORNIANS
DESERVE A FREE AND OPEN INTERNET.
PRINCIPAL COAUTHOR OF THIS BILL.
I OR JUST TO SEIZE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PASS.
THE STRONGEST NET NEUTRALITY
LEGISLATION IN THE COUNTRY.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHERE CALIFORNIA
SHOULD BE IN THIS FIGHT
[inaudible]
LEADING IT.
S. B. TWENTY TWO PROTECTS ALL
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS.
FROM THE POTENTIAL HARM OF
INTERNET ABUSE.
CALIFORNIANS LIKE SO MANY.
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY AND THE
WORLD RELY [inaudible]
ON A FREE AND OPEN INTERNET FOR
MANY FUNDAMENTAL SERVICES AND
FOR ACCESS TO VITAL INFORMATION
INCLUDING POLICE.
AND EMERGENCY SERVICES UTILITY
SERVICES TRANSPORTATION
ACCESSING THEIR HEALTH CARE
APPLYING FOR A JOB RUNNING SMALL
BUSINESS THE LIST GOES ON IN
ADDITION CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO
ONE OF THE WORLD'S LARGEST
INDUSTRIES.
ARE SILICON VALLEY.
WHICH IS BUILT ON THE CONCEPT OF
A FREE AND OPEN.
INTERNET WE HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
INNOVATORS IN THE STATE AND WE
MUST CONTINUE.
THE WORK TO PROTECT THAT SPIRIT
FINALLY S. B. TWENTY TWO IS
CONSISTENT WITH OUR CALIFORNIA
VALUES OF OPPORTUNITY EQUITY
JUSTICE AND INCLUSION THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE.
THE CALIFORNIA IS REAL AND
IMPACTS MANY RURAL AND INLAND
COMMUNITIES AND OTHERS THAT
STRUGGLE WITH ACCESS TO INTERNET
SERVICES EVERYONE EVERY
CALIFORNIAN.
DESERVES ACCESS TO AN OPEN AND
UNRESTRICTED INTERNET LET'S LEAD
THE WAY HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
LET'S PASS S. B. EIGHT TWENTY
TWO I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
IBOOK COLLEAGUES.
IF YOU MISSED BONTA MISS
MELENDEZ.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AFTER
LIFT LISTENING TO EVERYONE'S
COMMENTS.
I THINK I UNDERSTAND NOW WHERE
EVERYONE.
WHICH SIDE EVERYONE IS GOING TO
ON THIS ISSUE AND FOR MY
COLLEAGUES ACROSS THE AISLE.
I THINK IT IS BECOME ABUNDANTLY
CLEAR THAT THIS IS A RESISTANCE
EFFORT.
BECAUSE PRESIDENT TRUMP DIDN'T
RUIN THE INTERNET PRESIDENT
TRUMP DIDN'T CHANGE THE INTERNET
NOBODY IN CONGRESS DID THAT THIS
YEAR WAITING INTO AN AREA.
THAT YOU HAVE NO BUSINESS BEING
IN THIS IS A FEDERAL ISSUE THE
ARROGANCE ON THIS PLAN THIS
ISSUE IS COMICAL AT THIS POINT
[inaudible]
I MEAN.
I WOULD ARGUE THAT IF WE WE
ASKED FIVE PEOPLE IN HERE WHO
ARE ARGUING FOR THIS BILL YOU
COULDN'T EXPLAIN NET NEUTRALITY
IF YOUR LIFE DEPENDED ON IT
[inaudible]
THE LINE.
THIS IS NOT OUR ISSUE I GET IT.
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION MADE A
CHANGE AND IN CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATS WHO YOU YOU RESIST
CHANGE WHEN IT COMES TO THE
CURRENT ADMINISTRATION THAT'S
FINE [inaudible]
BUT DON'T PUT INTERNET CUSTOMERS
IN CALIFORNIA AT RISK DON'T
DISRUPT THEIR LIVES AND THEIR
INTERNET CONNECTION THEIR
SERVICE DON'T INTERRUPT THAT SO
THAT YOU CAN MAKE A POLITICAL
POINT THIS IS EMBARRASSING.
PLEASE VOTE NOW [inaudible]
MISTER ALAN.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
NET NEUTRALITY IS NOT ABOUT A
FREE AND OPEN INTERNET.
NET NEUTRALITY IS ABOUT
GOVERNMENT CENSORSHIP AND
REGULATION.
OF THE INTERNET.
WHAT NAY NEUTRALITY REALLY IS IS
NET NEUTRALITY?
IS A VERY SIMPLE PLAN. TO MAKE
THE INTERNET.
A TITLE TO COMMON CARRIER.
THIS WOULD MAKE.
THE INTERNET SUBJECT TO SAME
RULES.
THERE ARE PHONE COMPANIES
[inaudible] FOR INSTANCE ARE
SUBJECT.
TO THE PROPONENTS OF NET
NEUTRALITY LIKE TO SAY THAT THIS
IS ABOUT.
HAVING NO PAID PRIORITIZATION.
ON THE INTERNET.
BUT THINK ABOUT THIS LET'S TAKE
A LOOK AT OUR OUR POST OFFICE.
ANOTHER COMMON CARRIER.
WE YOU MAIL LETTER YOU CAN MAIL
IT FIRST CLASS.
YOU CAN ALSO MILLER PRIORITY YOU
CAN EVEN MAIL IT.
NEXT DAY [inaudible]
PAID PRIORITIZATION.
WITHOUT PAID PRIORITIZATION.
ON THE INTERNET.
THIS MEANS THAT YOUR AT HOME.
BUT YOU CAN'T WATCH YOUR NETFLIX
MOVIE.
BECAUSE YOUR NEIGHBOR DOWN THE
ROAD IS DOWNLOADING EIGHT PORN
MOVIES.
SO WHY SHOULD YOU HAVE TO PAY
[inaudible]
IN SPEED. FOR THE BEHAVIOR.
OF YOUR NEIGHBORS.
VERY SIMPLY THE MARKET HAS
ALREADY WORKED OUT A MECHANISM.
THE BOOK DEMAND THAT THE
DEMOCRATS WANT TO HAVE YOU
BELIEVE THAT SOMEHOW.
SOMEONE IS TRYING TO REGULATE
WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO SEE ON THE
INTERNET AND IF ONLY YOU ENACT
NET NEUTRALITY.
YOU KNOW WILL BE PROTECTED.
THE PROBLEM WITH THIS IS VERY
SIMPLE.
YOU'RE ALREADY PROTECTED TODAY.
THERE IS ANTI TRUST AND THEIR
ANTI TRUST LAWS.
PROTECT YOU AGAINST THIS.
THE VERY CIVIL MARKET MECHANISM
OF LEADER IN ITSELF PROTECTS YOU.
SIMPLY PUT NET NEUTRALITY IS
GOVERNMENT CENSORSHIP.
AND IT IS REGULATION OF THE
INTERNET.
NEVER MANY PEOPLE ARE CONFUSED
AS TO WHAT THE ULTIMATE ROOT.
OF WHY THE DEMOCRATS.
WANT NET NEUTRALITY AND WHY THEY
WANT TO REGULATE THE INTERNET.
AND POTENTIALLY EVEN CENSOR WHAT
WE SEE ON YOUR HEAD IT'S
FACTUALLY VERY SIMPLE.
BECAUSE BACK TO NINETEEN FORTY
NINE IN NINETEEN FORTY NINE THE
SEC CAME UP WITH SOME THE CALL
THE FAIRNESS DOCTRINE.
AND IT SOUNDED REALLY GOOD I'LL
TELL YOU WHAT IT WAS.
IT REQUIRED BROADCASTERS TO
PRESENT CONTROVERSIAL ISSUES IN
A MANNER THAT WAS HONEST.
EQUITABLE AND BALLOTS.
KIND OF SOUNDS LIKE FOX NEWS.
THE PROBLEM IS.
IS THAT BY.
NINETEEN SIXTY SIX THE DEMOCRATS
HAD FIGURED OUT THAT THIS IS A
TOOL THAT THEY CAN USE.
AND I WILL QUOTE.
BILL RUDER FORMER ASSISTANT
SECRETARY OF COMMERCE.
UNDER PRESIDENT KENNEDY.
WHO SAID THE FOLLOWING?
OUR MASSIVE STRATEGY WAS TO USE
THE FAIRNESS DOCTRINE TO
CHALLENGE AND HARASS RIGHT WING
BROADCASTERS AND HOPE THAT THE
CHALLENGES WOULD BE SO COSTLY TO
THEM THAT THEY WOULD BE
INHIBITED.
AND DECIDED IT WAS TOO EXPENSIVE
TO CONTINUE [inaudible]
VERY SIMPLY.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS A LONG
HISTORY OF USING SO CALLED
FAIRNESS.
AND RULES EXACTLY LIKE NET
NEUTRALITY TO SILENCE SPEECH
WITH WHICH THEY DISAGREE
VIOLATING OUR FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHTS.
BILL CLINTON EVEN RECOGNIZES IN
[inaudible]
NINETEEN NINETY SIX HE AMENDED.
THE COMMUNICATIONS ACT OF
NINETEEN THIRTY FOUR AND HE SAID.
THAT THE INTERNET SHOULD BE
UNFETTERED FROM FEDERAL OR STATE
REGULATION.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN NET
NEUTRALITY IS VERY SIMPLE THIS
IS NOT ABOUT BEING A FEDERAL
ISSUE OUR STATE ISSUES GOT NONE
OF THAT.
WHAT NET NEUTRALITY TRULY IS IS
AN EFFORT?
A CONCENTRATED EFFORT. TO
REGULATE YOUR INTERNET.
TREAT THE INTERNET LIKE A TITLE
TO COMMON CARRIER AND SAID YOU
THE SAME RULES THAT WE PUT UNDER
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES.
TREAT THE INTERNET LIKE A STODGY
UTILITY AND NOT THE VIBRANT
DIVERSE.
TOOL THAT WE ALL USE.
NET NEUTRALITY IS ABOUT IDEA NET
NEUTRALITY WILL LEAD TO HIGHER
COST YOU LEAD TO SLOWER
CONNECTIONS.
NET NEUTRALITY WILL LEAD TO LESS
CONTENT AND LESS DIVERSE VIEWS
ON THE INTERNET.
NET NEUTRALITY IS A VIOLATION OF
YOUR FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
BUT BEYOND ALL THAT.
IT'S JUST A BAD IDEA.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE A LONG
HISTORY OF TRYING TO REGULATE
WHAT WE HEAR WHAT WE SEE AND
WHAT WE BELIEVE.
THERE'S NO FAKE NEWS OF THIS THE
RECORD'S CLEAR NET NEUTRALITY IS
THE NEXT VERSION OF THE FAIRNESS
DOCTRINE. THIRTY CELULARES ROUND
SOLVE THIS WAS A BAD IDEA.
AS DID RONALD REAGAN.
LET'S KEEP THE INTERNET.
UNFETTERED FROM FEDERAL AND
STATE REGULATION.
LET'S GET READY NET NEUTRALITY
LET'S MAKE SURE THAT WE ALL HAVE
FASTER NET CONNECTIONS AND THE
MARKET WILL ACTUALLY SORT THIS
OUT.
WE DON'T NEED THE GOVERNMENT TO
SAVE US VOTE NO ON NET
NEUTRALITY.
THANK YOU MISTER AL.
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED MAKE
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
AS IT I AGREE I AGREE THAT WE
SHOULDN'T BE THE BODY THE HOUSE
TO MAKE THE DECISION WHEN IT
COMES TO THESE TYPES OF ISSUES.
WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO RELY ON THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO TO PROTECT
US SOMETHING THAT EVERY SINGLE
PERSON IN THIS STATE AND ACROSS
THE COUNTRY REGARDLESS OF YOUR
PARTY WHERE YOU'RE DEMOCRAT IN A
PEN REPUBLICAN.
OVERWHELMINGLY SUPPORTS IS A
FREE AND OPEN INTERNET AND WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO RELY ON OUR
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO NOT ROLL
BACK THOSE TYPES OF PROTECTIONS
THAT PROTECT US AND WHEN THAT
HAPPENS IT IS OUR JOB OUR JOB.
AS THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD WE'RE NOT JUST THE
REST OF THE NATION LOOKS TO SEE
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO ESPECIALLY
ON ISSUES OF TECHNOLOGY.
BECAUSE WERE LEADER BUT THEN
ALSO INTERNATIONALLY TO STEP UP
AND PROPOSE SOMETHING TO BE ABLE
TO PROTECT THE PEOPLE THAT WE
REPRESENT BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT
THEY EXPECT OF US.
THAT IS OUR JOB AND SO THAT IS
WHAT WOULD.
FILLING THE ROLE THAT WE NEED TO
FILL BECAUSE WE CANNOT RELY ON
THIS FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
PROTECT US WHEN WE NEED
PROTECTION AND I'M SORRY.
YOU ONLY NEED TO LOOK AT ONE
THING TO UNDERSTAND WHY YOU NEED
TO VOTE FOR THIS BILL OUR
FIREFIGHTERS TO EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF US.
REGARDLESS OF PARTY SPEAK SO
GLARINGLY OUT.
EVERY SINGLE TIME.
THEY'RE BATTLING ARE WILD FIRES.
AND THE ONE THING THAT THESE
COMPANIES CONTINUE TO SAY IS WE
DON'T BLOCK WE DON'T THROTTLE WE
DON'T DO THESE THINGS.
WE DON'T DO IT IT'S A NON ISSUE
WOULD NOT EXIST IN.
AND THEN THEY DO IT.
TALK ABOUT THE DUMBEST THING
THEY COULD HAVE POSSIBLY DONE TO
CONVINCE US.
THAT THEIR LION.
THEY CLEARLY DO IT IT'S AN ISSUE
THAT HIT THE FIREFIGHTERS THAT
ARE FIGHTING TO PROTECT OUR
CONSTITUENTS HOMES FIGHTING TO
PROTECT OUR CONSTITUENTS LIVES
SO I'M SORRY.
I'M SO I'M SORRY THAT THEY'RE
UPSET BUT THEY CREATED THIS
ISSUE FOR THEMSELVES HAD THEY
NOT WORK FOR YEARS TO GET RID OF
NET NEUTRALITY ON THE FEDERAL
LEVEL WE WOULDN'T BE HERE
DISCUSSING THIS ISSUE RIGHT NOW.
IT'S A PROBLEM THAT THEY CREATED
ON THE AROUND NOW WE'RE STEPPING
UP AND WE'RE DOING OUR JOB TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR CONSTITUENTS
AND THE PEOPLE THAT RELY ON US
TO DO OUR JOB.
KNOW THAT WE'RE PROTECTING THEM
AND WE'RE DOING WHAT'S RIGHT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
NAMES CALDERON MISTER DALLI.
THERE YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I'D JUST LIKE. FOR THIS BODY TO
JUST GET INTERNET TO HALF OF MY
DISTRICT AND THEN WE'LL TALK
ABOUT HOW WE CAN REGULATE IT.
THANK YOU MISTER DALLI MISS
GALLAGHER HERE RECOGNIZE.
THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER A PHONE
ON MY COLLEAGUE FROM BEAVER --
A VERY GOOD POINT BECAUSE THE
COSTS OF COMPLIANCE WITH THIS
BILL.
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO IMPACT
BROADBAND EXPANSION WHICH MANY
OF US HAVE FOUGHT. FOR TWO IN TO
BRING MORE INTERNET SERVICE TO
RURAL AREAS AND AND TO
UNDERSERVED PARTS OF THE STATE.
SO THAT'S A VERY REAL ISSUE --
ALSO ELIMINATING ZERO RATING.
IS GOING TO ELIMINATE.
SAVINGS TO CONSUMERS INCLUDING
MANY OF THE LOW INCOME FOLKS IN
THE STATE.
WHO AS WAS POINTED OUT BY MY
COLLEAGUE?
UTILIZE THEIR PHONES MUCH MORE
TO GET OUT TO GET OUT THIS VITAL
DATA INFORMATION SO.
EVEN SOME OF THE POINTS THAT ARE
BEING BROUGHT UP AS REASONS TO
VOTE FOR THIS DOESN'T ACTUALLY
HELP IT ACTUALLY HURTS CONSUMERS.
THESE REGULATIONS BUT LET'S GET
BACK TO BECAUSE WE START OFF
THIS DEBATE BY.
WHY WE'RE ALL HERE?
AND THE REAL REASON THAT WE'RE
ALL HERE.
IS SO THAT.
YOU GUYS CAN LIKE OUT DEBATE
EACH OTHER TRYING TO PLACATE
YOUR BASE.
OVER A BOOGEYMAN ISSUE OF NET
NEUTRALITY WE ALL AGREE ON THE
PRINCIPLES OF NET NEUTRALITY.
YOU ARE MY COLLEAGUE FROM IRAN
YOU KNOW WHO'S KIND OF KNOWN FOR
HIS.
HYPERBOLE AN EMBELLISHMENT --
YOU DID A REALLY GOOD JELLY POLY
GET ANOTHER TWO POINTS OVER 70%.
IN HIS HOME DISTRICT --
VIA ó EIGHTY SORRY YOU KNOW SO
HEY LOOK HE'S HE'S GONNA.
JACK OF THE POINTS AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS IS REALLY ALL ABOUT IS
TRYING TO PLACATE.
THAT MASON SHOW HOW HARD YOU'RE
FIGHTING AGAINST TRUMP WINNER
REALITY NONE OF THE STUFF IS
REALLY HAPPENING HAVE APPOINTED
ANY EVIDENCE.
OF THIS REALLY HAPPENING --
AND OF PEOPLE SLOWING DOWN
PURPOSELY PEOPLE'S DATA.
THAT HASN'T THAT HAS NOT BEEN
SUBMITS OCCURRED HERE THE THE
ISSUE THAT WAS BROUGHT UP
ACTUALLY HELD A SELECT COMMITTEE
ON THIS.
AND ACTUALLY EXPLAIN WHAT HAD
HAPPENED THE X. THEY HAVE
EXCEEDED THEIR DATA PLAN.
AND THE PEOPLE CALLED WAS A
HUMAN ERROR ISSUE.
ON BEHALF OF THE COMPANY IT WAS
OF THE COMPANY ITSELF
PURPOSEFULLY SLOWING DOWN
PEOPLE'S DATA.
AND AND AND IN FACT THE COMPANY
CAME BACK AND SAID NOW WE'RE
GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT IT FOR
EMERGENCY SERVICES IN THE STATE
THAT THEY DO HAVE THAT.
UNLIMITED DATA SO THAT THEY
DON'T RUN INTO THAT PROBLEM
AGAIN.
SO.
YOU EVEN THE ESSENCE OF THE
PEOPLE ARE POINT AND OH BY THE
WAY THE POLICY YOU'RE PASSING
TODAY WOULD DO NOTHING ABOUT
THAT SITUATION.
BY THE WAY LET'S TELL THE TRUTH.
THE POLICY OR PASSIVE THEY WOULD
DO NOTHING ABOUT THAT SITUATION
PERIOD.
SO WHAT WE'RE REALLY HEAR ABOUT
IS.
AGAIN TRYING TO PLACATE. TO THE
LEFT BASS.
ENJOY YOUR OUT DO EACH OTHER IN
FACT THIS BILL WAS KILLED --
WAS STOPPED IN A COMMITTEE.
AND THAT BRINGS ME TO ANOTHER
POINT OF WHY WE'RE HERE YBER
BULLYING.
MAYBE WE SHOULD START TAKING
THAT UP THAT ISSUE BECAUSE WHAT
I'VE SEEN MORE SO.
IS PEOPLE.
BOWING DOWN TO THE BOWLING THAT
THEY'RE RECEIVING ONLINE.
AND FORCING PEOPLE TO PASS A BAD
POLICY THAT'S NOT CONSISTENT
WITH FEDERALISM.
MSGOING TO CREATE A PATCHWORK
OF THINGS ACTUALLY GONNA SLOW
DOWN PEOPLE'S ABILITY TO GET
GOOD DATA AND I FIND IT SO
INTERESTING.
THEY WE TALK ABOUT WHAT WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY HAS
ACCESS TO ALL POINTS OF VIEW AND
CONTENT.
THE DATA WE DON'T WANT TO
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST CONTENT.
WHEN THIS BODY IS THE ONE THAT
SAY THE GOVERNMENT SHOULD GET IN
THE BUSINESS OF TELLING YOU WHAT
IS FAKE NEWS AND WHAT'S NOT?
JUST YESTERDAY WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT THAT THE REAL THREAT. TO
FREE SPEECH THE REAL THREAT WHEN
IT COMES TO CENSORSHIP IS THIS
BODY RIGHT HERE.
THAT IS NOT I S. PIECE IT'S
ACTUALLY GROUPS LIKE YOU.
TO AND FACEBOOK AND TWITTER.
WHO HAVE ACTUALLY SEEN ACTUALLY
DO THIS?
ACTUALLY DISCRIMINATE BASED ON
CONTENT ACTUALLY SAY THAT WE
DON'T YOU ACTUALLY SLOW DOWN
ACTUALLY BLOCK [inaudible]
CONTENT.
FROM VIEW POINTS THAT THEY DON'T
AGREE WITH.
NOT THE HIGHEST PEAS.
BUT I'LL SEE YOU GUYS STAND UP
AND DO ANYTHING ABOUT THAT.
BUT HEY IT'S JUST ANOTHER DAY
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE.
MAYBE THIS BILL ONLY GET TO
THIRTY NINE BUT DOESN'T MATTER
WILL BULLY OUR WAY TO FORTY ONE
RIGHT.
ALL DEBATE AND DISCUSSION HAVING
CEASED.
MISTER SANTIAGO YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE THE A
ROBUST DEBATE --
BUT THERE'S A PHILOSOPHICAL
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN SOME OF OUR
FRIENDS ON THE OPPOSITE SIDE OF
THE AISLE --
IN TERMS OF THE ISSUE OF NET
NEUTRALITY BUT I'M STILL HOPEFUL
THAT THEY'LL BE PIE PARTISAN
SUPPORT BECAUSE AT THE END OF
THE DAY.
I THINK TRULY THAT YOU BELIEVE
THAT THERE SHOULD BE AN OPEN.
AND FREE INTERNET.
I HEAR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL IS REALLY A QUESTION
OF VALUES.
STATED OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
DO YOU BELIEVE IN NET NEUTRALITY.
DO YOU BELIEVE.
AND A FREE AND OPEN INTERNET.
AND IT'S PRETTY SIMPLE BECAUSE
IF YOU DO.
YOU PRESS THE GREEN BUTTON THAT
MEANS YES.
AND IF YOU DON'T.
YOU PRESS THE RED.
ONE OR SOMETHING IN BETWEEN.
NOW THE WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME
HERE TALKING ABOUT JURISDICTION.
AND WHETHER IT'S A FEDERAL ISSUE.
OR A STATE ISSUE.
AND THEN MAYBE FIST
PHILOSOPHICAL DISAGREEMENT ON
THAT BUT I WILL REMIND YOU.
THAT IN THIS CHAMBER.
WE HAVE TAKEN A NUMBER OF
STANCES.
THAT REFLECT OUR VALUES HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO WHEN THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
I TAX IMMIGRANTS [inaudible]
HERE.
INSTEAD OF CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
PROTECT THEM.
AND WE FOUGHT BACK.
STATE YOUR POINT OF ORDER SHALL --
SPEAKER JUST SAID THAT THE
PRESIDENT ATTACKS IMMIGRANTS
THAT'S ACTUALLY A FALSE CLAIM.
AND I WOULD ASK HIM TO YOU ARE
YOU KNOW REFRAIN FOR MAKING
FALSE CLAIMS ABOUT THE PRESENT
I'D STATES [inaudible]
MISTER ALAN.
POINT OF ORDER IS NOT WELL TAKEN
THAT THE JOCKEY ON THE BILL IS
REFERRING TO THE PRESIDENT'S
POLICIES I WOULD HAVE.
THE AUTHOR THE JOCKEY HOWEVER.
REFRAIN FROM ANY DISCUSSION
BEYOND THE MERITS OF THE BILL.
WE'VE HAD A ROBUST DEBATE ON THE
MATTER.
LET'S CLOSE THIS OUT AND TAKE A
VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE QUESTION BEFORE US.
IS DO YOU BELIEVE IN A FREE AND
OPEN INTERNET AND HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE THE ABILITY
TO STAND UP.
SEND A MESSAGE ADDRESS THIS
COUNTRY.
BY VOTING YES.
ON S. B..
EIGHT TWO TWO SPEAKER
RESPECTFULLY ASK ABOUT.
QUIRK LIBERAL ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
TO DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE ANTI THE VOTE EYES
FIFTY EIGHT NO.
SEVENTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
TAKE OUT MS FRIEDMAN'S ITEMS.
OKAY MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE THIS FRIEDMAN TAKE UP HER
ITEMS.
FILE ITEMS ONE NINETY EIGHT AND
TWO ó ONE WILL START WITH FILE
ITEM [inaudible] ONE EIGHT THAT
IS S. B. [inaudible]
TWELVE FIFTEEN CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL TWELVE FIFTEEN BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG ACCOLADES
WATER [inaudible]
THIS FRIEDMAN.
AND NOW FOR SOMETHING COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT.
S. B. TWELVE FIFTEEN ENSURES
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES CAN
RECEIVE ADEQUATE AND SUSTAINABLE
SEWER SERVICE.
S. B. TWELVE FIFTEEN AUTHORIZES
THE REGIONAL WATER BOARDS TO
REQUIRE CONSOLIDATION WORKS
TENSION OF WASTEWATER SERVICES
TO DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
MANY OF WHICH RELY ON AN
ADEQUATE ONSITE SEWAGE TREATMENT
SYSTEMS.
IT REQUIRES A STATE WATER BOARD
TO COVER THE COSTS OF COMPLETING
THE EXTENSION OF SERVICES TO THE
RECEIVING SEWER SYSTEM UPON
FUNDING FROM THE LEGISLATURE.
IT ALSO ALLOWS AFFECTED PROPERTY
OWNERS TO HOPPED OUT OF THE
PROVISION OF SEWER SERVICE.
WE MAY MY ALSO PROGRESS TO
ENSURE ALL COMMUNITIES RECEIVE
SAFE DRINKING WATER NOW IT'S
TIME WE ADDRESS THEIR WASTE
WATER NEEDS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS FRIEDMAN SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
COR CLUB IN THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TELL ME ABOUT
AYE AYES FORTY THREE NOTES
TWENTY THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE TAKING UP FILE ITEM TO A
ONE IS FILE ITEM TO A ONE S. B.
[inaudible]
THIRTEEN HUNDRED CORKERY.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN HUNDRED BY
SENATOR JACKSON ANOTHER WAS AN
ACT RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT.
IT'S FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
AS WE'VE ALL LEARNED ADDRESSING
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IS NOT JUST
ABOUT HOLDING PERPETRATORS
ACCOUNTABLE ALTHOUGH OF COURSE
THAT'S CRITICAL.
IT'S ALSO VITAL THAT WE ENSURE
THAT OUR LAWS ON OUR WORKPLACES
PROTECT VICTIMS ALLOW THEM TO
SPEAK OUT ABOUT HARASSMENT AND
SEEK JUSTICE FOR SEXUAL
HARASSMENT COURTS.
S. B. THIRTEEN HUNDRED IS THE
RESULT OF A NUMBER OF THOUGHTFUL
HEARINGS HELD BY THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE IN THE
SENATE SELECT COMMITTEE ON WOMEN
WORK AND FAMILIES EARLIER THIS
YEAR.
AND SEEKS TO STRENGTHEN
PROTECTIONS FOR SEXUAL
HARASSMENT VICTIMS IN A NUMBER
OF KEY AREAS.
FIRST SB THIRTEEN HUNDRED
PROVIDES GUIDANCE A THE COURTS
ON THE SEVERE AND PERVASIVE
LEGAL STANDARD.
WHICH IS VERY VAGUE RIGHT NOW
UNDER THE LAW.
THE BILL PRESERVES THE SEVERE
AND PERVASIVE LEGALSTANDARD FOR
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN PLACE AND
IT'S A HIGH BAR. TO REACH THAT
IT PROVIDES KEY GUIDANCE OF THE
COURTS TO ENSURE THAT THE
STANDARD IS CONSISTENTLY AND
FAIRLY APPLIED.
REGARDLESS OF WHERE AN EMPLOYEE
WORKS OR HOW PRODUCTIVE THEY'VE
BEEN AT WORK FOLLOWING A
COLLEAGUES HARASSMENT.
SECOND S. B. THIRTEEN HUNDRED
CLOSES LEGAL LOOPHOLES BY
PROHIBITING NON DISPARAGEMENT
AGREEMENT OR WHAT'S COMMONLY
KNOWN AS SNEAKY RELEASES.
THE BILL PROHIBITS EMPLOYERS
FROM REQUIRING WORKERS TO SIGN
AWAY THEIR ABILITY TO SPEAK OUT
ABOUT HARASSMENT OR ABUSE OR THE
RIGHT TO FILE A CLAIM AGAINST AN
EMPLOYER.
AS A CONDITION OF EMPLOYMENT OR
CONTINUED EMPLOYMENT OR FOUR
WAGER BONUS THIS IS NOT THE
SECRET SETTLEMENTS THAT WE'VE
HEARD ABOUT THIS IS NOT ABOUT
SETTLEMENTS AFTER CLAIMS FILED.
THIS IS ABOUT EMPLOYERS WHO SAY
IF YOU WANT A BONUS OR YOU WANT
A PROMOTION OR YOU WANT TO WAGE
YOU HAVE TO IN ADVANCE SIGN AWAY
YOUR RIGHTS TO ANY FUTURE
LAWSUIT.
THIRD AB THIRTEEN HUNDRED ALLOWS
BUT DOES NOT REQUIRE EMPLOYERS
TO PROVIDE BYSTANDER INTERVENING
TRAINING AS PART OF THEIR
REGULAR SEXUAL HARASSMENT
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS. TO BE
CLEAR BECAUSE I'VE HEARD SOME ON
THIS UNDERSTANDING OF THIS
BYSTANDER TRAINING IS NOT
TRAINING PEOPLE THAT ARE OUTSIDE
YOUR SPHERE OF INFLUENCE AS AN
EMPLOYER.
OF COURSE THAT WOULD BE RID OF
RIDICULOUS STANDARD BUT RATHER
HOW TO TRAIN YOUR OWN EMPLOYEES
HOW TO INTERVENE IF THEY WITNESS
SEXUAL HARASSMENT FROM ONE OF
THEIR COLLEAGUES.
RECENT AMENDMENTS HAVE REMOVED
THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE'S JOB
KILLER LABEL FROM THE BILL.
THE BILL COLLECTIVELY SEEKS TO
PROVIDE MANY OF THE PROTECTIONS
FOR VICTIMS OF MOST OF US EXPECT
AS A MATTER OF COURSE TOMORROW
LAWS.
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISREAD IN THIS RACE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN
HUNDRED JACKSONVILLE.
MEMBERS WE'VE SEEN MANY MEASURES
ON THIS FLOOR INCLUDING TWO OF
MY OWN THAT ARE IN DIRECT
RESPONSE TO ISSUES THAT HAVE
BEEN HIGHLIGHTED.
DURING THE ME TOO MOVEMENT
HEARINGS.
THESE ACTIONS ARE CRITICAL IN
ORDER TO RESTORE TRUST OF THE
PUBLIC.
AND DO WHAT WE MUST TO PROTECT
FOR POTENTIAL VICTIMS. ONE OF
THE MOST CRITICAL PROBLEMS WE
FACE IS THE ISSUE WITH NON
DISPARAGEMENT AGREEMENTS.
IT'S CAN UNDERCUT VICTIMS.
S. B. THIRTEEN HUNDRED PROHIBITS
AN EMPLOYER FROM USING A RAZOR
BONUSES AND INCENTIVE.
OR CONDITION OF EMPLOYMENT AS A
CONDITION FOR HAVING AN
INDIVIDUAL SIGN THESE AGREEMENTS.
WE WILL NEVER HAVE WORKPLACE IS
FREE FROM HARASSMENT WHEN WE
GIVE HER ANSWERS A PERMISSION
SLIP. TO BEHAVE BADLY.
THIS BILL IS REASONABLE.
IT DOES NOT APPLY TO SEVERANCE
AGREEMENTS IT ALSO DOES NOT
APPLY TO SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS
THAT ARE MUTUALLY NEGOTIATED.
IT'S PUT AN END TO THE TACTICS
THAT ENABLE HARASSERS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON A. B. OR SP [inaudible]
THIRTEEN HUNDRED FAMOUS RACE.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
CLARK LIBERAL ON MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO GO
XANDER INCENTIVE PROGRAM WITH
THE GOAL OF DECREASING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS FROM
VEHICLES USED BY DRIVERS AS
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK COMPANIES.
OF THE PROGRAM WORK CELEBRATE
THE UP.
TAKE OF ELECTRIC VEHICLES ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES DEPLOYED BY
CALIFORNIA'S TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK COMPANIES WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
THANK YOU MISTER TANG SCENE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN ROLL-ON.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE GO
MISTER
TECH.
MISTER TING MOVES CALL.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP
CONCURRENCE ITEMS NOW.
THIS IS CONCURRENCE.
AND SENATE AMENDMENTS.
BEGINNING AT THE TOP OF THE FILE.
THIS IS CONCURRENCE FILE ITEMS
EIGHT AND NINE HOUSE A RETAIN.
WE GOING TO TAKE A FILE ITEM TEN
AB [inaudible]
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO A
CORPORATE.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO BY SOME MEMORY AS AND OTHERS
AND I PLAYED A MEDI CAL
[inaudible]
MS RACE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO IS BACK TO
THE ASSEMBLY ON CONCURRENCE.
BILL ENSURES THAT THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES MEETS
ITS STATE.
AND FEDERAL MANDATES FOR CHILD
BLOOD LEAD TESTING AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO HAS RECEIVED NEARLY
UNANIMOUS.
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND A WIDE
COALITION OF SUPPORT.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU ISRAEL'S [inaudible]
DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND WANT
TO THANK THE MEMBER FROM SAN
BERNADINO FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD.
LEAD POISONING IS SOMETHING MANY
INDIVIDUALS ONLY.
THINK ONLY IMPACTS AREAS LIKE
FLINT MICHIGAN.
ACCORDING TO THE RESEARCH DOZENS
OF CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES HAVE
EXPERIENCED RECENT RATES OF
CHILDHOOD.
LEAD POISONING THAT SURPASSED
THOSE OF FLINT MICHIGAN. ONE OF
THOSE SUCH COMMUNITIES IS IN MY
DISTRICT.
THE NINE THREE SEVEN OH ONE ZIP
CODE IN FRESNO COMMUNITY HAS
CHILDHOOD LEAD POISONING RATES
NEARLY THREE TIMES AS HIGH.
AS THOSE APPOINT.
THAT'S THIRTEEN POINT 6% A BLOOD
TEST COMPARED 25% IN FLINT.
WE SHOULDN'T HAVE CHILDREN BEING
POISONED BY LEAD ANYWHERE BUT
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE ESPECIALLY SHOULDN'T BE
SEEING IT HERE.
THIS BILL MOVES US CLOSER TO THE
GOAL THAT ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND I URGE
HER AYE VOTE ON AB.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO THANK YOU
DOCTOR ARAMBULA SAYING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
ITEM.
CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
THIS OUT VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE
AND DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AND OF OF
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT
ICE FOR DEFY AYE.
FIFTY SIX NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT AND
PASS RETAIN ON FILE ITEM.
ELEVEN THIS IS FILE ITEM TWELVE
AB [inaudible]
EIGHT EIGHTY GRAY.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT EIGHTY BY
SOME REMEMBER GRAY AND ACCURATE
AS TRIBAL GAMING.
MR GRAY YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
MEMBERS AB AB EIGHT EIGHTY WILL
ESTABLISH EFFECTIVE.
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK FOR THE
TRIBAL NATION GRANT FUND
INCREASE THE IMPACT OF GAMING
REVENUES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
FOR LIMITED GAMING TRIBES AND
NON GAMING TRIBES.
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
TODAY.
THINGS GRAY SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
CLICK WELL OF IN THE ROLE I'M.
SARAH VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK.
WELL CLOSE ROLLING TIED ABOUT
AYE SPEAKING I KNOW ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN IZZY TWO
THOUSAND CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO THOUSAND BY
SOME REMEMBER KALRA ANOTHER
CYNICAL IN ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES
KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ON THE MEMBERS TO SOME A
BILL TWO THOUSAND WOULD REVISE
AN EXISTING TITLES EXCEPTION FOR
THE SAP'S CENTER.
HOME OF THE SAN JOSE SHARKS TO
ALIGN WITH OTHER EXCEPTIONS
PROVIDE GREATER FLEXIBILITY
REGARDLESS OF THEIR MEANS OWNER
OR VENDOR ARRANGEMENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
FAMOUS KALRA.
SEEN NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN ROLL-ON.
WE STARTED VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
QUIRK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE.
TELL YOU THAT I SIXTY NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS.
OUR CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM.
FOURTEEN IS A. B. NINETEEN
EIGHTY ONE CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN EIGHTY
ONE BY SOME WOMEN REALLY MOMENT
ACCOLADE THE SOLID WASTE
[inaudible]
THIS AMONG.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE A. B. NINETEEN
EIGHTY ONE BILLS OFF PREVIOUSLY
PASSED LEGISLATION.
BY ADDING HELLFIRE IN THE FOREST
MANAGEMENT TASKS FIRST TO THE
AGENCY COORDINATION BETWEEN
REQUIRED BETWEEN CAL EPA CAO
RECYCLE.
CDFA AIR B. AND C. W. R. C. BEAT
TO DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT
POLICIES THAT FAVOR ORGANIC
WASTE FROM LANDFILLS AND PROMOTE
COMPOST USED EXPECT WE ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS EMMA.
SAY NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL UP THE ROLE.
AND MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERSVOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIXTY THREE NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
PASS RETAIN ON FILE ITEM.
FIFTEEN FILE ITEM SIXTEEN IS AB
TWENTY FOUR FORTY ONE BY MISTER
FRAZIER CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR FORTY
ONE BY SOME A MEMBER FRAZIER
ANOTHER SNACK RELATING TO
SACRAMENTO SAN JOAQUIN DELTA
[inaudible]
MISTER FRAZIER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR FORTY
ONE DIRECTS THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION IN CONSULTATION WITH
STATE AND LOCAL JURISDICTIONAL
AGENCIES. TO DEVELOP A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN FOR THE
REMOVAL OF A BAND IN COMMERCIAL
VESSELS IN THE DELTA.
THESE ABANDONED VESSELS POSE A
DIRECT THREAT TO THE DELTA DELTA
ENVIRONMENT AN ECOSYSTEM.
AND THE NAVIGATION OF THE DELTA
AND US ENTIRE STATES WATER
QUALITY.
THE BILL PASSED OF THE SENATE ON
A THIRTY NINE ZERO VOTE AND I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST RIVAL.
THINGS FRAZIER SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE CORPORAL OF THE RIDE.
SARAH VOTE OF ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
AND ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE VOTE I SIXTY NO
ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT AND PASS AND RETAIN
ON FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN IS AB.
TWENTY NINE SIXTY THREE BY
MISTER KALRA CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE SIXTY
THREE BY SIMPLY MEMBER KALRA
ANOTHER SNACK LEAD TO EMPLOYMENT.
THIS YEAR KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
A BETWEEN AYE SIXTY THREE PER
IMPROVE OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS ARE MADE AWARE OF AND
HANDLE CASES OF LEAD POISONING
MY WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA.
WOULD HELP PREVENT REPEATED OR
PROLONGED INCIDENTS A LEAD
POSING IN WORKPLACES.
SENATE AMENDMENT STREAMLINED HOW
INFORMATION IS REPORTED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH TO THE
DIVISION OF OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY
AND HEALTH.
MEMBERS LEAD POISONING I CAN
CAUSE HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE
COGNITIVE DIFFICULTIES RESULT
MISCARRIAGES OR PREMATURE BIRTH
AND PREGNANT WOMEN THAT CAN
CAUSE IRREVERSIBLE NERVOUS
SYSTEM.
AND KIDNEY DAMAGE UP.
THIS BILL SIMPLY ASSURES OF
THOSE WORKERS WERE EXPOSED TO
HIGH LEVELS OF LED POSING ARE
MADE KNOWN TO QALISYA ABOUT CAL
OSHA CONDUCT A WORKPLACE SAFETY
INVESTIGATION. TO DETERMINE HELP
IT AND HELP BUSINESSES CORRECT.
BECAUSE OF LEAD POISONING.
IT DOESN'T REQUIRE --
ANY CONCLUSION OF GALLOWS SHOWN
FACT.
OBGYN ACTUALLY HELP BUSINESSES I
GET NOT ONLY GETTING COMPLIANCE
BUT PREVENT THE DELAY OF
INSPECTIONS WHICH CAN BE MUCH
COSTLIER FOR EMPLOYERS AT THE
APPLE IF THEY'RE NOT INFORMED OF
AN ISSUE.
UNTIL YEARS AND YEARS LATER --
THE THOUGH OF THE REP THE THE
REHABILITATION CAN BE FAR MORE
COSTLY AS WELL AS LITIGATION.
AT THIS BILL SIMPLY BECAUSE CAL
OSHA LOOKING TO WORK SIZE AND
HAVE WORKERS WITH ELEVATED BLOOD
LEVELS ACTOR ABOVE TWENTY FIVE
MICROGRAMS PER DECILITER THE
LEVEL RECOMMENDED BY FEDERAL
GUIDELINES HAS ALREADY ADOPTED
BY THIRTY SEVEN OTHER STATES.
INCLUDING STATES SUCH AS TEXAS
ARKANSAS AND TENNESSEE.
THIS IS A MODEST AND COMMON
SENSE APPROACH TO HELP ENSURE
THAT PROPER NOTIFICATIONS AND
FOLLOW UPPER MADE IN ORDER TO
PROTECT PRESENT AND FUTURE
WORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
UP WE CERTAINLY CANNOT HAVE
ANOTHER EXCITE SITUATION AND THE
SPELL THIS BILL CERTAINLY HELP
ENSURE THAT STUFF WE ASK YOU AYE
VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CLERK LOCAL ROLL-ON.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS THERE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF OF
SURE KALRA MOVES A CALL
[inaudible]
THIS IS.
I AM NINETEEN AB THIRTY ONE
TWENTY CORPORATE.
SO WE WILL THIRTY ONE TWENTY BY
SIMPLY MEMBER GONZALEZ FLETCHER
ACT LIKE A CHILDHOOD SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER A. B. THIRTY ONE
TWENTIES BACK ON CONCURRENT
SENATE AMENDMENTS WERE
CLARIFYING AND AT A CHAPTER NOW
PROVISION.
SINCE IT MOVED TO THE SENATE
THIS BILL NOW HAS THE SUPPORT OF
THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION AND POOR ACT IN
ADDITION TO SUPPORT BY VICTIMS
ADVOCATE GROUPS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY VOTE.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CORD BLOOD ROLE ON MEMBERS VOTE.
THESE ARE VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLAND HOW I VOTE ICE
FORTY SIX KNOWS.
FOR THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
AND THIS IS FILE ITEM.
TWENTY AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR
COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR BY SOMETHING MEMBER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AND ACTUALLY
IN CRIMINAL LAW.
MISS GONZALEZ FLETCHER AB
EIGHTEEN ARE FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
AMENDMENTS AND SENATE CLARIFIED
OUR INTENTION OF THE BILL THE
BILL HAS NOT YET RECEIVED A NO
VOTE I HOPE THAT STANDS HERE AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
SAME KNOW DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLL-ON.
THIS OUT OF HURT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS DECIDED THOUGH
[inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I FIFTY FIVE
NO ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM
TWENTY ONE IS AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTY EIGHT CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE THIRTY
EIGHT BY SOME A MEMBER DAVID
CHIU AND OTHERS AND ATLANTA
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS.
RESEARCH YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY
EIGHT SIX TO REDUCE BARRIERS TO
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSING.
I AND IT'S BACK ON CONCURRENCE
SENATE AMENDMENTS SIGNIFICANTLY
NARROWED THE SCOPE OF THE BILL
IN EAST IMPLEMENTATION.
THE AMENDMENTS WERE DRAFTED WITH
EXTENSIVE INPUT FROM
STAKEHOLDERS AND THE
ADMINISTRATION AND REMOVED OR
ALLEVIATED MUCH OF THE BILL'S
OPPOSITION.
SINCE BILL'S PROVISIONS DON'T GO
INTO EFFECT UNTIL JUNE TWENTY A
LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS
WITH STAKEHOLDERS IF THERE ANY
LINGERING CONCERNS WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CORPORATE RURAL --
THE SAD VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
AND A VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
MR CHIU MOVES A CALL
.
FILE ITEM.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
QUICK READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CUNNINGHAM AND ACTUALLY A
SPECIAL EDUCATION.
MISTER CUTTING HIM.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY MEMBERS IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE WE TOOK
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS IN THE
SENATE. TO ADDRESS SOME CONCERNS
RAISED BY [inaudible]
THE ADMINISTRATION.
STRONG BILL IT'S GONNA DO.
A LOT OF GOOD FOR OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN THE AREA OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE
THESE ARE DIVERT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE THAT
I SIXTY ONE NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED AND FILE ITEM.
TWENTY THREE AB THIRTY TO SIXTY
FOUR GRAY.
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TO
SIXTY FOUR BUT THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION AND
ACTUALLY ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES
MISTER RAY.
MEMBERS AB THREE TO SIXTY FOURS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE THIS DEALS
WITH CRAFT DISTILLERS.
AND QUAN COURSE --
CONDUCT AS WELL AS DISTILLED
SPIRITS WHOLESALERS SOME.
I WOULD ASK YOUR AYE VOTE COULD
YOU.
SAY NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
QUIRK CLUB THE ROLL-ON.
DESERT OF OF ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE OF EYES
[inaudible]
FIFTY SIX NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED AND PASS RETAIN A FILE
ON TWENTY FOUR WE ARE FOLLOWED.
TWENTY FIVE AB TEN NINETY TO THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN NINETY TWO BY
SOME A MEMBER COOLEY AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY TO HEALTH CARE
SERVICE PLANS.
MISTER COOLEY.
CALLING THIS BILL DEALS WITH THE
USE.
STATISTICAL PLANS TO EVALUATE
FRAUD.
SPECIALIZED FIELD OF HEALTH CARE
SENTIMENTS WORKED OUT WITH THE
PARTNER MENTION OF CARE IT'S
GOOD BILL ORIGINALLY VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS COOLEY.
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE.
LOCAL OF THE OWN --
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLAND TALLY ABOUT
EYES FIFTY NINE NO ZERO THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX IS AB.
TWENTY SIX NINETY SIX A
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SIX NINETY SIX BY THREE MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ AND ACT IN A PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE THE EMPLOYEE RETIREMENT
THE PREPARATION THERE.
FOR THIS RODRIGUEZ.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE RISE
PRESENT AB TWENTY SIX NINETY SIX
WHICH IS BACK FROM THE CENTER
FOR CONCURRENT WITH SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
THIS BILL SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS AND NO
HAS NO OPPOSITION.
RESPECT OUTRIGHT VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERICAL THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
THIS ARE VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF OF ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TALBOT EYES FORTY
SEVEN THOSE NINE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM.
TWENTY SEVEN IS AB THIRTY TO
THIRTY ONE COOPERATE ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY TO THIRTY ONE BY
SOME A MEMBER GRAY AND ACTUALLY
TO EMPLOYMENT [inaudible]
MR GRAY.
THEY MISTREAT REMEMBERS AB
THIRTY THIRTY ONE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THIS MAKES SEVERAL
CHANGES LABOR CODE.
RELIGIOUS CERTIFIED PAYROLL
REPORTS ENSURING A TRANSPARENCY
AROUND THOSE OUT RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
SEEN NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CARP WILL OPEN.
ROSARIO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DECIDE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND HOW I LOVE.
AYE AYES.
FORTY SEVEN KNOWS.
ELEVEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT FILE ITEM TWENTY
EIGHT IS AB TWELVE FORTY SEVEN
COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE FORTY SEVEN
BY SOME REMEMBERED AS ARIANNA
AND ACTUALLY PROFESSIONS AND
VOCATIONS.
THE SERVICE AREA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I'M PRESENTING AB TWELVE FORTY
SEVEN FOR CONCURRENCE THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE PROFESSIONAL
FIDUCIARY IS TO RECEIVE CULTURAL
COMPETENCY TRAINING. FOR SERVING
PATIENTS IN THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY
PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARY IS
PROVIDE CRITICAL SERVICES TO
SENIORS AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES THEY MANAGE MATTERS
FOR CLIENTS INCLUDING DAILY CARE.
HOUSING AND MEDICAL NEEDS.
UNFORTUNATELY LGBT Q. SENIORS
FACE UNIQUE CHALLENGES AS THEY
AGE AND ARE AMONG THE MOST
VULNERABLE.
A WITHIN THE POPULATION IN OUR
SOCIETY.
AB TWELVE TWELVE FORTY SEVEN IS
INTENDED TO ENSURE THAT THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY SENIORS GET
COMPETENT AND RESPECTFUL CARE BY
PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARY EASE BY
REQUIRING LGBTQ CULTURAL
COMPETENCY.
AND SENSITIVITY TRAINING.
A THIS WOULD BE A ONE HOUR
TRAINING REQUIRED DURING THE
INITIAL LICENSING PROCESS.
AND EVERY THREE YEARS WITHIN THE
CONTINUING EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TAG BUT ICE FORTY
FIVE NO SIX SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRENT AND FILE ITEM
TWENTY NINE A. B..
THIRTY ONE FORTY THREE OPERATE
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE FORTY
THREE BY SOME IN MY FELLOW AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY GET TAX
REPAIRS.
MR LOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS IS AB
THIRTY ONE FORTY THREE THE
CALIFORNIA TAX EDUCATION.
COUNCIL SENDS A BILL
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER LOWE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THEM.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE IS OUT OF OF
CLERK WILL [inaudible]
CLOSE.
ZERO AND TELL THE VOTE.
I SIXTY TWO KNOWS ONE SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
ARE CONCURRENT IN [inaudible]
MR.
LOW YOU ARE UP AGAIN THIS IS
FILE ITEM.
THIRTY AB THIRTY ONE FORTY FOUR
COOPERATE ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
ONE FORTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LOW AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS.
MR LOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
THIS WEEK REMEMBERS AGAIN THIS
IS AN ADDITIONAL SUNSET BILL.
WHICH EXTENDS THE PROFESSIONAL
FOR THIS YEAR'S BUREAU FOR FOUR
YEARS RESPECT THAT'S RIGHT VOTE.
SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OVER THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
IS ARE OF THAT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF CLARK
WELL.
CLOSER ROLE THAILAND I SIXTY
THREE NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT AND THIS IS FILE ITEM.
THIRTY ONE AB.
SEVEN SIXTEEN A CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN SIXTEEN BY
SOME A MEMBER O'DONNELL ENACT
WILLING TO PUBLIC ELEMENTARY AND
SECONDARY SCHOOLS.
MISTER O'DONNELL.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB SEVEN
SIXTEEN UPDATES STATE LAW AS IT
RELATES TO THE DEVELOPMENT OF
SINGLE PLANS FOR STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT IN ORDER TO ALIGN.
WITH FEDERAL LAW AND THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
THIS BILL IS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES IN HAS NO OPPOSITION AYE
ASPIRIN AYE VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
THE COURT WELL OPEN AROUND.
ON MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN PASS RETAIN A
FILE ITEM.
THIRTY TWO FILE ITEM THIRTY
THREE IS AB THREE FIFTY FOUR THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FIFTY FOUR
BY SOME A MEMBER CALDERON AND
ACTUALLY THE HOUSING INVESTORS
[inaudible]
MISTER CALDERON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
THIRTY ISSUES ME THREE FIFTY
FOUR WILL HELP US TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND STAND THE SCOPE.
AND EFFECTS OF CORPORATE
INVESTING IN SINGLE FAMILY HOMES.
AND CALIFORNIA SENATE AMENDMENTS
MORE CLEARLY DEFINE WHAT AN
INSTITUTIONAL INVESTOR IS
BASICALLY NOT YOUR REGULAR FLIP
FLOP --
INDIVIDUAL I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ON THE VERSE
VOTERS OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE TIE VOTE AYE AYES
FORTY FIVE NO.
SEVENTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM THIRTY FOURS AB
[inaudible]
TEN EIGHTY COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILLTEN EIGHTY BY SOME
REMEMBER GONZALEZ FLETCHER AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC CONTRACTS.
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER TEN EIGHTY IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS
WERE TAKING THE SENATE TO TRY
AND DRESS THE CONCERNS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION.
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT BOTH HOUSES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CARPOOL OVER THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS
BETTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
WORK WELL.
CLOSE A ROLL TIDE THAT ICE.
FIFTY ONE NO IS THIRTEEN SAID
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT
IMPASSE RETAIN A FILE ON THIRTY
SIX IT FILE ITEM THIRTY SEVEN IS
AB [inaudible]
SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE A CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN FIFTY
ONE BY SOME THE MEMBER LOW AND
ACTUALLY CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES.
MR LOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB --
SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE IS THE
INTERSTATE PRESCRIPTION DATABASE
SHARING RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE.
SEEN NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN.
ON MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND HOW YOU VOTE AYE
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT IN
FILE ITEM THIRTY IS AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY THREE CORKERY.
AS UNABLE SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE
BY SOME A MEMBER LOW AND
ACTUALLY TO CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES.
MISTER LOVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTAKEN [inaudible]
TROLL.
BILL TO ADDRESS THE OKAY CRISIS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ADAM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROAD.
RUNS OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AND VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN
.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
THIRTY NINE AB EIGHTEEN OF FOR
THE COOPERATE ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN OH FOR BY FAMILY MEMBER
BERMAN AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
DO ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
[inaudible]
MISTER BERMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES COUNTIES MUST BE A
PART OF A HOUSING EQUATION IN AB
EIGHTEEN OH FOUR WOULD
EFFECTIVELY EXTEND AN EXISTING
INFILL EXEMPTION. FOR CITIES TO
URBANIZED AREAS AND COUNTIES
BOTH THE LIMITATION THAT IT
APPLIES ONLY TO RESIDENTIAL AND
MIXED USE HOUSING PROJECTS
SENATE AMENDMENTS AT A SUNSET
DATE AND FURTHER LIMITATIONS
WHICH STRIKE A CAREFUL BALANCE
OF PROMOTING INFILL HOUSING
PROJECTS.
WITH ADVERSELY IMPACTING THE
ENVIRONMENT AB EIGHTEEN OH FOUR
HAS RECEIVED NARY A NO VOTE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON CONCURRENT AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
COR CLUB THERE ALL ON THE HE'S
OUT VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
YOU IS OUT OF THOSE THE CLERK
WELL CLOSER ROLE ANTI ABOUT AYE
[inaudible]
SIXTY NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM FORTY IS
AB DAY TITO SIX THE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN OF SIX BY
SOME A MEMBER IRWIN AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY TO INFORMATION
PRIVACY.
MISSOURI.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
AB NINETEEN OH SIX IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE IS THE PAN AND BILL
TO SB.
THREE TWENTY SEVEN WHICH PASSED
THE ASSEMBLY ON TUESDAY WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
THE BILL ON TUESDAY.
HAVE IDENTICAL LANGUAGE AND BOTH
MUST BE PASSED TO CREATE
REASONABLE SECURITY FOR THE
INTERNET OF THINGS DEVICES SUCH
AS SMART THERMOSTATS SMART DOOR
LOCKS AND SMART TOYS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER ONE SCENE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE.
THESE ARE THAT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS I'VE OF ALL MEMBERS
HEADED IS THERE TO VOTE.
CLERK WELL.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF THE
CLOSE ROLE TALLY THOSE EYES
FORTY SIX KNOWS.
ELEVEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS I'M GOING TO LIFT THE
CALL.
ON FILE ITEM TWO A ONE THIS IS
FILE ITEM TOOL ONE S. B..
THIRTEEN HUNDRED THE CLERK WILL
READ.
PARMI THE CARPAL POSTS.
WELL MEMBERS HER WISH TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED WHICH TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. TO DESIRE TO
VOTE
[inaudible]
MS FREE REPLACES THE CALL.
AND NOW MEMBERS ARE GOING TO
LIVE THE CALL ON FILE ITEM
TWENTY ONE A. B.. TWENTY ONE
THIRTY EIGHT CARPOOL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHAT IS THAT ABOUT THE CLERK
WELL?
CLOSER ROLE.
AND TALLY THOUGH.
AYE AYES FORTY FIVE KNOWS.
TWENTY SIX THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS BACK IN FILE ORDER.
FILE ITEM.
FORTY ONE AB NINETEEN FIFTY SIX
BY MS LEMOND [inaudible]
CLARK.
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN FIFTY SIX
BY FAMILY MEMBER LIMON ACTUALLY
THE FIRE PREVENTION.
MISSILE MONTH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
NINETEEN FIFTY SIX IS BACK ON
CONCURRENT THINK CREATES A
ROBUST YEAR ROUND FIRE
PREVENTION LOCAL ASSISTANT GRANT
PROGRAM.
AND DIRECTS THE DIRECTS
CALIFORNIA TO INCREASE THE SCALE
AND PACE A FIRE PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES TO ENSURE THOSE
ACTIVITIES HAPPEN YEAR ROUND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTES.
THANK YOU MISS AMONG SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE RIGHT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
ROSARIO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IS THERE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLLING TIE THAT I SIXTY
SIX NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRENT.
WELL I'M FORTY TWO IS AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN SEVENTY
SIX BY SOME A MEMBER LIMON AND
OTHERS AND ACTION TO IMPLEMENT.
THIS WOMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER A. B.
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX REQUIRES AN
EMPLOYEE TO MAKE A REASONABLE
EFFORT TO PROVIDE A SPACE FOR
WOMEN'S TO EXPRESS NOT IN THE
WORKPLACE THAT IS NOT  BATHROOM.
SENATE AMENDMENTS CLARIFY THE
TEMPORARY SPACES ARE PERMITTED
ESTABLISHES.
ITSELF WHICH IS A PROCESS FOR
AGRICULTURE EMPLOYERS TO COMPLY
AND ESTABLISHES A HARDSHIP
HARDSHIP EXEMPTION [inaudible]
TO PROCESS.
THANK YOU KNOW RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THEY WAS OF A MISTER GABRIEL.
JUST WANTED TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM TOLEDO FOR
BRINGING THIS GREAT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
URGE AN AYE VOTE IT'S A GREAT
WAY TO SUPPORT WORKING WOMEN. TO
GREAT WAY TO SUPPORT FAMILIES
WITH -- WITH
YOUNG CHILDREN I HOPE NEVER WILL
SUPPORT IT.
THANK YOU MISS GABRIEL SAYING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
RESIGNED A VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE VOTE
I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM FORTY THREE IS AB
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX THE
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX BY SOME A MEMBER
CUNNINGHAM AND ACTUALLY
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES.
MISTER CUNNINGHAM.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX IS A
SIMPLE BILL THAT WILL PERMIT
CRAFT DISTILLERS. TO ALLOW
DONATIONS TO NON PROFITS SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND BOTTOMS UP.
THANK YOU MISTER CUNNINGHAM.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE FLOOR.
PERTAINING TO THIS BILL CLERK
WILL READ.
CARPOOL OVER THE ROLE
[inaudible]
SOMETHING.
ALL MEMBERS REYES THEIR VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS ARE RESERVE OF ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THEM.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLE.
TELL ME ABOUT I SIXTY FIVE KNOWS.
ZERO SENATE MEMBERS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM FORTY FOURS AB TWENTY
SEVENTY NINE CORKERY ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY SEVENTY NINE BY SOME
A MEMBER GONZALEZ FLETCHER AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
EMPLOYMENT.
THIS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
AB TWENTY SEVEN I IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THE AMENDMENTS
TAKING THE SENATE WERE CLARIFIED
IN NATURE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTERS THEIR VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY
FOUR KNOWS EIGHTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WHILE ITEM FORTY FIVE IS AB.
TWENTY ONE SIXTY EIGHT SEPARATE
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE SIXTY
EIGHT BY SOME A MEMBER THURMOND
AND ACTUALLY THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION [inaudible]
MR THURMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ARE RISE TO PRESENT AB.
TWENTY ONE SIXTY EIGHT THE BILL
TO SUPPORT SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHERS RECOGNIZING THAT WE
HAVE A SHORTAGE IN THE INTENSITY
OF THE WORK.
THIS BILL CREATES A MENTORSHIP
PROGRAM MENTORSHIP IS PROVEN TO
HELP SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHER
STAND A PROFESSION LONGER AND
BECOME BETTER EDUCATORS THAT
STRENGTHENING THE OUTCOMES FOR
STUDENTS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THEY MISS THURMOND SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
IS THERE A VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE.
NO DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL.
TIE VOTE I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO
SAN AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT.
FILE ITEM FORTY SIX IS AB.
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY EIGHT CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMON
AND ACTUALLY THE CALIFORNIA
RETAIL FOOD CODE [inaudible]
MS AMONG.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
IS BACK ON CONCURRENT THE GOAL
OF THE BILL IS TO GIVE LOCAL
CHARITABLE FOOD DONORS AND
REGULATORS.
FLEXIBILITY IN THE LAW TO ALLOW
FOR MORE FOOD TO BE DONATED AND
SAFELY.
AND SERVICE SAFELY THIS BILL HAS
RISK WHERE THROUGHOUT THE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS EMMA.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ADEQUATE LIBERAL.
ON THE OTHER SIDE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIE THAT I SIXTY TWO
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT.
FILE ITEM.
FORTY SEVEN IS AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY THE CORPORATE ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY ONE NINETY BY SOME
THE MEMBER REYES AND OTHERS IN
ATLANTA HOSPITALS.
MS RACE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AB TWENTY ONE NINETY IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS WERE
TAKEN OF THE SENATE THAT AND
PROVE ENFORCEMENT COMPLIANCE
WITH BENCHMARKS.
OVER 90% OF HOSPITALS IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE ALREADY MET.
TWENTY TWENTY SEISMIC
REQUIREMENTS.
AB TWENTY ONE NINETY ADDRESSES
DELAYS EXPERIENCED BY THE
REMAINING FEW HOSPITALS IN ORDER
TO KEEP THEM FROM CLOSING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
NAME ADDRESS SEEN NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
PARK WILL OVER THE RIGHT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
QUIRK WELL CLOSE ROLE TIE THAT I
SIXTY NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT AB TWENTY
TWO TWENTY ONE FOR COREY
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO TWENTY
ONE BY SOME A MEMBER BLOOM AND
ACTUALLY THE HEALING ARTS
[inaudible]
SURE BLOW.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
THIS BILL UPDATES THE
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY PRACTICE
ACT AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE
INCORPORATE INTO PUT FROM THE
BOARD OF PSYCHOLOGY.
AND THE BOARD OF OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPISTS AND MEMBERS.
MANY OF YOU KNOW THAT I'M
MARRIED TO AN OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY SO ON AN OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPIST SO.
I'M ASKING IT NO I'M BEGGING YOU
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
SO THAT WHEN I GO HOME AT THE
END OF SESSION IN THE LOCKS ON
THE DOORS WILL BE CHANGED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOW.
NOT GOING TO TOUCH OUR SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN ROLL-ON [inaudible]
XANDER VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLL TIDE
BUT I SIXTY NO ZERO THE SENATE.
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS PREPARED LIFT THE CALL
ON FILE ITEM ONE FORTY EIGHT
THAT'S S. B.. TO NINETY EIGHT
DOCTOR WEBER.
CLERK WILL READ [inaudible]
PLUS.
WELL MEMBER SAID WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHICH ABOUT
.
DOCTOR OR WEBER.
DOCTOR WEBER REPLACES A CALL.
IN FILE ORDER THIS IS FILE ITEM.
FORTY NINE AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
TWO BY DR QUIRK CORKERY.
AT SOME LEVEL TWENTY TWO TWENTY
TWO BY SOME A MEMBER QUIRK AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO CRIME
PREVENTION AND INVESTIGATION
[inaudible]
DOCTOR QUIRK.
THANK YOU SPEAKER.
AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO
STRENGTHENS LAW ENFORCEMENT'S
ABILITY. TO TRACE FIREARMS ARE
USED IN CRIMES SENATE AMENDMENTS
RESOLVE CHAPTER IN CONFLICTS.
WITH SENATOR PORTANTINO'S SP
SEVEN FOUR SIX I ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK DUCTWORK SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLUB WILL OPEN THE RIGHT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHICH VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO WISH TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHICH TO VOTE
CLERK WILL CLOSE WRONG TIME BUT
I SIXTY NINE NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT.
THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY AB.
TWENTY TWO FIFTY EIGHT CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO FIFTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CABALLERO AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
THIS COMING YEAR THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTY EIGHT WHICH IS BACKED. FOR
CONCURRENCE IN SENATE AMENDMENTS
ON THAT REMOVED THAT WERE
TECHNICAL IN NATURE AND REMOVED
ALL OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS CABALLERO.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
LETTERS OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AND ABOUT THE
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE ANTI THAT ICE FORTY
SIX KNOWS.
FIFTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS OR
CONCURRENT AND FILE ITEM FIFTY
ONE IS AB TWENTY THREE FIFTEEN
COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
FIFTEEN BY SOME A MEMBER QUIRK
SILVA AND ACTUALLY THE PEOPLE
HEALTH.
MS QUIRK SILVA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY THREE FIFTEEN
IS BACK FROM SENATE FOR
CONCURRENT SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
TECHNICAL IN NATURE AND THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS QUIRK SILVA.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLICK LOGO.
ON THE IT IS THERE THAT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
QUIRK WELL CLOSE ROLE.
TELL YOU LOVE I SIXTY TWO NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT.
THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY TWO AB.
TWENTY THREE FORTY EIGHT CORKERY.
AT SOME LEVEL TWENTY THREE FORTY
EIGHT BY SOME.
WE ARE CURRY AND ACT LIKE
WILDLIFE MS AGUIAR-CURRY GOOD
AFTERNOON A MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER.
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY EIGHT WELL
HEALTH HELP OFFSET THE COST OF
RICE A FOR RICE FARMERS TO
WINTER FLOOD THEIR FIELDS.
FLOODING RICE FIELDS HELPS TO
DECOMPOSE RICE STRAW BETWEEN
GROWING SEASONS AND ALSO
PROVIDES CRITICAL WETLAND
HABITAT FOR ROUGHLY SIX MILLION
BIRDS IN CALIFORNIA.
AFTER WORKING WITH
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE US
MILITARY I HAVE AMENDED THE BILL
TO REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE. TO CONSULT
WITH MILITARY BASES AND LARGE
AIRPORTS BEFORE GRANTING
AWARDING GRANTS FOR NEARBY
AIRFIELD RUNWAYS THIS AMENDMENT
IS INTENDED TO REDUCE THE
PROBABILITY OF BIRD STRIKES.
THE CAN DAMAGE PROPERTY IN
THREATEN HUMAN LIFE THIS BILL
HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THEY VISALIA CURRY.
A CUNNINGHAM WASN'T EVEN AS DESK
TO REPLY.
THAT'S WHAT I SAID.
BUT I THINK.
SORRY SIR GEORGE.
I MET MR GALLAGHER.
PAGING MS FRIEDMAN.
PAGE YOU MISS FRIEDMAN I NEED A
BREAK.
CLARK WELL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
UNDERSTOOD HIS THURMOND.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESERT OF ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ADAMANT
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE LOVE I
SIXTY FOUR NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN [inaudible]
THIS IS.
FILE ITEM FIFTY THREE AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY BY SOME A MEMBER HOLDEN
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO LEAD
EXPOSURE.
MISTER HOLDEN.
FIGURE SPEAKER --
AB TWENTY THREE SEVEN IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY REQUIRED DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD. TO ADOPT
REQUIREMENTS TO ENSURE THAT
CHILD CARE CENTERS DRINKING
WATER IS LEAD SAFE.
THIS BILL HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISS HOLDEN SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK WILL.
OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS ARE TO VOTE FOR WELL.
CLOSE ZERO TIVA I SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN
MEMBERS WE DON'T
USUALLY DO GUESTS INTO
INTRODUCTIONS.
TOWARDS THE END OF SESSION BUT
WE HAVE A VERY SPECIAL GROUP OF
VISITORS HERE WITH US TODAY.
I AM VERY HONORED TO BE ABLE TO
INTRODUCE TO YOU.
SEVERAL MEMBERS OF THE CONSUL
GENERAL'S OFFICE FOR MEXICO FROM
ACROSS THE STATE.
WE HAVE LILIANA PEREIRA CONSUL
GENERAL OF MEXICO IN SACRAMENTO.
WE HAVEN'T GUILLERMO REYES.
THE CONSUL GENERAL OF MEXICO IN
SAN FRANCISCO.
ANA CARMEN A SORRY.
YOU ARE ON A DEL CARMEN BUT AS
WELL LOW CONSUL GENERAL OF EL
SALVADOR FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
AND PATRICIA LEVINE LEVIN INYO
CONSUL GENERAL OF GUATEMALA FROM
SAN FRANCISCO IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBERS WITH US HERE TODAY
WELCOME TO ALL OF YOU
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK. TO
THE BUSINESS AT HAND.
WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM FIFTY FOUR
A. B..
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY ONE THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY ONE BY SOME
REMEMBER CARILLO AND ACTUALLY
THE VEHICULAR AIR POLLUTION.
THANK YOU A SUMMER MACARIO
DIRECTING US YOU MADAM SPEAKER --
I'M HERE 2% AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY ONE WHICH IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THIS BILL HELPS THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
IN THE FIGHT AGAINST THE VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGY DESIGNED. TO EVADE
CALIFORNIA.
CLEAN AIR LOS AN AMENDMENTS --
REVISE THE FUNDS MENTION IN THE
BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK.
MATT PURPOSE OPEN.
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE IS HIRED TO
VOTE
.
MYTH METAL PERKY MAY CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY THREE NO.
TWELVE THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCORD IN.
WE'RE MOVING NOW TO ITEM FIFTY
FIVE AB TWENTY THREE NINETY FIVE
MODEL QUICKLY.
THREE EXCELLENT BOOKS MONEY
THREE NINETY FIVE BY SEVEN
NUMBER CALDERON ACTUALLY TO
ENSURE ITS THANK YOU A SUMMER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THIS
BILL IS ABOUT PREVENTION AND
PREPAREDNESS IN THE LONG TERM
CARE INSURANCE MARKET.
THE BILL ADDS GUARD GUARD RAILS
INTO STATUE TO PREVENT
INSOLVENCY IS IN THE INDUSTRY
AND MAKE SURE THAT POLICY
HOLDERS AREN'T LEFT WITHOUT
COVERAGE IF ONE OF THESE
COMPANIES CAN NO LONGER SUSTAIN
ITSELF.
SENATE MEMBERS WERE TECHNICAL
AND CLARIFYING MEMBERS THIS IS
ABOUT LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE
WHICH EVERYBODY IN THIS ROOM
SHOULD CARE ABOUT AND WE DO CARE
ABOUT THIS BILL HASN'T RECEIVED
ANY NO VOTES HAS BEEN VERY MUCH
A BI PARTISAN EFFORT I REALLY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIGHT.
THANK YOU A SET A SOME OVER
VOEPEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MADAM SPEAKER A NON MEMBERS JUST
A POINT OF INFORMATION OF THIS
BILL IS SPOT ON I SPENT THIRTY
NINE YEARS IN THE INSURANCE
BUSINESS RAILING AGAINST THE
GUARANTEED FUND BEING UNDER
FUNDED AND THEY NEVER.
EVER.
ACTUAR EARLY CHECK IT THIS IS A
WONDERFUL BILL THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU I ASSUME THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA WOLD LIKE THAT TO
BE AS CLOSE.
WITHOUT ADEQUATE PLEASE OPEN THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
HOW MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE?
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING THE VOTES AYE SIXTY ONE
NO.
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCORDANT.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM.
FIFTY SIX AB.
TWENTY FIVE ELEVEN THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIVE ELEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHAO AND ACTUALLY TO BUSINESS
THANK YOU SO MEMBER CHAO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY FIVE ELEVEN WOULD
REQUIRE RETAILERS TO TAKE
REASONABLE STEPS TO ENSURE THE
PURCHASERS OF CERTAIN PRODUCTS
ARE OF LEGAL AGE.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
ESSENTIALLY IMPLEMENT THE
AGREEMENT THAT WAS NEGOTIATED
WHEN THE BILL WAS ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
BACK IN MAY.
THE BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MADAM CORPUS OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS BOWED DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
HE IS TIRED OF VOTE.
MEADOW PARK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TELLING THE VOTES ICE
FIFTY FIVE NO SEVEN THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCORD AND
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM
FIFTY SEVEN AB TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY FOUR THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
FOUR BY SOME A MEMBER WOULD
ACTUALLY TO THE CALIFORNIA OPEN
CODE THINK YOU SOME MEMBER WOULD
MAKE A BETTER SPEAKER AB TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY FOUR IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE FROM SENATE AFTER
CHAPTER IN OUT AMENDMENTS THE
BILL'S ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK.
THAT PARK WAS OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUR DESIRE TO VOTE.
BUT A PARK YOU MAY HAVE CLOSE
THE ROLE ANTI THE VOTES I SIXTY
NO ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE ARE MOVING NOW TO ITEM FIFTY
EIGHT AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
THREE BOTTOM QUICKLY STREET.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
THREE BY SOME THE MEMBER MARK
STONE ACTUALLY TO INMATES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
SENATE AMENDMENTS REDUCE COSTS
SIGNIFICANTLY BY REMOVING COPAYS
FROM CONSIDERATION THE OPERATION
THE BILL IASK FOR CONCURRENT
SINCE AND AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES FORTY
SEVEN NO.
TWELVE THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCORDANT.
WE ARE ON ITEM FIFTY NINE AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY NINE METAPHOR
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX TWENTY
NINE BY SOME THE MEMBER EIGHT
MEN AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
TRANSPORTATION [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EGGMAN.
I THINK YOU MANAGE SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY
NINE IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
HAVING TO DO WITH LEASING SPACE
UNDER CALTRANS PROPERTY FOR
SOCIAL SERVICE AGENCIES.
I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MADAM QUICKLY IS OPEN.
ON MEMBERS VOTE.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTES EYES SIXTY TWO
KNOWS HERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRENT IN.
WE ARE ON ITEM SIXTY AB TWENTY
SIX FORTY THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX FORTY
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD AND
ACTUALLY THE FISH AND WILDLIFE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AB TWENTY SIX
FORTY IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
AFTER SENATE AMENDMENTS THE BILL
HAS NO OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
I SEE NO REQUEST TO SPEAK.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR OWN --
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTES ICE FORTY NINE
NO TWELVE THE SENATE NOT SORRY
NO FOURTEEN THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM SIXTY ONE AB
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY NINE ABOUT A
QUICKLY STREET.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX SEVENTY
NINE ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL
AND ACTUALLY THE HEALTH
FACILITIES THING.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB TWENTY SIX SEVENTY
NINE MODERNIZES CALIFORNIA
STANDARDS FOR PROCESSING MEDICAL
LINEN.
SENATE AMENDMENTS RECAST THE
BILL TO PACE CALIFORNIA
STANDARDS FOR PROCESSING MEDICAL
LIMIT ON GUIDELINES ISSUED BY
THE CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL
AND THE CENTERS THE CENTERS FOR
MEDICARE AND MEDICAID SERVICES.
IT'S BILLS RECEIVE NO NO VOTES
LAST FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK ON WOMEN BENEFIT PLEASE
OPEN AROUND.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
LOOK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE ANTI
THE VOTES AYE SIXTY ONE KNOWS.
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT IN.
WE ARE ON ITEM SIXTY TWO AB
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY TWO THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MEDINA AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
PEOPLE INSTRUCTION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA.
I'M SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN AND SENATE FOR
AB.
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY TWO WILL
PROVIDE HIGH SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA THE OPTION. TO APPLY
FOR GRANT PROGRAM THAT WOULD
ALLOW THEM TO OFFER.
AN ETHNIC STUDIES CLASS IN THEIR
SCHOOLS.
BILL HAS BEEN RECENTLY NARROW.
TWO OFFER AN OPT IN PILOT
PROGRAM.
IT'S BILL WOULD HAVE FOR ELEVEN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADD A COURSE
IN ETHNIC STUDIES.
BASED ON THE MODEL CURRICULUM TO
THEIR HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION
REQUIREMENTS.
AB.
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY TWO WOULD
ALSO ACQUIRE REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
PROVIDE RESOURCES AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. TO PARTICIPATING
DISTRICTS.
WHO REPORT THE BEST PRACTICES TO
THE LEGISLATURE BY?
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR THE GOAL OF
A. B..
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY TWO IS TO
ALLOW ALL STUDENTS TO GAIN
KNOWLEDGE OF ONE'S HISTORY.
AND COMMUNITY.
WHILE ALSO HELPING STUDENTS TO
FEEL MORE CONNECTED.
AND EMPOWERED BY THE CURRICULUM.
AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN TO EXEMPT
GRADUATING HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS.
IN THE YEAR.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TRANSFER
STUDENTS DURING THEIR LAST YEAR
OF HIGH SCHOOL.
AS AMENDED THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION.
AND IS SUPPORTED BY THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC.
DESTRUCTION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU A SUMMER
EVER CHOI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I RISE SO
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS A MEASURE.
AB OUT TO A SEVEN SEVEN TWO OF
FOUR PILOTING [inaudible]
ETHNIC STUDIES.
THE HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL.
A WE LIVE IN NOW OUR GLOBAL AGE.
AND WE CALL OR THE UNITED STATES
HAS TO MET TING PARKED.
ALL DIFFERENT ETHNIC GROUPS.
I HAVE GATHERED.
WITH THE UNITED STATES AND THE
WE MAKE OUR ONE COUNTRY.
THERE ARE SO MANY DIFFERENT NAM.
CULTURES AND LANGUAGES IN THE
BACKGROUND AND DIFFERENT
HISTORIES.
BUT HOW MUCH WE DON'T KNOW.
THE DIFFERENCES AND THE CULTURES.
OF JUST OUR DIFFERENT CULTURE.
IT IS JUST SO AMAZING.
AS A PERSON WHO.
WE AS AN IMMIGRANT HIM MYSELF.
I WOULD LIKE TO INCREASE.
ALSO THE KNOWLEDGE [inaudible]
OF OUR WELL I ASIAN [inaudible]
STUDIES.
AMONG THE A STUDENTS SO THIS OUR
ETHNIC STUDIES ARE IN ONLY.
EIGHT ALL WOULD BE OUR GREAT AYE
IDEA [inaudible]
SO THAT.
JUST YOUNG STUDENTS WILL
UNDERSTAND.
IDEAS CAN BE ERASED [inaudible]
AND ARE.
WHAT WE COMMONLY SEE IS TEST
SCORE BOARDING [inaudible]
ALSO.
BEGIN SELF FROM THE PREJUDICE
AND THE BIAS IS SO BY NOT
UNDERSTANDING.
A DIFFERENT [inaudible]
PEOPLE.
FROM THE STRIP BAR AND THE
LANGUAGE.
AND THAT THERE.
OUR REGION OF THE COUNTRY SO I
THINK WHAT THIS ETHNIC STUDIES
SAW.
WE'RE DEFINITELY CONTRIBUTE TO
ELIMINATE THE THE PROBLEM SAID
THAT WE SEE AMONG YOUNG
[inaudible]
STUDENTS.
AND A HIGH SCHOOLER [inaudible]
MAYBE I A GOOD PLACE TO BEGIN IF
NOT EARLIER.
SO I STRONGLY URGE YOU ARE AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
YES MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
I'D TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
AS A PROUD COAL AUTHOR OF OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY TWO I WANT
TO THANK OF THE AUTHOR THE OTHER
AUTHORS.
OF OF FROM MISTER ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS WHO THAT HELP TO
BASICALLY FASHION THIS INTO
NEGOTIATED.
CLEARLY IDEAL SITUATION WOULD
HAVE BEEN TO HAVE A AS WE BEGIN
THE PROCESS TO HAVE IT REQUIRED.
STUDENTS TO HAVE TO TAKE THIS
BUT IMPLEMENTING A CURRICULUM
LIKE THIS THAT IS --
THAT REQUIRE SPECIFIC KNOWLEDGE
IN AND TRAINING THAT MAY NOT
EXIST RIGHT NOW AT A UNIVERSITY
FOR TEACHER PREPARATION PROGRAMS
UP MAKES IT DIFFICULT AND SOLD
TO BEGIN WITH THE PILOT PROGRAM.
IS REALLY THE FIRST STEP WE'VE
OFTEN SAID ON THIS FLOOR HERE
THAT ARGH ULTIMATE GOAL IS TO
BASICALLY CREATE AT SOME POINT A
CURRICULUM FOR STUDENTS.
WERE ALL INFORMATION IS
AVAILABLE FIRST STEP TO GET US
ALL TO THAT TO THAT POINT SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I BOTH
THE TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY TWO
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT IT FOR EVER
ON THIS FLOOR ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF IT DONE THE
VARIOUS ETHNIC.
A MONTHS INTO OF WHAT IS BLACK
HISTORY MONTH A CHICANO MUCH
HISTORY MONTH AND NOW IS OUR
TIME TO TRY TO BEGIN TO
IMPLEMENT AND TAKE THE FIRST
BABY STEPS TO MOVE FORWARD.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE FOR AB.
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY TWO THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU BUT LIKE TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FROM US AND DIEGO AND
ORANGE COUNTY.
BUT YESTERDAY WAS THE
ANNIVERSARY OF THE DEATH.
OF RUBEN SALAZAR IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO.
FOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MCCORKLE OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
HOW MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES.
EYES FIFTY THREE NO FIVE THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN MOVING TO ITEM SIXTY THREE AB
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY FIVE META
QUICKLY STREET.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
FIVE BY SOME THE MEMBER BONTA
AND ACTUALLY THE PARDONS THANK
YOU SO MEMBER BONTA YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
FIVE IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE IT
ESTABLISHES A ONE YEAR TIME LINE
FOR THE BOARD OF PAROLE.
HEARINGS TO ISSUE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON PARDON
APPLICATIONS AND REQUIRES THE
BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS TO
NOTIFY APPLICANTS WHEN THEY
RECEIVE AN APPLICATION AND WHEN
THEY HAVE ISSUED.
A RECOMMENDATION AMENDMENTS IN
THE SENATE.
I REMOVED THE CREATION OF A
PARDON AND COMMUTATION PANEL
WITHIN THE BOARD OF PAROLE
HEARINGS OF THE BILL.
IS AN API LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS
PRIORITY HAS A STRONG COALITION
OF TWENTY PLUS SUPPORTERS AND NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU IT'S YOU KNOW REQUEST
TO SPEAK MEDICAL PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM SIXTY FOUR
AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY METAPHOR
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO AND ACT.
UTILITIES ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I'M PRESENTING AB
TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY WHICH IS BACK
FROM OUR FOR CONCURRENCE.
A BILL WHICH WOULD AUTHORIZE THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
APPROVE THE REQUIRED SIXTY HOURS
OF CLASSROOM TRAINING. FOR
CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANTS TO
BE OFFERED THROUGH ONLINE OR
DISTANCE LEARNING CLASSES.
SENATE AMENDMENTS INCORPORATED
INPUT FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH.
CALIFORNIA SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES ARE FACING A
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND THIS
BILL WILL HELP ADDRESS
CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE SHORTAGE
BY MODERNIZING THE CLASSROOM
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS TO BECOME
A CNA.
AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD IN
MODERNIZING THE PROCESS.
COME A CERTIFIED NURSING
ASSISTANT.
WITH THAT I THINK YOU AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE MEMBERS DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE
SORRY CLOSER UNTIL AYE DEVOTES
AYE SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN MOVING TO ITEM SIXTY FIVE AB
TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY THREE MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY THREE BY SOME A MEMBER
LOW AND ACTUALLY PERSONAL
VEHICLES YOU'RE THINK YOUR
SUMMER LOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY THREE IS.
FIRST RESPECT TO PERSONAL
VEHICLE SHARING PROGRAMS AND
RECALL SAFETY MEASURES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU I SEE IT NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS BOTH THE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW THE VOTES AYE SIXTY THREE
KNOWS.
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL ON ITEM.
EIGHTEEN AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY
THREE THE CLERK WILL POST.
HOW MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
FORTY ONE IT KNOWS
TWENTY FOUR THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING ON TO ITEM
SIXTY SIX AB TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY SIX MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY SIX BY FAMILY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER AND ACTUALLY
TYPICAL REMOVAL AND IMPOUNDS THE
SUMMER EVER JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY SIX WHICH IS BACK FOR A
CONCURRENT VOTE.
THIS BILL WAS AMENDED IN THE
SENATE TO MORE ACCURATELY MAYOR
EXISTING CASE LAW REGARDING
WEREN'T LET'S [inaudible]
VEHICLE SEIZURE THE BILL HAS
BEEN RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
BOTH THE ASSEMBLY AND SENATE
POLICY COMMITTEE AS WELL AS ON
BOTH THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
AND THE SENATE FLOOR MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE AYE VOTE
ON THIS CONCURRENT VOTE.
SEEING NO REQUEST TO SPEAK.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS BURDENS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
AND TALLY THE VOTES.
I FIFTY FIVE AT NO ONE THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM SIXTY SEVEN
AB TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT
MEDICAL PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY EIGHT PRICE REMEMBER
CHAVEZ AND OTHERS IT ACTUALLY
THE SCHOOL ACCOUNTABILITY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER SCHABAS
YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT IS
BACK TO ASSEMBLY FOR CONCURRENCE.
AT DEALS WITH FAMILY ENGAGEMENT
AS A PARTY THREE DOG PRO FUNDING
I ASK FOR YOUR EYES.
SEEING THE NEVER QUESTION SPEAK
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS NO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
A DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MEDICAL PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND HOW THE VOTES I AS FIFTY
FOUR NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONFERRED IN
.
WE ARE MOVING ON TO ITEM SIXTY
EIGHT AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY
SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE HOUSING THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIRPERSON.
OF AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN
IS BACK FROM THE SENATE WAS
SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS TO NARROW
THE SCOPE OF THE BILL AND
CLARIFY IMPLEMENTATION.
WITH MORE WOMEN OF FARM WORKERS
AND FAMILIES LOOKING FOR SAFE
AND RELIABLE HOUSING WHILE
WORKING IN OUR FIELDS THIS BILL
SERVES TO UPDATE OUR FIFTY YEAR
OLD STATE RUN FARM WORKER
HOUSING PROGRAM. TO GIVE EACH
CENTER GREATER LOCAL DECISION
MAKING POWER.
AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN HAS
NO OPPOSITION AND BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND THANK GOODNESS.
I HAVE A GREAT PERSON ANGELO
WORKING ON THIS I REALLY RESPECT
WHAT SHE'S DONE AND I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MADAM COURT PLEASE OPEN.
MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
I MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
ANTI THE VOTES AYE SIXTY NO.
ZERO ITEM SIXTY NINE PASS
TEMPORARILY MOVING TO ITEM
SEVENTY AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY ONE
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE SIXTY
ONE BY SOMETHING ABOUT O'DONNELL
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
PUBLIC HEALTH.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED I
THINK YOU MEANT SPEAKER I AB
TWENTY NINE SIXTY ONE REQUIRES
LOCAL EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AGENCIES. TO REPORT AMBULANCE
PATIENT OFFLOAD TIME DATA TO THE
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AUTHORITY.
SENATE EARNS CLARIFY HOW LOCALLY
IN S. AGENCIES MUST REPORT THIS
DATA IN ORDER TO ENSURE
CONSISTENCY.
THE CURRENT LAW EXPECTED
ASTRONOMICAL.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY
ONE NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MOVING TO ITEM. SEVENTY ONE AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN OUT OF
HER PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN BY SOME A MEMBER IN THE
MODE AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
EMERGENCY SERVICES.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LIMON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AS AMENDED IN THE SENATE
AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
INCENTIVIZE AS A LEARNING
AUTHORITY SAYS TRANSLATE
EMERGENCY NOTIFICATIONS AND
ESTABLISHES A PROCESS TO MOVE US
FORWARD HAVING EMERGENCY
COMMUNICATIONS.
TRANSLATED INTO THE MOST
COMMONLY SPOKEN LANGUAGE OTHER
THAN ENGLISH.
THE BILL REQUIRES THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES TO CREATE A
LIBRARY OF TRANSLATED EMERGENCY
NOTIFICATIONS THAT MAY BE USED
BY DESIGNATED ALERTING
AUTHORITIES WHEN ISSUING
EMERGENCY NOTIFICATIONS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
HAVEN'T.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK.
MAN PURPOSE OPEN THE MEMBERS
MODE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALTHOUGH THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
I MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE ON
TELLY THE VOTES ICE SIXTY ONE
KNOWS IT ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM SEVENTY
TWO A. B. TWO OH NINE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
AS A LEGAL TWO THOUSAND AND NINE
BY SOME REMEMBER ME CHINA AND
OTHERS AT THAT POINT
INTERSCHOLASTIC ATHLETIC
PROGRAMS SO MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB TWO
THOUSAND NINE IS BACK ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR FOR CONCURRENCE
AFTER TAKING CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE.
THIS WILL PROTECT THE LIVES OF
STUDENT ATHLETES BY ENSURING
THAT TRAINERS HAVE ACCESS TO A
D. UNITS IN THE CASE OF A
MEDICAL EMERGENCY.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST TONIGHT ABOUT.
THANK YOU I SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE THE PURPLE OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MEDFORD PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY
EIGHT KNOWS ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM SEVENTY
THREE AB TWENTY NINETY ONE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINETY ONE
BY SOME A MEMBER GRAYSON AND
ACTUALLY THE FIRE PREVENTION
SOME EVER GRAYSON THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINETY ONE
IS BACK ON FOR CONCURRENCE.
SENATE AMENDMENTS REQUIRE FOR
FORCE MANAGEMENT TASK FORCE TO
COORDINATE WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE TO DEVELOP
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AN INSURANCE
POOL FOR PRESCRIBED BURN
MANAGERS.
THAT REDUCES THE COST OF
CONDUCTING PRESCRIBED FIRE WHILE
MAINTAINING ADEQUATE LIABILITY
PROTECTION FOR LIVES AND
PROPERTY LIABILITY CONCERNS AND
THE COST OF INSURANCE HAVE
CONSISTENTLY BEEN CITED AS
ROADBLOCKS. TO THE USE OF
PRESCRIBED FIRE AB TWENTY NINE
ONE IS MODEST BUT IMPORTANT STEP
IN. FOR FOR ONGOING EFFORT TO
MODERNIZE CALIFORNIA'S APPROACH
TO FOREST MANAGEMENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CORPORAL OPEN THE
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE IS TIRED OF
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY TWO
NOSES ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM SEVENTY FOUR AB
TWENTY ONE TWENTY SIX MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE TWENTY
SIX BY SOME THE MEMBER EGGMAN
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
RESOURCES CONSERVATION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER EGGMAN.
THE CURE MUCH BEEN SPEAKER AB
TWENTY ONE TWENTY SIX IS BACK
FROM THE SENATE FOR CONCURRENCE.
HAVING TO DO WITH CONSTRUCTING
NEW PROGRAMS IN THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS TO DEAL WITH
THE FOREST.
THE SENATE ATTITUDE ADDITIONAL
CREWS TO BE ABLE TO HELP IN OUR
FOREST LANDS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THREE AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE TO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND HOW THE VOTES AYE SIXTY
THREE KNOWS ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM SEVENTY FIVE AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY NINE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
NINE BY SOME A MEMBER WEBER AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE PEOPLE
RIGHTS ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER.
YES MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY NINE THE YOUNG
PEOPLE'S RIGHT TO EDUCATION
ACTORS BACK FOR THE SENATE.
FROM THE SENATE FOR CONCURRENCE
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS A
CLARIFYING IN TECHNICAL IN
NATURE AND INCLUDE LANGUAGE TO
AVOID CHAPTER IN OUT.
THIS BILL LEFT THIS HOUSE WITH
SEVENTY THIS HOUSE THIRTY NINE
IN THE SENATE THERE BEEN NO NO
VOTES SO LET'S NOT SCREWED UP
NOW.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON CONCURRENCE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
META PURPOSE OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE HIS IRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING THE VOTES IT'S NOT
SEVENTY EIGHT BUT IT IS SIXTY
TWO YESES NO KNOWS THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM SEVENTY SIX
AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY EIGHT THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO WATER
QUALITY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I HAVE A
BEEF TWENTY FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
ABA WHICH IS BACK FROM FOR
CONCURRENCE AND HAS RECEIVED IN
ON IT WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
THE ASSEMBLY.
AFTER TAKING AMENDMENTS TO
REMOVE THE PILOT PROJECT
COMPONENT FROM THIS BILL.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD TO
DEVELOP FINANCIAL CAPABILITY
ASSESSMENT GUIDELINES AS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DID IN
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN TO BETTER
ASSIST LOCAL JURISDICTIONS.
ADVANCED STRONG ACOSTA MS FOUR
PERMITS THE CURRENT ESOS COSTS
ARE EXTREMELY HIGH IN MANY OF
OUR CITIES AND WILL CREATE
FINANCIAL INSTABILITY.
BRADBURY IS A CITY IN MY
DISTRICT WHOSE ASSESSED REGIONAL
WATER BOARD PERMIT FEES ARE
ALMOST TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS.
THAT IS ALMOST THIRTY FOUR
THIRTY FOUR I'LL SAY AGAIN
THIRTY FOUR TIMES THEIR ANNUAL
BUDGET.
THE RATIO OF COSTS TO REVENUES
MEANS TAKING OUT BONDS OR LOANS.
BETTER ARE ALSO NOT A
POSSIBILITY FOR THEM.
MEMBERS CITIES AND COUNTIES ARE
IN NEED OF GUIDANCE AND
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE IN ORDER TO
DEVELOP ADEQUATE CONSISTENT AND
COST THEM FORM PERMITS AS
REQUIRED BY LAW.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO DEBATE.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS WROTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE?
HOW MEMBERS THROUGH THE DESIRE
TO VOTE?
MEDICARE PLEASE CLOSER UNTIED
THE VOTES AYE SIXTY TWO NO ZERO
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
PRECLUDED IN.
WE ARE ON ITEM SEVENTY SEVEN AB
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
ONE BY SOME A MEMBER WHAT IT
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO FORESTRY
AND FIRE PREVENTION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD.
THINK ABOUT A SPEAKER AB TWENTY
FIVE FIFTY ONE IS BACK FOR
CONSERVE CURRENTS OF SENATE
AMENDMENTS THE BILL CREATES A
JOINT BURNER PROGRAM WITH CAL
FIRE TO MAKE IT EASIER. FOR THE
DEPARTMENT COLLABORATE WITH
PRIVATE LANDOWNERS ON PROACTIVE
FIRES DOES ENJOY UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO DISCUSSION
MCCORKLE OPEN THE PRO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS PARK RECORD IN.
ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT PASS
TEMPORARILY MOVING TO ITEM
SEVENTY NINE A. B. THIRTY ONE
THIRTY ONE THAT PURPOSE.
THREE ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE
THIRTY ONE BY SOME A MEMBER
GLORIA AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
GET MILITARY EQUIPMENT SOME
NEVER GLORIA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
MEMBERS AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY ONE
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENT WITH
SENATE AMENDMENTS MONDAY
AMENDMENTS TAKEN ON THE SENATE
SIDE ELIMINATION OF THE
REQUIREMENT FOR GOVERNMENT --
BODY APPROVAL ELIMINATION OF THE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION FOR
FAILURE TO COMPLY WITH THE USE
POLICY IN THE BILL.
AYE IT NARROWS THE SCOPE OF THE
BILL IN TERMS OF THE STATE AND
LOCAL AGENCIES --
IN THEIR ABILITY WOULD TO
RESPOND TO NATURAL DISASTERS
THIS BILL HOWEVER CONTINUES TO
HAVE A CHOIR USE POLICY BE IN
PLACE. FOR THE KINDS OF MILITARY
EQUIPMENT WE'VE SEEN IN SOME
COMMUNITIES AND NOW REQUIRES OF
THE POLICY BE SUBJECT TO PUBLIC
COMMENT AT A AT A MEETING OF THE
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES.
BOARD I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MADAME QUICK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
WHY AND WHAT'S THE CALL
.
WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM EIGHTY HE
B. THIRTY ONE THIRTY SEVEN MEDIC
MEDIC HER PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE THIRTY
SEVEN BY SOME THE MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ AND ACTUALLY THE STATE
PROPERTY THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
ARE RICE PRESENT AB THIRTY ONE
THIRTY SEVEN WHICH IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE.
THIS OF THE DISTRICT BILL SENATE
AMENDMENTS ADDRESS A CHAPTER IN
CONFLICT.
RESPECT WE ASK FOR OUR VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MADAME PURPOSE OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND HOW THE VOTES AYE SIXTY FIVE
NO ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM EIGHTY ONE A. B.
TWENTY SIXTY THREE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIXTY THREE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO THE
PROPERTY ASSESSED CLEAN ENERGY
PROGRAM THANK YOU SOME EVER I'VE
YEAR CURRY METAL SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB TWENTY SIXTY THREE IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE.
THIS BILL MAKE CERTAIN THE PRIOR
TO SIGNING A PACE PROGRAM
ASSESSMENT OR HOME IMPROVEMENT
CONTRACT AND BEFORE WORK
ACTUALLY BEGINS.
A HOMEOWNERS ABILITY TO PAY FOR
THE INCREASED TAX ASSESSMENTS
WILL BE CONFIRMED.
THE AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN IN
RESPONSE TO CONCERNS THE PACE
PROVIDERS AND MAKING A CLARIFIER
CLARIFYING CHANGE.
THANK YOU TO MY CONSULTANTS
JIMMY MACDONALD THE DEBBIE
MICHAEL FOR THEIR GREAT WORK ON
THIS VERY TOUGH ISSUE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING THAT NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE MEADOW PARK
WAS OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MY PARK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY
TWO NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE PREPARED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM EIGHTY TWO AB
TWENTY THREE FIFTY EIGHT
METAPHORICALLY STREET ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY THREE FIFTY EIGHT BY
SOME A MEMBER CARILLO AND OTHERS
ACTUALLY TO EMPLOYMENT SOME
MEMBER CARILLO.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AYE PRESENTE BE
TWENTY THREE FIFTY EIGHT WHICH
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCY
AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL IN
NATURE AND THE PASSED THE SENATE
A FLOOR UNANIMOUSLY WITH ZERO NO
VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
QUESTION SPEAK THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY FIVE NOS
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN
.
MEMBERS I'M PREPARED TO LET THE
CALL ON ITEM.
SEVENTY NINE I AB THIRTY ONE
THIRTY ONE THE CLERK WILL POST.
NOT A QUICKLY IS CLOSE THE
RULING TIED THE VOTES.
AYE AYES FORTY ONE IT KNOWS
THIRTY ONE OF THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM EIGHTY
THREE AB.
TWENTY FOUR NINETY THREE META
QUICKLY THREE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FOUR NINETY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM
[inaudible]
INTERESTS LIKE.
I REMEMBER BLOOM.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THIS
BILL IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE AND
WOOD MODERNIZE THE BOTTLE BILL
PROGRAM.
BY REMOVING CERTAIN OPERATIONAL
RESTRICTIONS IN ORDER TO ENABLE
TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATION WITHIN
THE PROGRAM.
AMENDMENTS WERE MADE IN THE
SENATE TO REMOVE.
THE BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN.
A MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
NOW MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLAND
TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY SEVEN
KNOWS ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM EIGHTY FOUR AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTY SEVEN MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX FIFTY
SEVEN BY SOME THE MEMBER WEBER
AND ACTUALLY THE PEOPLE THAT'S
PLAN.
SOME MEMBER WEBER YES --
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTY SEVEN AS BACK
FROM THE SENATE FOR CONCURRENCE
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS MODIFY THE
LANGUAGE PROHIBITING CERTAIN
RESTRAINTS.
REMOVE THE DEBRIS FROM
PROVISIONS AND INTRUDE LANGUAGE
TOOK IS CONSISTENT WITH SPECIAL
EDUCATION LAW.
THERE'S BEEN NO OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL AND IT HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
ON CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO DISCUSSION OF
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES.
I SIXTY FIVE NOSE ONE THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
LIVING TIED OF EIGHTY FIVE AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY EIGHT THE
CORPOREAL.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX NINETY
EIGHT BY SOME A MEMBER RUBIO AND
OTHERS AND ACT LIKE A CHILD CARE
SOME MEMBER RUBIO THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I HAVE AB.
TWENTY SIX NINETY EIGHT WHICH IS
BACK FROM FOR CONCURRENCE --
WHICH IS ALSO A WOMEN'S CAUCUS
PARITY BILL THAT WILL HELP OUR
CHILDREN AND TEACHERS IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM TO BENEFIT FROM EARLY
CHILDHOOD.
CHILDHOOD MENTAL HEALTH
CONSULTATION SENATE AMENDMENTS
INCLUDE JOB DURING OUT LANGUAGE
AND ADDED SEVERAL --
WE ADDED SEVERAL CO AUTHORS
WE'RE SIMPLY AUTHORIZING
PROVIDERS TO UTILIZE EXISTING
SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE FUNDING TO
PROVIDE VALUABLE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
WHICH RESEARCH SHOWS WILL
IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR CHILDREN
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR ABOUT THANK YOU I SEE
NO DISCUSSION MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROWING
TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES SIXTY
FIVE NOSES ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM EIGHTY SIX AB
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY FOUR MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY
AND ACTUALLY TO INSURANCE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY.
COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
FOUR DEALS WITH INSURANCE
PRODUCER AGREEMENTS SENATE
AMENDMENTS CLARIFY IT AND
TIGHTEN THE APPLICATION WAS
PROVISIONS ARE QUESTION I VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO DISCUSSION
METACARPALS OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE ON TELLY DEVOTES EYES
[inaudible]
SIXTY SEVEN KNOWS.
ONE THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCORD IN MOVING TO ITEM EIGHTY
SEVEN AB THREE OH OH TO THE
CLERK WILL READ.
AS ILLEGAL THREE THOUSAND AND
TWO BY SELLING OVER GRAYSON AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY GET
DISABILITY ACCESS THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED HIM OUT OF SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB THREE THOUSAND TWO IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE.
THIS BILL AS A PROACTIVE MEASURE
THAT GETS CRITICAL INFORMATION
ABOUT DISABILITY ACCESS
COMPLIANCE INTO THE HANDS OF
BUSINESS OWNERS BEFORE THEY
START CONSTRUCTION SENATE
AMENDMENTS MADE TECHNICAL
CLARIFICATIONS.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIGHT.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
A DESIRE TO VOTE.
BUT APART PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND HOW THE VOTES AYE SIXTY
THREE KNOWS ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS I I AM PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL ON ITEM SIXTY THREE AB
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY FIVE THE
CLERK WILL POST.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLIED THE VOTES EYES FORTY ONE
KNOWS.
TWENTY SIX THE SENATE MEMBERS
ARE HEARD IN.
WE ARE MOVING NOW TO ITEM.
EIGHTY EIGHT I TO MEDIATE ACR
TWO FIFTY THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT SOLUTION TO
FIFTY BY SOME THEM MEMBER HOLDEN
BOLTED TO THE RAIL CYCLE VICTIMS
OF OIL OVER.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER ACR. TWO
FIFTY WILL HONOR.
THE LIVES OF SIX INDIVIDUALS WHO
LOST THEIR LIVES DURING THE
COLLAPSE OF THE FOOTHILL BRIDGE
BY CHANGING THE NAME.
OF THE NORTH.
ARROYO BOULEVARD OVER CROSSING
TO THE ARROYO SECO VICTIMS
MEMORIAL OVER CROSSING.
THIS BRIDGE WAS BEING BUILT TO
PASS.
THE FOOTHILL FREEWAY OVER THE
ARROYO SECO NEAR ARROYO
BOULEVARD IN ROSEMONT AVENUE IN
THE CITY OF PASADENA.
THERE WOULD BE AN APPROPRIATE
TRIBUTE TO NAME THE OVER
CROSSING IN HONOR OF THE SIX MEN
WHO LOST THEIR LIVES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU I SEEN KNOW REQUEST TO
SPEAK MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE ON
TELLY THE BOATS EYES SIXTY THREE
NO ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
SOME MEMBER HOLDEN I'M SORRY
SOME EVER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
THERE ARE THIRTY OF US ON THIS
FLOOR THAT DO NOT HAVE FLOOR
JOCKEYS IN THE SENATE FOR THEIR
BILLS.
IS THE DAY BEFORE THE LAST DAY
IF YOU ARE ONE OF THE THIRTY
THAT DO NOT HAVE A FLOOR JOCKEY
FOR ONE YEAR BILLS IN THE SENATE.
IT'S NOT BEING TAKING UP AND
THAT ONLY MAKE THINGS MORE
COMPLICATED PLEASE DESIGNATE A
FULL FLOOR JOCKEY FOR THE BILLS
THAT YOU HAVE IN THE SENATE
THANK YOU.
ITEM. EIGHTY NINE PASS
TEMPORARILY WE ARE MOVING TO
ITEM.
NINETY AB TWELVE FORTY EIGHT
MADAM FOR PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE FORTY EIGHT
BY SOME A MEMBER GLORIA AND
ACTUALLY THE PEOPLE'S THANK YOU
AS A MEMBER GLORIA THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AB TWENTY A TWELVE
FORTY EIGHT IS BACK FROM THE
SENATE ON CONCURRENCE.
SENATE MINUTES CLARIFY STUDENT'S
RIGHT TO WEAR CULTURAL
ADORNMENTS OF A RECOGNIZED --
IN TRIBAL RELIGIOUS OR CULTURAL
SIGNIFICANCE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ABOUT HER PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLAND
TALLY THE VOTES.%
I SIXTY KNOWS ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
ITEM NINETY ONE PASS TEMPORARILY
ITEM NINETY TWO AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY ONE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
ONE BY SELLING THEM BLOOM AND
ACT KIND OF HOUSING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THIS
BILL IS BACK FROM THE SENATE
MAKES A NUMBER OF CHANGES TO THE
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ASSESSMENT ALLOCATION PROCESS.
TO ENSURE THAT EVERY
JURISDICTION IS PLAYING A
MEANINGFUL ROLE IN ADDRESSING
THE HOUSING CRISIS.
THE AMENDMENTS ON THE SENATE TO
A NUMBER OF THINGS THEY ENSURE
THAT THE RING A PROCESS OF LINE
WITH STATE CLIMATE GOALS.
CREATE A ROLE FOR THE STATE TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT
WHILE LEAVING THE ULTIMATE
AUTHORITY FOR THE RINA PROCESS
WITH EACH COUNSELOR GOVERNMENT.
ALIGNED ARENA ALLOCATION PROCESS
WITH THE REQUIREMENTS --
THAT ARE IN THE FAIR FEDERAL
FAIR HOUSING ACT.
INCREASED TRANSPARENCY BY
REQUIRING THAT ALL RELEVANT
MATERIALS RELATED TO THE RING
ALLOCATION PROCESS ARC SENSIBLE
ONLINE.
AND ADDRESS A NUMBER OF OTHER
CONCERNS RAISED BY STAKEHOLDERS
THANK YOU I ASK YOUR ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU I SEE NO DEBATE.
THE CLERK MAY OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
A DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES ICE FORTY
ONE A NO TWENTY ONE THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM NINETY THREE AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY FIVE ITEM
QUICKLY STREET ASSEMBLY WILL
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY FIVE BY SOME
REMEMBER WHAT AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO INSURANCE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD.
BE AMENDED SPEAKER I RISE TO
PRESENT EIGHT MAYBE EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE WHICH IS BACK FROM
FOR FOR CONCURRENCE AFTER
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE THIS
BILL SEEKS TO INFORM CONSUMERS
AND PRIDE MORE OPTION FOR
PROPERTY OWNERS.
AND HAS ENJOYED BART BROAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THROUGHOUT
THE PROCESS RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU I SEE NO
REQUEST TO SPEAK MAN QUICKLY SO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
YOU DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY
THREE NOSES ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT IN.
MOVING TO ITEM NINETY FOUR A. B.
NINETEEN THIRTY THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN THIRTY BY
SOME THE MEMBER MARK STONE
NATALIE TO FOSTER CARE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STONE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
THIS IS WHAT'S BECOME AN ANNUAL
CCA IMPLEMENTATION BILL SENATE
AMENDMENTS ADDRESS RESOURCE
FAMILY APPROVALS AND CHAPTER OUT
AMENDMENTS I ASK FOR YOUR
CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
DEBATE THIS ITEM THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHOSE ARE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY NO
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
WE ARE NOW ON ITEM NINETY FIVE
A. B. NINETEEN FORTY FIVE MINUTE
QUICKLY.
THREE ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN
FORTY FIVE BY SOME THE MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO GREENHOUSE GASES
SOME MEMBER GARCIA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES A. B. NINETEEN FORTY
FIVES BACK FROM THE SENATE FOR
CONCURRENCE RESPECTFULLY ASK
ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
MEMBERS VOTE IT IS OUR DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WERE DESIRING TO VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTES.
EYES FIFTY ONE NO ONE THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM NINETY SIX AB
TWENTY ONE OH SEVEN MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE OH
SEVEN BY SOME THE MEMBER RAY AS
AN ACTOR AND A NEW MOTOR
VEHICLES ASSEMBLY MEMBER AREAS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY ONE OH SEVEN
UPDATES THE LAWS GOVERNING THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN AUTOMOBILE
MANUFACTURERS.
AND CALIFORNIA FRANCHISE NEW CAR
DEALERS.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS REFLECT
OVER THIRTY HOURS OF
NEGOTIATIONS WITH MY OFFICE.
AND BETWEEN STAKEHOLDERS.
AMONG THE MANY PROVISIONS THE
BILL EIGHT OF THIS BILL ARE COST
CONTAINMENT PROVISIONS OF
ASSURED THAT THE MOVE TOWARD
RETAIL WARRANTY REIMBURSEMENT
RATES.
OCCUR OVER SEVERAL YEARS.
THIS IS THE BALANCE BILL THAT
CAREFULLY WEIGHS THE INTEREST
BETWEEN LARGE MULTINATIONAL AUTO
MAKERS AND CALIFORNIA'S NEW CAR
DEALERS.
AB TWENTY ONE OH SEVEN WILL
ENSURE THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES
REMAIN COMPETITIVE.
IN AN INCREASINGLY COMPETITIVE
MARKET MARKETPLACE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK METAPHORICALLY SO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLIP WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES.
SIXTY FIVE NO.
ONE THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING TO ITEM
NINETY SEVEN AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY
TWO MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE SIXTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID
CHIU AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
LAND USE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
TO THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY
TWO IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE TO
STREAMLINE THE PRODUCTION.
SUPPORT OF HOUSING IN THE MIDST
OF OUR HOMELESSNESS CRISIS THIS
IS BEEN A PROVEN METHOD FOR
REDUCING HOMELESSNESS THAT IS
ALSO COST EFFECTIVE.
SENATE AMENDMENTS WOULD LIMIT
THE APPLICATION WITH REGARDS TO
SMALLER CITIES AND COUNTIES
REDUCE PERCENTAGE OF UNITS
REQUIRED TO QUALIFY FROM 35225%.
TO ALIGN WITH STATE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROGRAMS AND MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES AT THE REQUEST
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT APPRECIATE
YOUR PRIOR SUPPORT ASK YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AS A MEMBER DALY ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I WANT TO
COMMEND OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO. FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE UNDER THE
CURRENT APPROVAL PROCESS SUPPORT
OF HOUSING PROJECTS IN TAKE UP
TO THREE OR MORE YEARS TO
DEVELOP.
THIS BILL WILL EXPEDITE THE
APPROVAL OF THESE PROJECTS WHICH
MADE A LIST OF REQUIREMENTS.
SITES WHICH ARE ALREADY ZONED
FOR RESIDENTIAL USE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE YOU KNOW FOR THE
REQUEST TO SPEAK MCCORKLE OPEN
THE ROAD.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES.
AYE AYES FORTY FIVE KNOWS TWENTY
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING NOW TO ITEM
NINETY EIGHT AB.
TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY FIFTEEN BY
SOME MEMBER KALRA AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE VETERINARIANS.
AS A MEMBER KALRA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
SOME OF THE MEN MR AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTEEN REMOVED PROVISIONS LATER
ADDING CANNABIS FOR ANIMAL USE
IN THE MEDICINAL AND ADULT USE
CANNABIS REGULATIONS SAFETY ACT.
THE BILL MAINTAINS THE ABILITY
FOR VETERINARIANS TO HAVE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THEIR PATIENT
OWNERS REGARDING CANNABIS USE
ESPECIALLY THOSE DISCUSSIONS ARE
INITIATED BY THE PATIENT OWNER
AND HAS PROVISIONS AGAINST
CONFLICTS OF INTERESTS.
AB TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN HAS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
IS SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
VETERINARY MEDICAL BOARD AND THE
CALIFORNIA VETERINARY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS BUSINESS
GROUPS LIKE THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
AND SOCIAL COMPASSION AND
LEGISLATION COLLEAGUES DO NOT
LET THIS OPPORTUNITY GO UP IN
SMOKE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON SENATE AMENDMENTS.
SEEN NO REQUEST TO SPEAK ON
CANNABIS FOR DOGS LOCAL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS WROTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
WHOSE HARD TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY
TWO TO AYE FIFTY FOUR NO ONE
THIS.
MR CONCURRED IN.
MOVING OUT ITEM NINETY NINE AB
TWENTY TO THIRTY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TO THIRTY
EIGHT BY SUMMING [inaudible]
CURRY AND THE LOCAL HAS
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY.
THANK YOU I'M MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB TWENTY TO THIRTY
EIGHT IS BACK FROM THE SENATE
WITH AMENDMENTS THAT MADE
SEVERAL TECHNICAL CHANGES AND
ADDED CHAPTER IN LANGUAGE.
THIS BILL CAME ABOUT AFTER LAST
FALL'S DEVASTATING FOUGHT WILD
FIRES.
AND MAKES UPDATES TO HOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS PREPARE.
FOR MITIGATE AND ACCOUNT FOR
DISASTERS W. MICHAEL THANKS FOR
THE GREAT JOB ON THIS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
I SEE NO REQUEST TO SPEAK
MEDICAL PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE YOU DESIRE.
TO ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY SIX
NO ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRENT IN.
LIVING OUT TO ITEM ONE HUNDRED
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY THREE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
THREE BY SOME A MEMBER HOLDEN
AND ACTUALLY THE HEALING ARTS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN.
A THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
ASSEMBLY BILL HE HAS BEEN.
AND IN OUR CONCURRENCE THIS BILL
WILL CLARIFY THAT PHYSICAL
THERAPY DIRECT ACCESS LAWS DO
NOT APPLY TO THE SERVICES
PROVIDED. TO IMPROVE STUDENT
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE ACCORDING
TO AN IEP.
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE ONLY
ADDED INTO LANGUAGE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I SEE NO
REQUEST TO SPEAK THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLL.
CALL MEMBERS BONE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTES EYES SIXTY SEVEN
KNOWS ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM ONE NO ONE AB
TWENTY FOUR FORTY SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR FORTY
SEVEN BY SOME THE MEMBER REYES
AND OTHERS.
ATLANTA LAND USE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REYES.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
TODAY I AM PRESENTING* AB
TWENTY FOUR FORTY SEVEN WHICH IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
[inaudible]
SENATE AMENDMENTS.
AS BEFORE THE CORE MESSAGE OF
THIS BILL IS SIMPLE.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD PRIORITIZE
BRING IN THE MOST VULNERABLE
GROUPS IN THE STATE. TO THE
TABLE WHEN MAKING LOCAL LAND USE
DECISIONS.
MANY OF OUR MOST DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ARE NOT ONLY
POLLUTED BUT ALSO STRUGGLED TO
ENGAGE IN THE TRADITIONAL SEQUEL
PROCESS GIVEN BARRIERS IN PLACE
FOR PEOPLE OF LOW INCOME.
AB TWENTY FOR FORTY SEVEN
ENSURES WE TAKE AN EXTRA STEP.
TO ENGAGE THESE INDIVIDUALS BY
PUTTING IN PLACE NOTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS FOR LOCAL RESIDENTS
WHEN INDUSTRIAL OR EQUIVALENT
LAND USES ARE BEING PROPOSED.
MEMBERS THIS BILL DOES NOT RE
ALLOCATE RESOURCES.
BUT ENSURES MEANINGFUL OUTREACH
ENGAGEMENT WITHIN THE EXISTING
SICK OR PROCESS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK THREE AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I'M SEEING NO REQUEST
TO SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHOSE ARE
TO VOTE.
PHONE MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
THE ROLAND TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FORTY ONE KNOWS TWENTY SIX THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCORD
AND MOVING TO ITEM.
ONE OH TO AB.
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY I BEG YOUR
PARDON THAT ITEM IS NO LONGER ON
FILE.
WE'RE MOVING INSTEAD TO ITEM ONE
OH THREE AB.
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTEEN MATTER
QUICKLY STREET.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTEEN BY SOME A MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND ACTUALLY TO
FORESTRY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTEEN WILL PROMOTE HOLISTIC A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
LONG TERM FORESTRY MANAGEMENT.
AND WILDFIRE RISK BY EXPANDING
THE MARKET FOR INNOVATIVE WOOD
PRODUCTS IN CALIFORNIA.
THESE PRODUCTS CRAIG A VALUABLE
IN USE FOR SMALL AND LOW VALUE
WOOD HARVESTED DURING FORCE
MAINTENANCE ACTIVITIES.
CREATING IN STATE MARKETS FOR
THESE RODUCTS WILL INCENTIVIZE
PRIVATE INVESTMENT FOREST HEALTH.
WHICH IS NECESSARY TO PROTECT
OUR NATURISTS SOURCES PREVENT
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES DEVELOP
RURAL ECONOMIES AND PROMOTE PART
CLIMACOOL.
DARIEN YOU'RE AWESOME THANKS --
FOR FOR FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON TWENTY FIVE EIGHTEEN THANK
YOU I AM SEEING A REQUEST TO
SPEAK.
MY PURPOSE OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES I SEVENTY ONE NO.
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCORDANT.
WE ARE MOVING OUT ITEM ONE OH
FOR A BI TWENTY SIX CITY FOR THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY FOUR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY PARENTAGE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY FOUR UPDATES
THE UNIFORM PARENTAGE ACT AND
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE REMOVE
ALL OPPOSITION.
E. A CALIFORNIA HAS LONG BEEN A
TRAILBLAZER IN PROTECTING LGBT
INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR CHILDREN
THIS BILL ENSURES THAT WE
CONTINUE ON THAT PATH.
AND UPDATES LAWS TO REFLECT
CURRENT CULTURE.
AND TECHNOLOGY I ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SING A REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE MEMBERS BOTH.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES ICE SIXTY
THREE KNOWS ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM ONE OF FIVE AB
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY SEVEN BY
SALLY MEMBER BLOOM ACTUALLY TO
HOUSING ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM.
THANK YOU NEXT UP I HAVE AB
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY SEVEN ALSO
BACK FROM THE SENATE WHICH
CLARIFIES A PROVISION.
IN DENSITY BONUS LAW TO ENSURE
THAT A PROJECT COULD NOT BE
FOUND INCONSISTENT WITH THE
COASTAL ACT MERELY BECAUSE IT
RECEIVES A DENSITY INCREASE
UNDER STATE LAW.
THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE
SENATE CHAPTER OUT CONFLICTS
WITH S. B. TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN
SKINNER.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY AB TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY THREE FRIEDMAN.
THE BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION IS AN
IS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
BOTH HOUSES THANK YOU AND I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEING A REQUEST TO SPEAK
MEDICAL PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRING TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES I SYSTEM
STEVE FOR NOSE ZERO THE SENATE
MEMBERS ARE PREFERRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM ONE OF SIX AB
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY SIX THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY SIX BY SON NEVER GLORIA
AND OTHERS AND ACTING A TRIBAL
AFFAIRS THE SOME MEMBER GLORIA.
THEY YOU KNOW SPEAKER THIS IS AB
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY SIX BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE ALL YOU NEED TO KNOW
YOU ARE PASSING IS THE LAST TIME
THE SENATE PASSED UNANIMOUSLY AS
WELL ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEING KNOW REQUEST FOR ALLOW
ABERRATION.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR OWN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE YOU DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY NOW CLOSE
THE RUINED HOW THE VOTES I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM ONE OF SEVEN AB
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY FIVE MEADOW
PARK PLEASE READ.
A SOME PEOPLE TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID
CHIU AND I PLAYED THE
TRANSPORTATION THANK YOU AS A
MEMBER.
TO THANK ADMINISTRATOR
COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY SIXTY FIVE
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
SENTIMENTS NEAR THE BILL TO
REQUIRE THE SAN FRANCISCO
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY WORKING
WITH THE SENATE CLARA VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY. TO GO
THROUGH THE EXISTING CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION
PROCESS TO CREATE MANAGE LANES
ON THE CONGESTED ONE I WANTED TO
EIGHTY QUARTERS THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO.
REQUEST TO SPEAK THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE.
A MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE ON
TELLY DEVOTES EYES FORTY TWO IT
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
DAVID I DON'T WANT TO WAIT AB
TWENTY NINE SIXTY SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ.
AT SOME LEVEL TWENTY NINE SIXTY
SEVEN BY FAMILY MEMBER QUIRK
SILVA AND ACTUALLY TO FOSTER
CARE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY
SEVEN WOULD ENSURE FOSTER YOUTH
ARE PROVIDED WITH BIRTH
CERTIFICATES FREE OF COST AS THE
BASIC.
PRE REQUISITE FOR ADDITIONAL
FORMS OF IDENTIFICATION
IMPORTANT SERVICES EDUCATION AND
EMPLOYMENT.
SENATE AMENDMENTS CLARIFIED THE
IMPLEMENTING THE IMPLEMENTATION
<c.blue>ATE AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY SEVEN</c>
HAS RECEIVED NO OPPOSITE.
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR IN LIFE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
I MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLIED THE VOTES AYE
AYES SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM ONE ON
NINE AB THIRTY EIGHTEEN BETTER
PARK PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY EIGHTEEN THE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW AND ACTUALLY THE
PUBLIC CONTRACTS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MINISTER CAN
MEMBERS A. B. THIRTY EIGHTEEN IS
A SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE.
SEEING A REQUEST TO SPEAK THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON THE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
CLARK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TELLING THE VOTES EYES FORTY SIX
KNOWS EIGHTEEN THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
ITEM.
ONE TEN PASS TEMPORARILY.
ITEM ONE ELEVEN A. B. THIRTY
EIGHTY ONE THE CLERK WILL READ.
AS ONLY A THIRTY EIGHTY ONE BY
SOME A MEMBER GONZALEZ FLETCHER
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
IMPLEMENT.
SO MEMBER GONZALEZ FLETCHER
THANK YOU THIS IS A WORKPLACE --
KEEPING WORKPLACE SAFE FROM
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IT'S BEEN
NARROWED SUBSTANTIALLY IN THE
SENATE TO JUST TWO THINGS ONE A
THIRTY DAY PERIOD OF REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION OF FIRED AFTER --
SUBMITTING A SEXUAL HARASSMENT
CLAIM IN THE SECOND IS TO HOLD
LABOR CONTRACTORS ACCOUNTABLE
FOR SEXUAL HARASSMENT ASSAULT
DISCRIMINATION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE YOU KNOW WHAT
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE METAPHOR
PLEASE OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE BECAUSE OUR TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES
TWENTY ONE I'M SORRY AYE AYES
FORTY ONE KNOWS TWENTY ONE THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
MOVING TO ITEM ONE TWELVE AB
THIRTY ONE OH ONE THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE OH ONE
BY SONY MEMBER CARILLO AND
ACTUALLY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARILLO.
ALL UP IN MY SHOTS [inaudible]
SALAS PLEDGE.
THANK YOU MEDICS BAKER I'M HERE
PERCENT AB THIRTY ONE OH ONE
WHICH IS BACK ON CONCURRENT
SENATE AMENDMENTS CLARIFY.
THE NON CREDIT STUDENTS ARE
EXEMPT FROM FILING A RESIDENCY
REQUIREMENTS DURING THE
APPLICATION PROCESS.
BUT ENSURE THAT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE CAN SEEK THIS INFORMATION
AFTERWARDS THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR THE SENATE FLOOR
UNANIMOUSLY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW THE VOTES EYES SEVENTY ONE
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT IN MOVING TO ITEM ONE
THIRTEEN AB.
THIRTY ONE SIXTY EIGHT THAT
APART PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY ONE SIXTY EIGHT BY SALLY
MEMBER RUBIO AND ACTUALLY THE
OUTDOOR ADVERTISING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER A. B.
THIRTY ONE SIXTY EIGHT GIVES
CITIES FLEXIBILITY TO RELOCATE
PERMITTED FINE EDGE OUTSIDE OF
MINUTES MUNICIPAL BOUNDARIES.
UNTO SECTIONS OF LANDSCAPE
FREEWAY WHILE STILL CONFORMING
TO STATE AND FEDERAL REGULATIONS
AND NOT ADDING ANY MORE NEW
SIGNAGE ON CALIFORNIA HIGHWAYS.
SENATE AMENDMENTS INCORPORATED
IMPORT FROM CALTRANS THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY SIX
NO ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE COMFORTING AND
MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING TO ITEM ONE FOURTEEN
A. B. THIRTY ONE EIGHTY EIGHT
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT BY SOME YOU ARE BUT
THEY'RE MEANT AND ACTING SCHOOL
ACCOUNTABILITY.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THURMOND.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS I'M STANDING BEFORE YOU
TO PRESENT AB. THIRTY ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT THIS BILL LOOKS AT HOW WE
PREPARE OUR STUDENTS FOR THEIR
FUTURES.
TYPICALLY SCHOOL DISTRICT'S
THINK IN TERMS OF EITHER
PREPARING STUDENTS FOR COLLEGE
BUT WITH THE ATG REQUIREMENTS.
OR FOR THE WORKFORCE --
THROUGH CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS WE NOW KNOW
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO GIVE
OUR STUDENTS ACCESS.%
BOTH COLLEGE AND CAREER
PREPARATION THIS BILL REQUIRED
ARE SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE RIGHT
INTO OUR LOCAL CONTROL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLANS HOW WE
MEASURE OUR PREPARATION OF
STUDENTS FOR BOTH.
INTERESTED TO SEE ISSUE AND YOU
SEE AND INTO THE WORLD OF WORK
ON BEHALF OF OUR STUDENTS WE
HOPE TO PREPARE FOR THE FUTURE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON A B..
THIRTY ONE EIGHTY EIGHT THANK
YOU SEEN NEVER CROSSED TO SPEAK
THE PARK LOCAL THE ROLE MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK COULD MAKE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MOVING TO ITEM OF ONE FIFTEEN AB.
NINETY ONE BUT A QUICK PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL NINETY ONE BY
SOME A MEMBER CERVANTES AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO HIGHWAYS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY AND PRESENTING AB
NINETY ONE THAT'S IT ON IN
CONCURRENCE ASKING FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRING TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY SIX
KNOWS ONE THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCORD IN MOVING TO ITEM.
ONE SIXTEEN AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTY THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
THIRTY BY SEMI MEMBER BIGELOW
AND EXPLAIN TO VEHICLES DECLARE
THE URGENCY THERE UP TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BIGELOW.
THANK YOU MENACE BIGGER
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
SEEING NO REQUEST TO CONTINUE
THE DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON
MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MET PAUL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE THIS REQUIRES
FIFTY FOR ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
THE CLERK.
MAY CLOSE THE ROLAND TALLY THE
VOTES.
ISAIAH SIXTY SIX KNOWS ONE ON
THE URGENCY NO I'M SORRY ZERO IN
THE URGENCY I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO
ON THE MEASURE.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING TO ITEM ONE
SEVENTEEN A. B. THIRTY SIXTY ONE
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY SIXTY ONE
BY SOME A MEMBER GLORIA AND
OTHERS AT THAT POINT STATE
HIGHWAYS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA.
THANK YOU MEDI SPEAKER AB THIRTY
SIXTY ONE IS BACK ON CONCURRENT
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW THE CITY
OF SAN DIEGO TO LEASE CALTRANS
PROPERTY.
AT FORTY SEVEN FORTY SEVEN
PACIFIC HIGHWAY FOR ONE DOLLAR
FOR THE PURPOSES OF EMERGENCY
SHELTER AND FEEDING PROGRAMS FOR
THE HOMELESS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MADAM CLERK WAS OPEN
THE RUN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED. TO LIFT
THE CALL ON ITEM ONE TWENTY
SEVEN S. B. NINE FIFTY EIGHT THE
COURT WILL POST
.
MR AYE MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE
THE ROLE TALLY THE VOTES AYE
AYES FORTY ONE KNOWS.
THIRTY ONE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING BACK TO ITEM ONE EIGHTEEN
AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY FIVE THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY ONE THIRTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER AND
ACTUALLY THE STREETS AND
HIGHWAYS THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO YOUR COLLEAGUE SOME
NUMBER FRAZIER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
ARISE TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
AB.
THIRTY ONE THIRTY FIVE THE FACT
THAT.
IS HERB SINCE TWO THOUSAND TEN
THE STATE'S HIGHWAYS HAVE BECOME
LESS SAFE.
SPECIFICALLY CRASHES OF
INCREASED 29%.
IN THE NUMBER OF DEATHS PER MILE.
DRIVEN HAS INCREASED 27%.
THE STATISTICS FAR OUTPACED THE
STATE'S POPULATION GROWTH OF 8%
AS WELL AS INCREASE OF LICENSED
DRIVERS ARE REGISTERED VEHICLES
OF 11%.
THE DECLINING SAFETY OF OUR
HIGHWAYS IS DIRECTLY RELATED TO
THIS FACT.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TEN THE
NUMBER OF CHP OFFICERS ON OUR
ROADS HAVE ACTUALLY DECREASED 7%.
IT IS TIME FOR THE STATE TO TAKE
ACTION TO REVERSE THESE TRENDS
AND PROPERLY FUND THE OFFICERS
WE NEED TO ENSURE CALIFORNIANS
CAN TRAVEL SAFELY.
WE HAVE NOT ADDED AN ADDITIONAL
OFFICER FOR NINE YEARS.
AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY FIVE
REQUIRES THE GOVERNOR TO
PRIORITIZE THE FUNDING WE
COLLECT FOR ENFORCING HIGHWAY
SAFETY LAWS AND SPEND IT.
AS IT SHOULD BE SPENT ON
OFFICERS.
THIS BILL RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN SENATE PASSIONATE
UNANIMOUSLY OUT OF COMMITTEE
LAST NIGHT.
AND HAS NO OFFICE IN OPPOSITION.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN PLEASE HELP
ME.
PREVENT OTHER FAMILIES FROM
HAVING TRAGEDIES LIKE MY FAMILY
DID ON A CALIFORNIA STATE
HIGHWAY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS MEMBERS I RISE
AND ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT THIS
BILL ON CONCURRENCE --
THE HIGHWAY PATROL IS VITAL TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC AND TO ENSURE
GOODS CAN MOVE EFFICIENTLY ON
OUR ROADWAYS RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
HAVING ADDITIONAL HIGHWAY PATROL
OFFICERS.
REDUCES ACCIDENTS AND REMOVES
TRAFFIC HAZARDS SINCE CUTS WERE
MADE DURING THE RECESSION
CALIFORNIA'S GAME MORE PEOPLE
MORE DRIVERS AND MORE VEHICLES.
IT MAKES SENSE THAT WE HAVE MORE
CA HP AS WELL.
CHP IS IMPORTANT TO OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY AND OUR ECONOMY AND I ASK
FOR YOUR IDEA.
THANK YOU WITHOUT MADAM CLERK
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON ALL
MEMBERS VOTE YOU DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLLING TIDE THE BOATS I SEVENTY
TWO NO ZERO SEVEN THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCORD AND
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO THIRD
READING FILE.
ITEM OF ONE TWENTY NINE PASS AND
RETAIN IT MOVING TO ITEM ONE
THIRTY EIGHT YEAR.
FIFTY NOT A PURPOSE READ.
ASSEMBLY TYPE RESOLUTION FIFTY
BY SONY MEMBER REYES AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO VEHICULAR AIR
POLLUTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
FOR OVER FIVE DECADES CALIFORNIA
HAS LED THE NATION WITH EFFORTS
COMBATING AUTOMOTIVE EMISSIONS
VIA BIPARTISAN EFFORTS TO
ESTABLISH STANDARDS THAT SERVE
AS A MODEL FOR THE REST OF THE
NATION.
AND THE WORLD.
RECENTLY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
RELEASED A PLAN.
THAT WOULD ROLL BACK
CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO SET ITS
OWN AUTOMOTIVE EMISSIONS RULES.
AS PROVIDED VIA WAIVER UNDER THE
FEDERAL CLEAN AIR ACT.
THIS NEW PLAN WILL INCREASE
POLLUTION AND HAVE A DRASTIC
IMPACT ON OUR ECONOMY WITH THE
INCREASED COSTS.
AT THE FUEL PUMP. FOR CALIFORNIA
DRIVERS.
AND THE WILL ALSO CAUSE GREATER
HEALTH CARE COSTS.
CALIFORNIA'S AUTOMOTIVE
POLLUTION STANDARDS HAVE PUSHED
AND EXHILARATED INNOVATION IN
THE AUTUMN OF THE AUTOMOTIVE
INDUSTRY.
OUR MODERN CARS PRODUCED FEWER
EMISSIONS AND HAVE INCREASED GAS
MILEAGE WITHOUT COMPROMISING
PERFORMANCE.
SUPPORTING AJ ARE FIFTY IS A
VOTE FOR SCIENCE AND CONTINUE
DEVELOPMENT OF TECHNOLOGIES TO
PROTECT OUR AIR WITHOUT
COMPROMISING CONSUMER CHOICE.
I ASKED TO JOIN WITH ME TODAY TO
REJECT THIS POORLY THOUGHT OUT
POLICY BEING PROPOSED IN
WASHINGTON DC.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I VERY MUCH THANK OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM SANDRA DINO --
FOR JOINING ME IN OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM INGLEWOOD IS JOINT AUTHORS
OF THIS RESOLUTION AND STRONGLY
URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
WITH A BIT OF HISTORY.
THE CLEAN AIR ACT WAS
[inaudible]
SUPPORTED.
THE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
ORIGINALLY SIGNED BY REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENT WHO FOUNDED A
REPUBLICAN ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY.
THE FIRST WAIVER FOR THE CLEAN
AIR ACT WAS REQUESTED BY
GOVERNOR RONALD REAGAN.
AND HAS RECEIVED RE APPLICATION
AND REALLY.
APPROVAL OVER A HUNDRED THIRTY
TIMES IN FIVE DECADES WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
THAT'S BECAUSE THE WAIVER WORKS.
IF YOU ECONOMY STANDARDS WORKS
AND AND REALLY AGGRESSIVELY
TRYING TO MEET OUR MISSIONS
CHALLENGES WORKS.
AND WE'VE SEEN THAT FOR DECADES.
IT'S ALSO SOMETHING THAT IS.
A GREAT APPLICATION OF THE
PRINCIPLE OF FEDERALISM.
BUT I KNOW MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES
ALSO SUPPORT AS ONE OF OUR
FUNDAMENTAL REPUBLICAN BELIEFS.
WHICH IS ALLOW OUR STATES TO BE
THE ONES TO DECIDE AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE WHAT CAN BE BEST FOR
THEM IN FACING THE CHALLENGES.
THAT THEY HAVE BEFORE THEM IN
CALIFORNIA HAS HISTORICALLY HAD
GREAT GREAT CHALLENGES IN ITS
AIR QUALITY WE ARE LEADING THE
WAY IN ADDRESSING THOSE
CHALLENGES BUT THE WAIVER IS A
FUNDAMENTAL WAY TO DO THAT.
AND THIS IS IT ASKING FOR A
SPECIAL FAVOR WE ALREADY HAVE
THIS WAIVER AND IT'S BEEN
REVOKED FROM US AND THAT IS WHAT
THE PROPOSAL IS.
SO I WANT TO UNDERSCORE HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO REALIZE THE
HISTORY OF THIS WAIVER.
THE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IS HAD
FOR DECADES.
AND ALSO I REALLY THINK THE WAY
WE CAME TOGETHER IN A RESOLUTION
AND AND INSTEAD OF ONLY HAVING
ONE PARTY.
ON ONE RESOLUTION ONE PARTY ON
THE OTHER WE CAME TOGETHER IT
TOOK PEOPLE WILLING TO DO THAT
WE HAVE A MUCH STRONGER VOICE
WHEN WE COLLABORATE AND WE HAVE
A UNITED MESSAGE WHICH WE CAN DO
TODAY.
AND TODAY IS THE TIME TO DO IT
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS MEETING WITH THE
STATE OFFICIALS RIGHT NOW ABOUT
THIS WAIVER AND THE RULES AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL.
AND SO I VERY STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT --
AND I'D MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS A
BIPARTISAN MEASURE WE HAVE A
MUCH STRONGER VOICE IN FIGHTING
FOR OUR STATE. FOR GOOD POLICY
THAT PROTECTS OUR ENVIRONMENT
AND BY THE WAY THESE FUEL
ECONOMY STANDARDS THE MORE AND
MORE WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO BE
SUCCESSFUL.
AND MORE FUEL EFFICIENT VEHICLES
AND EMISSIONS PROGRAMSTHAT
WE'VE DONE IN CALIFORNIA THE
MORE AFFORDABLE WE ARE MAKING
TRAVEL AND VEHICLE OWNERSHIP AND
FUEL IN THIS STATE.
AND I WILL SAY IT'S NOT OFTEN
ENOUGH THAT WE DO THINGS THAT
HELP CALIFORNIANS AFFORD TO LIVE
HERE THIS IS ONE OF THE THINGS
YOU CAN DO --
BY SUPPORTING THIS MEASURE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY TO ASK MY COLLEAGUES TO
JOIN ME IN SUPPORT OF AG ARE
FIFTY REGARDING THE FEDERAL
CLEAN AIR ACT.
EIJI ARE FIFTY WILL ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA KEEPS ITS COMMITMENTS
TO THE EXISTING CLEAN CAR
STANDARDS AND CONTINUES TO
PURSUE THE FEDERAL CLEAN AIR ACT
WAIVERS THAT HAVE HELPED OUR
GREAT STATE LEAD THE COUNTRY.
AND SETTING VEHICLE EMISSION
STANDARDS THAT IMPROVE THE WELL
BEING OF OUR ENVIRONMENT OUR
ECONOMY AND THE HEALTH OF OUR
PEOPLE.
THE ABILITY TO PURSUE WAIVERS IS
NOW BEING THREATENED BY AN
ADMINISTRATION SEEKING TO
RESTRICT OUR STATE AUTHORITY.
AT A TIME WHEN CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO MEET OUR GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSION REDUCTION GOALS AND
WE CONTINUE TO SUCCESSFULLY
ADDRESS OUR CLIMATE.
CHANGE CHALLENGES IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT CALIFORNIA
EXERCISES ITS AUTHORITY IN
PURSUIT OF THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF OUR PEOPLE.
MEMBERS CALIFORNIA IS KNOWN AS
THE GOLDEN STATE.
IT IS GOLDEN BECAUSE WE CHOOSE
TO SET THE GOLD STANDARD FOR
HEALTH FOR THE ECONOMY FOR
EDUCATION AND FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO JOIN
ME IN SUPPORTING AG ARE.
FIFTY THANK YOU I SEE NO FURTHER
REQUEST TO SPEAK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REYES WOULD YOU LIKE CO AUTHORS
AND WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
[inaudible]
YES ON THE CO AUTHORS ON THIS --
BIPARTISAN JOINT RESOLUTION AND
THE YES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE
FOR AUTHORS MEMBERS THIS ROLE IS
FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS MEMBERS FOR CALL THIS ROLE
IS FOR COAUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
THERE ARE FIFTIES THERE ARE
FIFTY SEVEN CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION MADAM FOR PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE ON THE REST OF ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
AND A QUICK YOU MAY CLOSE OF THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY SEVEN KNOWS FOR THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM ONE THIRTY
ONE AJ ARE FIFTY ONE MAN A
QUICKLY.
THREE ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION
FIFTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOPER RELATIVE TO RIGHTS OF
FEDERAL EMPLOYEES [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AG OUR FIFTY ONE URGE THE
PRESIDENT TO RESCIND THREE
EXECUTIVE ORDERS REGARDING
REPRESENTATION COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING.
IN DUE PROCESS RIGHTS OF FEDERAL
EMPLOYEES.
THESE ORDERS HAVE NARROWED
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING RIGHTS IN
NEW NEGATIVITY'S.
INCREASE EMPLOYEE PROBATIONARY
PERIODS AND OPPOSE PERFORMANCE
STANDARDS.
ESTABLISHED DEADLINES TO
COMPLETE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
NEGOTIATIONS.
EFFECTIVELY SILENCE THE VOICES
OF OUR ONE HUNDRED FORTY
THOUSAND FEDERAL [inaudible]
EMPLOYEES.
IS EXECUTIVE ORDERS WHAT
NEGATIVELY AFFECT ALL
CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY VETERANS
[inaudible]
SECURITY BENEFICIARIES MILITARY
TROOPS AND THOSE IN THE THE FEMA
ASSISTANCE.
AS OUR RECENT FIRE VICTIMS I
URGE MY VOTE NESS THE FIRST ROLE
BUILT OVER COAUTHORS.
THANK YOU I AM SEEING THE NO
REQUEST TO SPEAK MADAM HERCULES
OPEN THE ROLE AUTHORS.
MEMBERS THIS ROLE IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RISEN.
ISRAEL IS RECALL AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLE IS FOR COOPER IS ON OF
THE RESOLUTION MADAM CLERK YOU
MAY CLOSE THE ROLE THERE ARE.
FORTY SEVEN CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION METAPHOR PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS THIS ROLE IS
FOR THE VOTING ON THE RESOLUTION
ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND HOW THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY SEVEN NO.
ELEVEN THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL.
ON ITEM TO A ONE SP.
THIRTEEN HUNDRED THE CLERK WILL
POST.
META PARK YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY ONE NO.
THIRTY THAT MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO BE
PASSING AND RETAINING ON FILE
ITEM.
TO FORTY FIVE MOVING NOW TO ITEM
ONE THIRTY TO AJ ARE FORTY SEVEN
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY TRACK RESOLUTION FORTY
SEVEN BY SOMETHING I BLOOM AND
OTHERS FELT OF THE CLIMATE
CHANGE AND COASTAL RESOURCES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS SIN JUST COUPLE
OF WEEKS THE STATE WILL HOST THE
GLOBAL CLIMATE ACTION SUMMIT.
EIJI ARE FORTY SEVEN URGES THAT
STATE AND FEDERAL ACTION INCLUDE
THE EFFECT OF CLIMATE CHANGE ON
OCEAN SYSTEMS AND COASTAL
COMMUNITIES WITH EQUITY
CONSIDERATIONS AT THE FOREFRONT.
pTHE NEED FOR ENVIRONMENTALLY
JUST PROGRAMS AND POLICIES THAT
CONSIDER HUMAN COMMUNITIES IN
ADDITION TO FISH AND WILDLIFE.
ESPECIALLY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THAT WILL SUFFER
DISPROPORTIONATELY FROM
DISPLACEMENT PROPERTY LOSS AND
RISING HOME INSURANCE COSTS WITH
THINGS LIKE SEA LEVEL RISE.
THANK YOU AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND ASK THAT THE FIRST WILL
BE OPEN [inaudible]
FOR CO AUTHOR.
THANK YOU I AM SEEING NO REQUEST
IS IT ON THIS ITEM METALCORE
PLEASE OPEN THE RAINN AUTHORS.
MEMBERS THIS RULES FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLE FOR COAUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLE IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE RULE THERE
ARE FORTY FOUR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION THAT PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE.
IS GOAL IS FOR VOTING ON THE
RESOLUTION ITSELF ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
MADAM QUIRK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES ICE
FIFTY SEVEN NO THREE THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM ONE THIRTY
THREE EIGHT YEAR FORTY THREE
MEDICARE PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION FORTY
THREE BY FAMILY MEMBER BLOOM
RELATIVE TO HOUSING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AS YOU
ALL KNOW MEMBERS THE NATION IS
FACING A HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
AND SUPPLY CRISIS IS NOT JUST
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND YET THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
HAS CONSTANTLY PROPOSED TO
IMPOSE WORK REQUIREMENTS RENT
INCREASES ANOTHER BURDENS.
ON MILLIONS OF LOW INCOME
FAMILIES AND SENIORS WHO RECEIVE
FEDERAL HOUSING ASSISTANCE
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT.
AT A TIME WHEN WE SHOULD BE
ASSISTING OUR MOST VULNERABLE AS
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THERE ARE
MOST PROSPEROUS THAT THEY ARE
MOST PROSPEROUS.
WHEN THEY HAVE HOUSING?
EIJI ARE FORTY THREE CALLS UPON
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES AND THE SECRETARY OF
HOUSING AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT.
TO HONOR THEIR PLEDGES TO
PROTECT RENTAL HOUSING AT RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS. TO VETO ANY
LEGISLATION THAT UNDERMINES
THOSE PROGRAMS AND TO WORK WITH
THE CONGRESS TO FURTHER PROTECT
RENTAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS AND
THE MISSION OF HIDE.
THANK YOU I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND ASKED THAT THE FIRST
ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK WOULD YOU LIKE CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION.
MADAM PURPOSE OPEN THE ROLE FOR
POPULOUS MEMBERS THIS IS FOR
POLL AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
[inaudible]
ALL MEMBERS.
BUT EFFORT YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE THERE ARE FORTY SEVEN
COAUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE ON THE
RESOLUTION.
I MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
ON THE RESOLUTION ALL MEMBERS
VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
BENEFIT YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TELLING THE BOATS ICE FIFTY
KNOWS FOURTEEN THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING OUT OF
FILE ORDER TO ITEM.
ONE SIXTY THREE S. B. SIX FIVE
SIX MY PURPOSE READ.
SENATE BILL SIX FIFTY SIX BY
SENATOR MORLOCK AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY DO IT WOULD YOU JUDGES
RETIREMENT MAKING PREPARATION
THERE FOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY.
COLLEAGUES I'M PERFECTLY PLEASED
TO BRING TO YOU TODAY SENATE
BILL SIX FIVE SIX BY SENATOR
MORLOCK.
THIS DEALS WITH WHAT IS KNOWN AS
THE JUDGES RETIREMENT SYSTEM.
TWO IT IS A PENSION SYSTEM
ESTABLISH IN NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR IT SUPPORTS ABILITY OF OUR
STATE'S BENCH. TO HAVE A
RETIREMENT SYSTEM [inaudible]
A AS AT THIS POINT TWENTY FOUR
YEARS IN THE LIFE OF THE SYSTEM.
IT'S CLEAR THAT SOME OF ITS
RULES.
DON'T MESH WITH THE WAY CAREERS
OF JUDGES ON FULL.
A JUDGE YOU MAY HAVE A HEALTH
ISSUE DUE TO RETIRE.
EARLY IT'S SOMEWHAT OF A
CONSTRAINED SYSTEM THIS BILL
DOES NOT INCREASE BENEFITS.
BUT ALLOWS RESTRUCTURING HOW THE
BENEFIT IS ENJOYED.
A DOES NOT.
ALTER THE ACTUAR SOUNDNESS OF
THE FUND ACTUALLY STRENGTHENS IT.
ARE VERY OUTSTANDING BILL FOR
THE THESE IMPORTANT PARTNERS
INJURED JUDICIARY BRANCH HER
QUESTION RIGHT VOTE.
THANK YOU ETCETERA GROW.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
IS A PRINCIPLE CO AUTHOR THIS
LEGISLATION.
BUT THIS HAD BEEN TRIED BEFORE
STARTED AND FAILED AND SENATE
PURRS I JUST WANT TO
CONGRATULATE CENTER MORLOCK AND
SARAH LARA.
FORGET IN THIS BILL OVER THE
HURDLE AND FOR ALL THEIR HARD
WORK ON THIS AND ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
I AM SEEING NO FURTHER REQUEST
TO SPEAK SOME EVER COOLEY DID
YOU WANT TO CLOSE.
EXHIBITION BROS TAKEN AS MY
CLOTHES THANK YOU DID YOU WANT A
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY --
MEDICARE PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS BONE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES
SIXTY SEVEN AT NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES
.
TALK AMONGST YOURSELVES
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THE FILE BUT IN THE
MEANTIME I'D LIKE TO ENTERTAIN A
REQUEST FOR VOTE CHANGES --
FROM YOUR DESKS IF YOU'LL RAISE
YOUR MICROPHONES ALLEN ADVISE I
RECOGNIZE INDIVIDUAL MEMBERS FOR
VOTE CHANGES.
NOT QUIRK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
A. B..
A. B. ONE SEVEN FIVE ARE.
ONE I TO ABSTAIN THAT'S A. B..
ONE SEVEN FIVE ONE I TO ABSTAIN.
BOAT CHANGE QUIRK ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY FIFTY ONE I TO NOT
VOTING.
THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK.
ASSEMBLY NEVER COOPER YOUR
RECOGNIZED FOR VOTE CHANGE FILE
ITEM TO NINETEEN S. B. --
THIRTEEN OH THREE FROM AYE TO NO.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER
COOPER SENATE BILL THIRTEEN NO
THREE ITEM NO.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MELENDEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR THE PURPOSES OF A
CHANGE FILE ITEM ONE FIFTEEN A.
B. NINE ONE NO TO AYE.
MELENDEZ ASSEMBLY BILL NINETY
ONE NO TO OUR THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MELENDEZ A SIMILAR MARK
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR VOTE CHANGE YES
FILE ITEM.
ONE FORTY NINE S. B. SEVEN TWO
ZERO FROM NOTRE AYE.
RODRIGUEZ SENATE BILL SEVEN
TWENTY NO TO OUR THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS RODRIGUEZ.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CABALLERO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR THE CHANGE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
FILE NUMBER TO SIXTEEN S. B. TWO
THIRTY SEVEN NOTE I CABALLERO
SENATE BILL TWO THIRTY SEVEN NO
TO OUR THANK YOU MISS KILEY ERA.
SUMMIT MEMBER STEINORTH DO YOU
RECOGNIZE FOR THE CHANGE FILE
ITEM NINETY SIX AB TWENTY ONE OH
SEVEN NO TWO I STEINORTH
ASSEMBLY RULE TWENTY ONE OH
SEVEN NO TIME --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALLEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR VOTE CHANGE.
THANK YOU --
FILE FIFTY THREE AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY ALL I TO NOT VOTING.
ALLEN A ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY SEVENTY ITEM NOT
VOTING.
THANK YOU SIR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LIMON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR A
CHANGE THANK YOU SP.
ONE THREE THREE THREE UP FROM
AYE TO NOT VOTING.
THE MOMENT SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
SEVENTY THREE I TO NOT VOTING.
THEY CAN IS UNKNOWN DOCTOR CHOI
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR VOTING
CHALABI'S RSP UP ONE TWO TWO
FIVE ON NO [inaudible]
TWO NOT VOTING.
DON'T YOU I APOLOGIZE WOULD YOU
REPEAT THAT O CHANGE PLEASE SP.
ONE TWO TWO FIVE NO TWO NOT
VOTING.
STORY SENATE BILL TWELVE TWENTY
FIVE NOTES ABOUT VOTING.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CHOI ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LIMON COULD YOU REPEAT
YOUR VOTE CHANGE PLEASE FOR THE
RECORD.
S. B. ONE THREE THREE THREE FROM
I TEND NOT VOTING.
LIMON SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
SEVENTY THREE ITEM THIRTEEN
THIRTY THREE I TO NOT VOTING.
THANK YOU AS LONG.
A MEMBERS OTHER VOTE CHANGES.
PLEASE OF MAJOR MICROPHONES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
VOTE CHANGE THANK YOU AB TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY THREE AYE IT'S NOW.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER ASSEMBLY WILL
28-7 THREE OUGHT TO KNOW.
THANK YOU MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
TO BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THE CHANGE FILE NUMBER TWO ONE
SIX SP TO THIRTY SEVEN AYE TO
NOT VOTING.
BONTA US SENATE BILL TO THIRTY
SEVEN ARE TO NOT LOADING.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA.
MEMBERS AT ANY OTHER MEMBERS
WISHING TO MAKE A VOTE CHANGE AT
THIS TIME PLEASE RAISE YOUR
MIKES
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY WE ARE
NOT A JOURNEY AT THIS TIME --
BUT THE INTEREST OF YOUR USING
YOUR TIME.
WELL I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE UP
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY SIDE ASK
YOU TO PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR.
THE CALL WILL NOT BE LIFTED WE
ARE NOT A JOURNEY MEMBERS
.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR WE WILL MOVE TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
STARTING WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL.
I STARTED WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS --
TODAY I ADJOURNMENTS MY
COLLEAGUE --
FROM THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY IN
THE MEMORY OF SENATOR JOHN
MCCAIN.
HIS LIFE AND SERVICE.
IS A REFLECTION OF THE BEST OF
OUR AMERICAN IDEALS.
IN HIS YOUTH.
MCCAIN'S AS A NAVY AVIATOR.
FOLLOWING IN THE SAME FIGHTING
SPIRIT AS HIS FATHER AND
GRANDFATHER BEFORE HIM.
WHO ARE BOTH FOUR STAR ADD ROOMS?
IN HIS BOOK FAITH OF MY FATHERS
MCCAIN WROTE OF THEIR
INSPIRATION.
WHICH ULTIMATELY LED HIM INTO
PUBLIC SERVICE.
DURING THE VIETNAM WAR HE
VOLUNTEERED FOR COMBAT DUTY IN
FLEW CARRIER BASED ATTACK PLANES.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN HIS A
FOR SKY HAWK PLANE WAS SHOT DOWN.
AND HE WAS TAKEN PRISONER. FOR
OVER FIVE YEARS.
THIS WAS THE FIRST TEST OF THE
CHARACTER OF JOHN MCCAIN.
WHEN IT WAS DISCOVERED THAT HE
WAS THE SON OF A NAVY OFFICER
MCCAIN WAS OFF YOU OFFERED EARLY
RELEASE?
SEVERAL TIMES HE WAS OFFERED
EARLY RELEASE.
BUT HE REFUSED.
DESPITE TORTURE.
IN PERILOUS CONDITIONS.
MCCAIN WOULD NOT ALLOW THOSE
TAKEN PRISONER BEFOREHAND BE
RELEASED AFTER HIM.
IT WAS IN PRISON WHERE MCCAIN
LEARNED WHAT IT MEANT. TO LOVE
HIS COUNTRY. TO REALLY LOVE HIS
COUNTRY.
NOT A USEFUL APPRECIATION FOR
THE COMFORTS OF AMERICAN
PRIVILEGE BUT A MATURE
PATRIOTISM.
WHICH WAS DISCOVERED
[inaudible]
THROUGH SACRIFICE.
HE DID NOT ALLOW THE INJUSTICES
IN INJURIES INFLICTED UPON HIM.
TO DETERMINE HIS DESTINY.
OR TO DAMPEN HIS PASSION FOR
THIS COUNTRY.
MCCAIN WAS ULTIMATELY RELEASED.
HE CONTINUED PUBLIC SERVICE.
AND IS SERVICE TO HIS COUNTRY
FIRST AS A NAVY LIAISON TO THE
U. S. SENATE.
AND THEN DURING THE REAGAN
REVOLUTION HE WAS ELECTED. TO
THE U. S. HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES FROM ARIZONA
[inaudible]
AND EVENTUALLY.
A US SENATOR.
IT WAS DURING THIS TIME THAT HE
FIRST EARNED THE NICKNAME
MAVERICK.
BUT TO ME.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT THAT NAME.
IT'S PROBABLY A MISNOMER.
HE HAD VERY DEEPLY HELD
CONVICTIONS.
AND HE FOLLOWED THEM.
WHEREVER THEY LEAD.
SOMETIMES THAT PUT HIM AT ODDS
WITH HIS PARTY.
AND MOST OF HIS CLOSEST
COLLEAGUES.
BUT HE WAS TRUE [inaudible]
HIS CONVICTION.
AND HE WAS A MAN OF CHARACTER.
MANY KNOW THE REST. SIX TERMS IN
THE U. S. SENATE AND TWO
PRESIDENTIAL RUNS.
NOT FIRST PRESIDENTIAL RUN.
IN.
TWO THOUSAND I REMEMBER WELL AS
A YOUNG COLLEGE STUDENT ON
CAMPUS SEEN HIM GOING AROUND THE
COUNTRY ON THE STRAIGHT TALK
EXPRESS.
IT IT WAS A FRESH VIBRANT
CANDIDACY WAS.
IT WAS MAYBE ONE OF THE FIRST.
OR NOT THE FIRST BUT AN EARLY
ANTI ESTABLISHMENT [inaudible]
CAMPAIGN.
I MEAN I REMEMBER AS A YOUNG
PERSON.
WATCHING HIM IN AND AND HIS
FIRST CAMPAIGN FOR THE
PRESIDENCY HAD INSPIRED ME AND
INSPIRED MANY YOUNG PEOPLE.
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. TO GET
INVOLVED IN PUBLIC SERVICE.
AND TO SPEAK TRUTH [inaudible]
TO POWER.
NOW THROUGHOUT HIS TENURE HE
WOULD WORK ON MANY ISSUES
OBVIOUSLY VETERANS ISSUES HE WAS
VERY WELL KNOWN FOR HEALTH CARE.
HE TRAVELED THE WORLD --
TO IMPROVE U. S. DIPLOMATIC
RELATIONS.
AND THE COUNTRY.
HE WAS ALWAYS A FIERCE ADVOCATE
[inaudible] FOR STRENGTH.
IN THE WORLD THAT THE U. S. HAD
TO PLAY A PIVOTAL ROLE.
IN THE WORLD.
THAT WE WERE ESSENTIAL. TO
THINGS THAT WERE GOING ON IN THE
WORLD AND THAT WE NEEDED TO BE
STRONG.
IN THE NINETIES BECAME WOULD
ACTUALLY IMPROVE YOU ESTA BUT
DIPLOMATIC RELATIONS WITH
VIETNAM.
AND SPONSORED THE VETERAN
HOSPICE BENEFIT ACT WOULD
PROVIDE HOSPICE CARE HOSPICE
CARE FOR TERMINALLY ILL VETERANS.
IN NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN HE WAS
NAMED IN TIME MAGAZINE HAS ONE
OF THE MOST INFLUENTIAL.
PEOPLE IN AMERICA.
IN HIS FAREWELL HE WROTE THAT IT
WAS A PRIVILEGE TO SERVE HIS
COUNTRY.
AND THAT BEING CONNECTED TO
AMERICA'S CAUSES LIBERTY.
EQUAL JUSTICE RESPECT FOR THE
DIGNITY OF ALL PEOPLE.
BROUGHT HIM MORE HAPPINESS.
THEN LIFE'S FLEETING PREP
PLEASURES.
IT WAS THE AMERICAN EXPERIENCE.
THAT BROUGHT HIM CONTENTMENT AND
HE LIVED IT WELL.
AND SO TODAY MEMBERS AS WE
GATHER TOGETHER AS WE ARE.
PRACTICING THE ART OF
STATESMANSHIP.
AS WE ARE COMING TOGETHER ON
FROM DIFFERENT.
PARTS OF THE STATE FROM
DIFFERENT PARTIES.
A FROM DIFFERENT POINTS OF VIEW
BUT ALL WITH THE GOAL OF TRYING.
TO TO BETTER OUR STATE TO BETTER
OUR NATION I ASKED THAT WE
ADJOURN AND THE MEMORY OF OF THE
GREAT AMERICAN PATRIOT AND
STATESMAN.
IN SENATOR JOHN MCCAIN
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER
MISTER GABRIEL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
NICHOLAS --
FOR INCLUDING ME ON THIS JOURNEY
MEMORY AS WE WERE DISCUSSING THE
POSSIBILITY OF DOING THIS FOR
SENATOR MCCAIN WE FELT THAT.
GIVEN HIS ROLE IN OUR DEMOCRACY
WOULD BE FITTING AND APPROPRIATE
THAT YOU HAVE A BIPARTISAN
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY.
I ALSO RISE TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY
OF SENATOR JOHN CITY MCCAIN OF
ARIZONA WHO DIED LAST SATURDAY
AT THE AGE OF EIGHTY ONE IN THE
COURSE OF HIS LONG PUBLIC
SERVICE.
SENATOR MCCAIN REPRESENTED THE
BEST OF PUBLIC AMERICAN PUBLIC
SERVICE [inaudible]
COMMITMENT [inaudible]
INTEGRITY [inaudible]
PERSONAL SACRIFICE.
INDEPENDENT THINKING.
AND AN ABIDING FAITH IN THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AS WE WAY THE DECISIONS BEFORE
US AT THE CLOSE OF THIS
LEGISLATIVE SESSION WE WOULD DO
WELL TO HEED SENATOR MCCAIN'S
EXAMPLE.
AND EMULATE HIS APPROACH TO
LEADERSHIP.
MOST NOTABLY SENATOR MCCAIN
LIVED OUTSIDE THE BORDERS OF
DOGMA.
BEYOND THE CLAMOR OF THE
POLITICS OF THE DAY.
HE WAS BEHOLDEN TO NO ONE ABOVE
HIS OWN CONSCIENCE.
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS OF HIS
LIFE SENATOR MCCAIN BUCK
CONVENTION TO LEAD THE
BIPARTISAN GANG OF EIGHT
ATTEMPTING TO FORGE COMPROMISE
ON THE ALWAYS CONTROVERSIAL
TOPIC OF IMMIGRATION.
THIS WAS JUST ONE MOMENT.
IN A IN A LONG ANTHOLOGY OF
MOMENTS IN WHICH SENATOR MCCAIN
SPENT HIS POLITICAL CAPITAL. TO
ADVANCE AN EFFORT WHO SUCCESS
WAS FAR FROM GUARANTEED.
AS ALWAYS HE WAS UNDETERRED AND
UNAFRAID TO TAKE PERSONAL RISKS
FOR HIS COUNTRY.
THROUGHOUT HIS CAREER SENATOR
MCCAIN REJECTED ZEALOUS
TRIBALISM AND THE POLITICS OF
FEAR.
I WILL NEVER FORGET NINE MAGICS
THAT'S TRUE OF MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES THE MOMENT DURING THE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT CAMPAIGN.
WHEN A WOMAN INTO TOWN HALL
ASKED A QUESTION ABOUT HIS
OPPONENT BARACK OBAMA LADEN WITH
RACIAL INNUENDO?
SENATOR MCCAIN DIDN'T FLINCH.
NO MA'AM HE SAID HE'S A DECENT
FAMILY MAN AND A CITIZEN THAT I
JUST HAPPEN TO HAVE
DISAGREEMENTS WITH ON
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUES.
AND THEN HE MOVED ON THAT MOMENT
REVEALED EVERYTHING ONE NEEDS TO
KNOW ABOUT JOHN MCCAIN'S
ESSENTIAL CHARACTER.
UNSURPRISINGLY THERE WAS MUCH
THAT I PERSONALLY DISAGREED WITH
SENATOR MCCAIN ON ON ISSUES OF
POLICY IN THE ROLE OF GOVERNMENT.
AS A YOUNG STAFFER IN UNITED
STATES SENATE I WORK FOR A
DEMOCRAT WHEN.
SENATOR MCCAIN SERVE THERE WAS A
LEADING REPUBLICAN.
WE WERE OFTEN AT ODDS.
BUT IN THAT BODY AS AT EVERY
STAGE OF HIS CAREER.
SENATOR MCCAIN MAINTAIN THAT OUR
FATES AS AMERICANS WERE
INTERTWINED IN A WAY IN A WAY
THAT TRANSCENDED POLITICS
[inaudible]
POLICY DIFFERENCES.
IN HIS FAREWELL LETTER HE WROTE
OUR IDENTITIES AND SENSE OF
WORTH ARE NOT CIRCUMSCRIBED BUT
ARE IN LARGE BY SERVING GOOD
CAUSES.
BIGGER THAN OURSELVES.
EVEN IN THE SUNSET OF HIS LIFE
SENATOR MCCAIN WAS DRIVEN BY
THAT NOBLE IDEAL.
IN THE DAYS SINCE HIS DEATH IT'S
BEEN DIFFICULT TO TURN ON THE
TELEVISION OR GO ON SOCIAL MEDIA
WITHOUT SEEING OR HEARING OR
WITNESSING A TRIBUTE TO SENATOR
MCCAIN.
THEY HAVE COME FROM EVERY CORNER
OF THIS COUNTRY.
AND FROM AMERICANS OF ALL
BACKGROUNDS AND FAITHS AND
POLITICAL AFFILIATIONS.
A COMMON THEME THROUGH EACH
TESTIMONY.
THE CONSENSUS REACHED BY A JURY
OF COLLEAGUES OF ADVERSARIES OF
COMPETITORS A FELLOW AMERICANS
[inaudible]
SAME.
JOHN MCCAIN SERVED OUR NATION
WITH INTEGRITY WITH HONOR AND
WITH TREMENDOUS DEVOTION.
AND I BELIEVE AND HOPE AND
EXPECT AS MY COLLEAGUE SAID THAT
HIS LEGACY.
THE WAY THAT HE CONDUCTED
HIMSELF IN HIS PERSONAL LIFE AND
IN HIS PUBLIC LIFE THE WAY IN
WHICH HE SOUGHT TO BRING PEOPLE
TOGETHER AND TO SPEAK TO OUR
HIGHER IDEALS.
THAT LEGACY WILL BE A GUIDEPOSTS
FOR ALL OF US.
AND HIS MEMORY WILL BE A
BLESSING FOR OUR NATION.
PLEASE JOIN ME TODAY IN
ADJOURNING IN MEMORY OF SENATOR
JOHN MCCAIN.
THANK YOU MISTER GABRIEL
.
SIMILAR RETIREMENT.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES SALLY.
I RISE TO ASSN WE NEED YOUR IN
MEMORY OF FOR A MY PROFESSOR
FROM GRADUATE SCHOOL A MENTOR
AND FRIEND.
NOT RAYMOND ALBERT.
I OUT RAMEN WAS THE BROTHER --
OF A TO RESA WHO IS A
CONSTITUENT.
AND THE DISTRICT OF OF MR
MCCARTY I WANNA THANK.
MR MCCARTY FOR ALLOWING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY --
TO PROVIDE THIS ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY.
OF FOR WAY ALBERT.
WHO PASSED AWAY ON AUGUST?
FOR FROM PANCREATIC CANCER.
AT THE AGE OF SIXTY SEVEN RAY
CREATED -- A
PROGRAM THAT I THINK IT'S STILL
THE FIRST OF ITS KIND.
IN THE NATION THE MASTER OF
SOCIAL WORK AND A MASTER.
OF LAW AND SOCIAL POLICY IT'S
THE ONLY PROGRAM THAT I APPLY.
TO IT BREEDS AN INTERSECTION
BETWEEN SOCIAL WORK AND LEGAL
ISSUES AND GOVERNMENT AND THE
ROLE.
OF GOVERNMENT IN SHAPING SOCIAL
POLICY TO HELP.
CHILDREN FAMILIES DISADVANTAGED
BACKGROUNDS.
SO RATE TAUGHT ME AND OUR
COLLEAGUES CONSTITUTIONAL LAW.
HE TAUGHT US MEDIATION.
YOU TAUGHT US ABOUT ARBITRATION
HE TALKS ABOUT THE ROLE OF
GOVERNMENT.
THE MOST IMPORTANT WE STRUGGLED
AND WHEN I STRUGGLED AS AN
ALMOST FULL TIME.
STUDENT AND A FULL TIME EMPLOYEE
ARE WITH FINANCIAL DIFFICULTIES
HE ENCOURAGE ME AND SAID OF
COURSE YOU GET THROUGH YOU MIGHT.
STUMBLE ACROSS THE FINISH LINE
BUT YOU GET ACROSS THE FINISH
LINE.
HE HAD A CALM WAY IN A CALM
WHICH A KIND WORD FOR ANYONE WHO
ASKED [inaudible]
ROBERT.
CREATED HIS OWN EDUCATIONAL
EXPERIENCE FOR STARTING AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF PENNSYLVANIA.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR RAY
WENT ON TO EARN A MASTERS OF
SOCIAL WORK.
AND HIS JURIS DOCTOR --
DEGREES LATER FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CONNECTICUT HE
ALSO RECEIVED HIS DOCTORATE IN
SOCIAL WORK.
FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
PENNSYLVANIA. FOR FOR THIRTY
EIGHT YEARS RAY SERVE AT MY GRAD
SCHOOL ALMA MATER BRYNMAWR
COLLEGE IN PENNSYLVANIA.
A TINY LIBERAL ARTS COLLEGE THAT
IS A TODAY STILL ONE OF THE
HISTORIC WOMEN'S COLLEGE BUT IS
COED AT THE GRADUATE LEVEL HE
DEVELOPED THE PROGRAM THE MASTER
OF LONG SOCIAL POLICY PROGRAM.
USING HIS KNOWLEDGE ARE IN THE
LAW IN RECOGNIZING THE
INTERSECTION OF LAW SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
RAYMOND WAS AN ACTIVE SCHOLAR.
TREATING NUMEROUS ARTICLES AND
BOOKS IN CHAPTERS.
HE PUBLISHED TWO BOOKS LAW AND
SOCIAL WORK PRACTICE A LEGAL
SYSTEMS APPROACH AND SOCIAL
WELFARE PROGRAMS NARRATIVE.
OF HARD TIMES.
HE ALSO WAS VERY WELL WRITTEN
AND BURST.
IN MEDIATION AND OFTEN CALLED
UPON TO LEAD MEDIATION.
I OUTSIDE OF HIS ACADEMIC
PURSUITS --
HE ALSO ARE PROVIDED
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS TO
WORK IN LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
AND HE VOLUNTEERED IN A PROGRAM
TO SERVE FORMERLY INCARCERATED
MEN OF COLOR.
ON BECAUSE HE WAS VERY COMMITTED.
A DELINQUENCY PREVENTION.
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. FOR
MANY YEARS HE SERVES AS THE DEAN
OF SOCIAL WORK OUT AND BRING
MARK COLLEGE IN THESE PROVIDED
MENTORSHIP TO GENERATIONS OF
STUDENTS.
FACULTY MEMBERS AND COLLEAGUES
IN HIS ABSENCE WILL BE FELT
THROUGHOUT THE BRIMAR COMMUNITY
AND PHILADELPHIA WHERE HE HAS
LIVED.
THE LAST MANY YEARS AND
OBVIOUSLY BY HIS FAMILY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
RAMOS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
TERESA THEIR DAUGHTER ALEXIS AND
HIS SISTER ROSALYN ALBERT ST
DRAWN SKI MEMBERS I ASKED WE
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY.
OF RAMEN ALBERT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
.
IT'S CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND JOINT RESEARCH TO A THE
FILE NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE TO
HEAR.
AB SEVEN FORTY EIGHTEEN ON
FRIDAY AUGUST THIRTY FIRST AT
NINE THIRTY A. M. IN ROOM
[inaudible]
ONE TWENTY SIX WITHOUT OBJECTION.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I'M
RESCINDING MY PREVIOUS REFERRAL
OF AB SEVEN FORTY EIGHTEEN TO
PRIVACY AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE AND ARE WE REFERRING
THE BILL TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE.
SCHOLAR YOU ARE RECOGNIZED I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND THE RULES TO ALLOW SOME
MEMBER LOW MOAN TO TAKE UP AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY FOUR WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF CONCURRENT SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
IS WALDRON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED WE
OPPOSE THE WAR MOTION ON US FOR
ALL CALL.
OKAY MISS WALDRON OBJECTS. TO
CALDERON MOVES MISTER GIPSON
SECONDS.
THAT THE RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE
MEMBERS.
CLICK WELL BELOW.
MEMBERS THE PROCEDURAL VOTES
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE MISS WALDRON IS ASKING
FOR NO THE CLIP WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE.
ICE FIFTY ONE KNOWS.
TWENTY FIVE WHEELS ARE TO A
SUSPENDED
.
WE ARE MOVING NOW TO AB TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY FOUR MISTER CLERK
PLEASE READ.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
FOUR BY SOME WOMEN WILL BE MORE
THAN OTHERS AND I BELIEVE THE
PUBLIC RESOURCES.
SOME EMBLEM ON THINK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY FOUR IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THE BILL BUILT ON
THE PREMISE THAT ACCESS TO OUR
PARKS BEACHES AND PUBLIC
RESEARCH THEY SHOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO EVERYONE TO ENJOY
REGARDLESS OF THERE'S A CODE.
SENATE AMENDMENTS CREEK TO SUB
ACCOUNTS RELATED TO BE JACKSON
HOLLISTER RANCH IN SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY.
THESE ACCOUNTS ARE NOT
APPROPRIATED AND REQUIRE FUTURE
LEGISLATIVE ACTION THIS BILL
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN PART
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE SENATE
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTES.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK.
THE CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR QUIRK YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY
FIVE NO NINETEEN THE MEASURE
PASSES MR CAO.
THE SENATE MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED
IN SOME EVER CALDERON.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX TO
WITHDRAW SB FIVE A TO PORTANTINO
FROM TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
IN ORDER TO BUILD A THIRD
READING FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER
.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL ON AN ITEM ONE FORTY
EIGHT SP.
TO NINETY EIGHT THE CLERK WILL
POST.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE.
EYES TWENTY SIX KNOWS THIRTY THE
MEASURE FAILS [inaudible]
THE REASON.
SOME MEMBER ROBERT WEBER REQUEST
RECONSIDERATION.
I AM PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL
ON FILE ITEM OF ONE SIXTY NINE
SP TEN FOURTEEN THE CLERK WILL
POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS OUR ALL
MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TELLING THE VOTES.
I AM A AYE AYES FORTY THREE
KNOWS.
TWENTY TWO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR DOES ANY MEMBER
WISH TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING ON THE CLERK
WILL READ THE SECOND A CONCERT.
SO ME JOINT RESOLUTION FIFTY TWO
BY SOME WOMEN RECALL ANOTHER
SUPERLATIVES VIETNAM.
THANK YOU THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE ON THE CONSENT.
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE ON THE I WONDER ALL MEMBERS
VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING THE VOTES I SEVENTY
THREE NO.
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED [inaudible]
OKAY KERKORIAN.
SOME JOINT RESOLUTION.
FORTY FOUR I SEVENTY THREE NO.
ZERO MEMBERS UPON ADJOURNMENT.
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
WILL BE MEETING IN ROW FORTY TWO
OH TWO UPON ADJOURNMENT OF SO.
SESSION FORCE THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS BOARD
MEETING TOMORROW AUGUST THIRTY
FIRST AT TEN A. M..
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION TO
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED AND WE
WILL NOW MOVE.
TO THE REMAINING ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY.
MEMBERS WE DO HAVE AN ADDITIONAL
ADJOURNMENT MEMORY THE CLUB
QUORUM CALL HAS BEEN LIFTED.
PLEASE EITHER TAKE A SEAT AT
YOUR DESK OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR
.
MR BROKE PLEASE LOG IN JUST A
MOMENT WHILE WE GET.
ORDER IN THE IN THE CHAMBER
WHILE WE DO THAT.
I MISS GARCIA YOUR RECOGNIZE
THAT YOU'RE JUST FOR A VOTE
CHANGE.
YES VOTE CHANGE AB. THIRTY ONE
FORTY TO THE FROM THE NO TWO I
VOTE CHANGE GARCIA ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY ONE FORTY THREE NO TO AYE.
THEY CAN DISCUSS UNITS GONZALEZ
FLETCHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
VOTE CHANGE.
AJ ARE FORTY FOUR RIGHT NOW.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER SOME JOINT
RESOLUTION FORTY FOUR I TO KNOW.
BANKING IS GONZALEZ FLETCHER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN JOURNEY
MEMORY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR OF A
CHANGE THANK YOU ITEM. TWO
THIRTY SEVEN NO TO NOT VOTING.
FRIEDMAN SENATE BILL TWO THIRTY
SEVEN NO TO NOT VOTING.
MAKING HIS FRIEDMAN.
MEMBERS ARE IN RETURN TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
OF MISS REMAIN YOU HAVE
ADDITIONAL DON'T CHANGE YOUR
RECOGNIZED I'M SORRY IT WAS FILE
NUMBERED NOT THE SENATE BILL
NUMBER IT WAS AN ASSEMBLY BILL
AND I DON'T HAVE A NUMBER.
BECAUSE BEEN A CORRECTION
MYSTERY MILLION WE'VE THE STATE
THE BILL NUMBER PLEASE
[inaudible] ONE MOMENT
[inaudible] THIRTY SEVEN THIRTY
SEVEN MAYBE IT IS.
IT'S REASONABLE WILL MOVE TO
ADJOURNMENTS VERY WELL AND WILL
COME BACK TO YOU.
IT IS I'M SORRY IT IS SENATE
BILL TWO THIRTY SEVEN NO TO NOT
VOTING THANK YOU [inaudible]
YEAH.
FRIEDMAN SENATE BILL TWO THIRTY
SEVEN NOTES ARE NOT VOTING.
TAKING ANY ADDITIONAL VOTE
CHANGES REQUESTS.
CNN MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS ARE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
STERN GROVE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMBER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IT'S
WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT I ASKED
WE ADJOURN THE MEMORY OF BE
MILLER OF DANA POINT.
BE IN HER HUSBAND BOB WE'RE ONE
OF THE ORIGINAL PROPRIETORS IN
THE DANA POINT HARBOR.
WHEN THEY BLOCK THE COFFEE
IMPORTERS IN THE SEVENTIES?
AS A FAMILY.
THEY MADE IT INTO A THRIVING
BUSINESSES TODAY PATTERNING
AFTER THE COFFEE SHOPS THE
MILLERS ENJOYED DURING THEIR
TRAVELS IN EUROPE. FOR THIRTY
NINE YEARS P. MILLER HAS BEEN A
LIGHT OUR COMMUNITY WEALTHY
WELCOMING THOSE WHO VISIT THE
DANA POINT HARBOR WITH OUR KIND
HOSPITALITY.
BE RETIRED IN NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR LEAVING THE BUSINESS
OPERATIONS TO HER SON JIM.
BUT SHE WAS ALWAYS IN THE
BACKGROUND WAS OFTEN SEEN ON THE
PATIO SIPPING COFFEE WHILE
ENJOYING THE REALIZATION OF
THEIR DREAMS.
BE PASSED AWAY ON AUGUST
THIRTEENTH KNOWING THAT JIM WILL
CONTINUE THE VISION THE
ESTABLISHED THIRTY NINE YEARS
AGO.
AS THE SMALL EUROPEAN CAFE
CONTINUES AS A LANDMARK NOT ONLY
IN THE DATA POINT HARPER.
BUT THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY OF
ORANGE SHE WILL BE TRULY MISSED
BUYER FAMILY CLOSE FRIENDS AND
COUNTLESS OTHERS WHO HAVE BEEN
TOUCHED BY OUR HOSPITALITY.
AND PASSION FOR A GATHERING
PLACE AT THE WATER'S EDGE OUR
THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS ARE WITH
THE MILLER FAMILY DURING THIS
DIFFICULT TIME.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER BRO.
MEMBER PLEASE MEMBERS PLEASE
BRING THE NAMES TO THE DESK TO
BE PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL REQUESTS TO JOIN IN MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED AND RETAIN ALL MOTIONS
SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION.
I AM OUT OF BUSINESS
.
MR REPEAT ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASS AND
RETAIN ALMOST AND SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEN IN HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS I AM READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. TO ADJOURN.
MEMBERS I WANNA BE VERY CLEAR
YOU MAY STILL MAKE A VOTE CHANGE
AFTER WE ADJOURN I ASK FOR YOUR
WITH PATIENTS BY WEEK AND THIS
MEETING.
MISTER COOLEY MOVES [inaudible]
DALY SECONDS.
THAT THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED.
AND THIS HOUSE STANDS IN RECESS
UNTIL FRIDAY AUGUST THIRTY FIRST
AT TEN AM.
MEMBERS WERE INJURED